Was möchte mir Windows mitteilen?
Ah ja, okay.
Windows-Logik.
Verstehe.
Ich habe OneDrive nicht, äh, ich bin in OneDrive nicht angemeldet.
Das ist natürlich eine Security-Issue, ganz klar.
Natürlich.
Was auch sonst?
Meine Maus geht nicht.
Geht meine Maus nicht.
Wartet mal.
Ich hoffe, OBS geht noch.
Sehr schön.
Oh, schon direkt hier.
Sub am Start.
Das ging ja instant.
Wen haben wir denn hier?
Ähm, den HS-Yohi, Stufe 1, drei Monate am Start.
Dankeschön.
Huge Sub.
Du warst aber saumäßig schnell.
Das ist ja fast schon das Gegenstück, wie man auf YouTube früher gesagt hat, die Abo-Box-Camper.
Das ist hier dein Twitch-Channel.
Du warst ja direkt am Start.
Instant.
Erst mal ein bisschen Zeug ausschalten.
Meine USV ist übrigens verreckt.
Ich habe sie auf Twitter geschrieben.
Aber, ähm,
das Ding lässt sich auch nicht wieder in Gang setzen.
Ich habe es jetzt aufgeladen.
Zwei Tage ohne was dran.
Und es geht an, aber macht komische Geräusche.
Wir haben halt alles am Start schon hier.
Der RealRenax ist da.
Crash, Fluffy,
ähm, HS-Yohi, der auch gerade gesappt hat.
Wir haben Magi111.
Der Netto-Assi ist auch am Start.
Ähm, ich zeige euch, was ich für ein USV habe.
Und zwar,
äh, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es sich lohnt.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es sich lohnt.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es sich lohnt, dass ich mir...
...your orders...
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es sich lohnt, dass ich eine neue Batterie kaufe.
Cyberpower?
Ich zeige euch mal meine USV, die ich hier am Start habe.
Das... das Ding hier.
So.
Guckt mal.
Also, dieses Ding hat schon mal einen äußerst griffigen Produktnamen, muss man sagen, ne?
OR600ELCDRM1U.
Alles klar.
Das ist wirklich Next Level Produktname.
Also, wie auch immer.
Ich meine, das hat schon alles seinen Sinn, ja?
Also, OR, keine Ahnung.
Das hier ist, ähm, die... die Leistung von dem Ding.
Das da ist keine Ahnung.
Und das da ist Rack-Mount, äh, eine Höheneinheit.
Aber, ähm, ich hätte im Leben nicht gedacht, dass die USV mal das ist...
Ähm, warum mein Zeug hier daheim abkackt.
Ich meine, es war nicht weiter wild.
Das ist halt abgekackt.
Und ich hab, ich hab...
Jetzt ergibt es bei mir auch alles Sinn, ne?
Ähm, jetzt ergibt es bei mir auch irgendwie alles Sinn.
Ich hab nämlich letztens drüben bei mir im Bett gelegen, abends.
Und irgendwann so um, keine Ahnung, 23.30 Uhr oder so.
Ich hab schon, ich hab schon mehr oder weniger gepennt.
Und auf einmal hab ich es piepsen gehört.
Und ich dachte mir so, hä?
Was war das? Hast du irgendwie ein YouTube-Video auf dem Tablet laufen?
Oder, oder was, was ist das?
Bin ich aufgewacht, hab geguckt.
Es kam irgendwie aus dem Schrank.
Ist ja ein Arsch-Schwachsinn.
Es kam wahrscheinlich von der Straße.
Hat sich nur so angehört, als käme es aus dem Schrank.
Ähm, im Nachhinein ergibt das Sinn.
Das war die USV.
Das war die USV, die wahrscheinlich gepiepst hat.
So nach dem Motto, ich bin kurz vorm Verrecken.
Und nachdem das aus dem Schrank kam, ist auch klar.
Weil, ähm, in meinem Schlafzimmer steht der Schrank an der Wand.
Wo im Arbeitszimmer quasi dann schräg gegenüber das Rack steht mit der USV.
Ähm, und...
Was hatte deine Heizungs...
Deine Heizungspumpe fest und ausdehnungsge...
Ich weiß es noch nicht.
Der Heizungsman ist morgen am Start.
Das ist sehr merkwürdig.
Es geht mal und mal geht es nicht.
Ich vermute mal wirklich, dass es irgendwo in irgendeiner Art und Weise undicht ist.
Weil man muss halt permanent Wasser nachfüllen.
Können wir uns mal I Chinga...
Wie spricht man das eigentlich aus, diese Nagios-Frog-Geschichte anschauen?
Wir könnten uns das anschauen.
Warum kann ich den Skype nicht ausschalten?
Warum habe ich Skype überhaupt noch installiert?
war ja auf der 4 HE Kiste schon gar nichts mehr in Betrieb, deswegen im Endeffekt, ich habe jetzt einfach umgestöpselt, ich habe umgestöpselt alles, was an der USV angeschlossen war, das war mehr oder weniger nur die Steckdosenleiste im Rack und habe es jetzt halt an die Steckdose angeschlossen, es geht wieder, so und wo ich mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher bin ist, also das ist das Ding hier, das ist die USV, die ist auch schon ein bisschen älter, aber ich meine bei USV tut sich nicht allzu viel,
die USV ist glaube ich Release Date 2013 oder so, aber who cares, was juckt mich, wann die USV rausgekommen ist, die funktioniert ganz gut, allerdings, die Batterien sind wahrscheinlich im Arsch, weil ich habe es jetzt 2 Tage aufgeladen ohne was dran und wenn ich es jetzt einschalte, dann geht zumindest wieder das Display an, das Ding piepst halt wie verrückt, dass die Batterie leer ist, das heißt also, das ist im Arsch die Batterie,
ich weiß jetzt nicht so genau, ob sich das lohnt, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht so genau, ob sich das lohnt, mir eine neue Batterie zu kaufen, was kostet denn sowas, Batterie, oh ja, die USV hat leider kein RGB, was ja schon mal 50% der Leistungsfähigkeit ausmacht, da sind wir uns ja einig,
übrigens Leute, wisst ihr, wie man Google auf Afrikanisch ausspricht, ich gucke gleich mal nach der Batterie, ich muss euch mal was cooles zeigen,
wartet mal, das ist zu geil, ich muss die Musik ausmachen, das ist zu geil,
L, I, I, GULUGULU, zu geil, GULUGULU,
falls ihr von immer verwisst wollt, wie man Google auf Afrikanisch ausspricht, ich könnte mir das echt den ganzen Tag reinhören,
GULUGULU,
das ist so geil,
ich wundere mich, ganz ehrlich, warum hat das Video nicht mehr Views, das ist eigentlich so ein Video, das müsste man eigentlich,
50 Millionen oder so haben,
GULUGULU,
weißt du, wie man in the beginning of Afrikaans ausspricht, keine Ahnung, was soll ich das wissen,
Moin, kannst du das Asrock J5005ETX empfehlen, ja, das ist ja mehr oder weniger das, was ich in meiner aktuellen Kiste,
Surferkiste auch drin hab, wo ich die, ich hatte ja vorher so einen fetten 4HE, 8 Kern Xeon Ding rumstehen,
und jetzt hab ich auch sowas ähnliches hier,
also ich hab jetzt ja einen J41 Ding, das ist die kleine Variante von dem, was du da rausgesucht hast, das hab ich jetzt aktuell als Board in meiner Surferkiste,
äh, brauch so gut wie keinen Strom, hat jetzt auch nicht die Wahnsinnsleistung, allerdings mehr als so einen Raspberry Pi wahrscheinlich jemals haben wird,
und das ist nicht schlecht, das ist nicht schlecht, ich mein, du schreibst, du willst das für einen Proximox Surfer haben,
da ist natürlich die Frage, wie viele?
5VMs willst du drauflaufen lassen, wie viel Leistung soll das Ganze haben?
Also, äh, Proximox Surfer installieren kannst du da mit Sicherheit easy drauf, das wird auch ohne jegliche Probleme funktionieren,
wenn du da jetzt allerdings, ähm, 5-6VMs draufhaben willst, die ordentlich Leistung brauchen, dann geht das natürlich nicht, ne.
Aber wenn's einfach nur zum Probieren ist, klar, das sind, das sind ziemlich gute Boards, ich weiß gar nicht, wie's mit der Nachfolgegeneration von diesen Dingern aktuell aussieht,
aber man muss wohl auch bei vollen Gewässern von der acidic Basic die Energie wiederholen und die Nahrungершützigkeit nicht zu mehr 걸ben.
Guck mal mal, ob es da bald' was gibt, GT panic…
Die gibt's schon.
Aber wahrscheinlich gibt's da kein… wahrscheinlich gibt's keine Mainboard, ne,
er ist wie hörsten die Hälfte dinger?
Wer ist da schon Mainboards центр 1?
N412?
Ach nee, das ist der,
also gibt es da wahrscheinlich keine.
Ja, hab ich Panda auf marble-Bitart.que.
Jetzt, my god, gibt es mir bestimmt.
bisher. Gibt irgendwelche
Notebook-Dinger und so.
Ich will wissen, wie da wirklich
wann der echte Nachfolger kommt.
Skyhaw Lake?
Jasper Lake?
Kann sich Intel mal irgendwie überlegen,
wie sie ihren Kram nennen, dass ich noch durchblicke?
Das ist mir
zu big brain, die Intel-CPU-Benahmung.
Elkhart Lake?
Ja, was denn nu?
Ich blick nicht mal durch.
Das ist mir einfach...
Ich ignoriere das jetzt, bis es raus ist.
So, was kostet denn hier eine Batterie für meine
OSV?
Oh ja, ein bisschen Chat übersehen.
Ähm...
Ich habe mir ein Tool installiert,
in dem man Windows-App
rausschmeißen kann. MSMG
kann ich dir empfehlen.
Was?
Hä?
Ich habe mir ein Tool installiert, in dem
man Windows-App rausschmeißen kann.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
was du mir sagen möchtest.
Ich verstehe es sogar, leuchtet mir gerade nicht ein.
Max, was hattest du eigentlich
als Thema in der Abschlussarbeit?
Ich habe ein Layer 2 VPN
gebaut für Telefone.
Mit OpenVPN.
OpenVPN
an zwei Standorten mit
zwei 1HE-IBM-Servern
verbunden per Layer 2 OpenVPN
und habe dann
Telefone, IP-Telefone
an die Telefonanlage angebunden.
Quasi über das Layer 2 VPN,
so als wären sie direkt im gleichen
Gebäude drin.
Hast du schon den neuen PC von MontanaBlack gesehen?
Ne, wollen wir uns das mal angucken.
MontanasBlack, neuer Ultimate PC.
Okay, MontanaBlack hat mit dem PC so viel zu tun, wie, äh,
keine Ahnung, Michael Schumacher mit irgendwie Snickers.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob der jemals Snickers-Werbung gemacht hat, aber.
Wie viel Watt braucht das Teil mit meiner Config?
Kann ich dir sagen. Ich drehe mich mal um.
13,8, gerade.
13,8, das ist mit 10 Gigabit-Netzwerkkarte drinne,
einer 12 Terabyte und einer 12 Terabyte, äh, HDD.
Die natürlich runtergefahren ist, ne, gerade.
Wenn die anfährt, dann brauchst du ein bissl mehr.
Okay, was ist das hier?
Mythcom.
Das ist irgendwie unglücklicher Name, oder?
Mythcom präsentiert Montana Blacks neuer Ultimate PC.
Na gut, dann schauen wir mal.
Ja, Flo96, da habe ich auch dran gedacht. Der Name ist irgendwie unglücklich.
Okay, die machen schon mal ordentlich Kraft.
Warum genau zeigen die mir ne PS4, PS4, äh, Disc,
wenn es ein Ultimate PC ist?
Bereits zum dritten Mal haben wir die Ehre, Montana Blacks PC entwickeln zu dürfen.
Wir haben die Ehre. Welch Ehre? Ich darf einen PC bauen und einen Namen draufschreiben?
Krass, krasse Ehre.
Ich will nicht wissen, was das kostet, Alter.
Das ist nicht umsonst.
Also, es ist, also, was ich meine ist, es ist nicht so, dass, also, die müssen dafür ja was bezahlen, ne.
Das ist bestimmt nicht günstig.
Das liegt aber auch daran, weil jetzt natürlich alle Fanboys hingehen und sagen dem Motto, äh, Papa, Papa, ich will Montana Blacks PC.
Das Ziel, etwas ganz Besonderes schaffen.
Nicht nur den besten Stream-PC der Welt bauen.
Der Sprecher muss da aber auch ganz nah an das Mikrofon ran, dass das besonders männlich klingt.
Sondern noch eins draufsetzen.
Und ich glaube, das haben wir geschafft.
Okay, mal gucken, was da drin ist.
Hi, ich bin Manu, zuständig für euch, die Community und die Videos hier bei Miffcom.
Wir arbeiten schon seit einiger Zeit in einem geheimen Projekt, das ich euch heute endlich zeigen werde.
Und zwar Montes neuer PC.
Es ist ein wassergekühltes 4K-Gaming, Streaming und Schnittmonster.
Und zwar mit einer kleinen Besonderheit, aber dazu später mehr.
Für brachiale Leistungen sorgen die 32 Kerne des brandneuen AMD Threadripper 3000.
Aber das ist halt ne ordentliche CPU.
Warum ist das so leise? Ist das, ach, ist das zu leise? Ich kann das, kann das ruhig lauter machen.
Ähm, dachte, das wäre laut genug.
Das ist natürlich ne ordentliche CPU.
Allerdings rein zum Spielen ist es natürlich einmal Overkill und wahrscheinlich sogar ein Ticken langsamer als CPUs mit nicht ganz so viel Kern.
Aber wenn du damit auch Videos schneiden sollst und rendern und so, warum nicht? Kann man machen.
Wir haben uns für diesen Prozessor entschieden, da er nicht nur viele Kerne bietet, sondern auch eine starke Single-Core-Performance.
Er kann in Games bis zu 4,5 GHz boosten und ist somit der perfekte Allrounder für Gaming und Videoproduktion.
Schlechtes Ding nicht.
Die CPU kostet halt irgendwie nur 1.500 Euro oder sowas.
Aber er schneidet doch selber keine Videos. Ja und?
Da geht's doch bei dem PC nicht drum.
Ein paar Tabs zu viel offen.
Deswegen haben wir seine Ghetto My Level Edition mit 128 GB RAM versorgt.
Es handelt sich dabei um Corsair Dominator Platinum Sticks.
Für ordentlich Grafik-Power sorgen gleich zwei RTX 2080 Ti's.
Die feuern ein Raytracing-Feuerwerk ab, das hier vorteilt.
Spiel, das kein SLE Support hat, kann er immer noch die zweite Grafikkarte benutzen, um z.B.
in OBS den Stream damit zu encodieren.
Äh, das kann man auch so, da braucht man keine zweite Grafikkarte für, das hat eigentlich
mit dem einen überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Also du kannst ohne Probleme den Encoder verwenden, wenn du gerade was spielst, das eine und das
andere hat wenig miteinander zu tun.
Oh, allein schon das Mainboard kostet wahrscheinlich 700€.
Und dann, genau, dann spielt der Fortnite in 1080p.
Ich finde es ja, muss ich ja, hab ich schon öfters gesagt, ich finde es ja mittlerweile
voll grotesk, ne?
Das SSD ist schon ein passendes System.
Ich finde es ja, muss ich ja, hab ich schon öfters gesagt, ich finde es ja mittlerweile
voll grotesk, ne?
Und dann, genau, dann spielt der Fortnite in 1080p.
Passivkühler braucht er.
Zusammen 6TB und jedes dieser Module kann mit bis zu 4.950 Km.
Kann man dann, kann man dann, äh, kann man dann Casino Slots in 80K spielen?
Und um das Ganze auf eine runde Zahl zu bringen, haben wir noch 4TB an normalen Storage-SSD's
verbaut.
Damit diesem Hightech-System nie der Saft ausgeht, haben wir Corsairs AX1600i Netzteil
sage und schreibe 1,6 Kilowatt
an Strom. Aber jetzt
zur Optik. Warum sieht dieser PC so
heftig aus?
Also mir gefällt er nicht.
Also mir gefällt die Optik nicht.
Man kann jetzt nicht sagen, das Ding ist hässlich
oder so, aber für mich
muss ein PC nicht glänzen.
Ich meine,
Styling ist das sicherlich ziemlich
gut gemacht.
Und das Ding sieht auch so aus, als wäre es handwerklich gut gemacht.
Aber mir gefallen tut er mir nicht.
Mein PC sieht halt
ganz normal aus. Schwarze Kiste.
Und was für mich ja schon
Hightech ist, dass ich da ein Glasfenster
nebendran habe, anstatt einfach ein schwarzes
Gehäuse.
Das liegt vor allem an Corsairs brandneuen
QL-Lüftern. Von denen haben wir 10 Stück
verbaut und jeder einzelne Lüfter
hat 34 RGBs.
Das Problem davon ist, dass
man diese Crap IQ Software laufen
lassen muss. Der Name
hat, also
dass das Ding IQ heißt, ist ja schon
komplette Verspottung.
Von Big Brain Leuten, weil die Software
ist absolut nicht High IQ.
Die braucht 5%
CPU Leistung im Hintergrund permanent
für nichts.
3?
What?
Habe ich das richtig gehört?
340 LEDs nur vor den Lüftern.
Das gibt natürlich
nochmal 30% Boost.
Tro M, 2 Monate Twitch Prime. Dankeschön.
Huge, huge sub.
Samus Climber.
Aus den Gehäuse-LEDs haben wir eine zentrale Software, nämlich IQ.
Oh Gott, Crap, abso...
Oh, diese Software.
Ich hab's wieder... Ich war so froh,
als ich mein Corsair, also als ich die K95
ausgewechselt hab,
gegen ein aktuelles Logitech-Keyboard.
Ich war so froh, dass ich diese IQ-Software
deinstallieren konnte. Das könnt ihr euch nicht vorstellen.
...wählen wie Regen
oder Visier.
Visier?
Wer aber keine Lust hat auf Presets, der kann sich auch selber Custom-Profiles erstellen.
Das haben auch wir getan und so Montes Design erschaffen.
Das... Ich bin mir noch nicht sicher.
Ist das so ein reines Prestige-Ding?
Ist das so ein reines Prestige-Ding für Mifcom,
wo die sich denken, okay,
wir können damit Werbung machen, aber kaufen wird's keiner?
Oder ist das so ein Ding, wo man wirklich von ausgeht, dass das so die
Ultra-Hardcore-Fanboys kaufen?
Ich bin mir da nicht so ganz sicher.
Dom... Dom-PC.
Drei Monate lang schon.
Sam... Samus Climber!
Aber ihr fragt euch bestimmt schon seit dem Intro,
was hat das mit dem PlayStation-Game auf sich?
Wir haben eine PS4 Pro Custom-Wasser gekühlt
und in Montana Blacks PC integriert.
Nahtlos und mit sämtlichen Anschlüssen und dem Laufwerk.
Die Wasser...
Warum?
Die Wasserkühlung sorgt dafür, dass die Konsole flüsterleise läuft.
Und die Lautstärke ist eine Sache,
die Montana schon öfters an der PlayStation gestört hat.
Aber meine Kollegen haben sich gesagt, das reicht immer noch nicht.
Wir bei Mifcom haben hohe Ansprüche.
Jetzt kommt noch eine Xbox dabei, hä?
... sind die langen Ladezeiten.
Deswegen haben wir diese PlayStation noch zusätzlich mit einer 4TB SSD veredelt.
Na komm, jetzt hättet ihr zumindest noch eine Switch und eine Xbox einbauen können,
wenn ihr da schon mal dabei seid.
Damit Montana Black die PS4 in seine Streams einbinden kann,
muss er sie an einem PC capturen.
Also war es naheliegend, gleich ein Capture-System in diesen PC zu integrieren.
Unsere Wahl fiel dabei auf Elgatos 4K60 Pro MK2.
Dieses Biest kann nicht nur 4K capturen, sondern das auch...
Dieses Biest?
Warum ist das jetzt in...
Naja...
Ich mein, die Capture-Cut ist nicht übel.
... 240 FPS.
Und nachdem selbst HDR von ihr unterstützt wird,
ist die bestmöglichste Aufnahme- und Streamqualität gesichert.
Wir wollten Montana die bestmögliche Streaming-Hardware bieten.
Und das Ganze sollte auch noch in einem schicken System integriert sein,
ohne großes Kabelverhauen.
Wenn ihr findet, das hat einen Daumen nach oben verdient,
dann würden wir uns sehr über einen Like freuen.
Was ich ja cool finde, dass bei dem ganzen Deal noch nicht mal drinne war,
dass Montana Black selber ein Wort oder so dazu sagt.
... um uns wissen, was ihr super findet am Ultimate PC...
Und es war wahrscheinlich trotzdem teuer genug.
... und was ihr komplett anders gemacht hättet.
Ihr merkt schon sicherlich, wir haben sehr viel Herzblut in dieses Projekt gesteckt.
Vor allem Kohle!
Und ich könnte noch Stunden lang weiter über diesen PC erzählen.
Aber, Monte wartet schon auf die Rakete
und ihr seid bestimmt auch schon gespannt, wie das aussieht,
wenn er das erste Mal mit dem neuen PC live geht.
Deswegen bedanke ich mich fürs Zuschauen
und ich freu mich auf das nächste Video mit euch.
Bis dahin. Ciao.
Ich mein, die Specs sind natürlich nicht übel.
Aber das ist keine Kunst.
Einfach das Teuerste nehmen, was es gibt und einbauen.
Gleich Kaya Jahren.
Gleich Kaya Jarnas 20k...
Moment...
Was?
Kaya Jarnas 20...
Gibt's den noch?
Ich hab von Kaya Jarnas irgendwie die letzten 15 Jahre nix merkt.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass der noch in irgendeiner Art und Weise in Erscheinung tritt.
Ich wollte gucken, was meine USV-Batterie kostet übrigens.
Seit 20 Minuten oder so.
Was, der streamt auf Twitch?
Okay.
Entweder geht er mit der Zeit oder es hat keinen Fernsehsender mehr Bock.
Was soll der Spaß kosten?
Ja, was kostet der Spaß?
Weiß man nicht.
Aber wenn ich das mal so überschlage...
Ich mein, allein schon die Grafikkarten kosten, keine Ahnung, 3000 Euro.
Die CPU kostet irgendwie auch nochmal 1500.
Das Mainboard kostet irgendwie 700.
Das ist schon 5000.
Dann der RAM irgendwie nochmal, keine Ahnung, 7000.
Wahrscheinlich kostet der 15.000, okay.
10k kostet das.
10k ohne PS4 mit PS4 15k.
Warum macht das eine PS4 5000 Euro teurer?
What the fuck?
Ja, wahrscheinlich müssen die die Kosten irgendwie reinbekommen.
Die sagten das, was der Deal gekostet hat.
So, was kostet eine Batterie?
50 Euro.
Okay, dann lohnt sich das doch tatsächlich, eine neue Batterie für meine USV zu kaufen.
Aber schon übelst teuer, ja.
Weil integriert, jebaited.
4 TB SSD ist nicht günstig.
Ja, aber nicht so teuer, 700 Euro oder so.
Oh doch, guck mal, ist doch viel günstiger geworden mittlerweile.
Also günstig, jebaited günstig.
Also günstig nicht wirklich, aber günstiger als ich gedacht habe.
Ist doch okay.
420 Euro für 1 TB SSD.
Ich habe vor ein paar Jahren, was kostet denn die Evo?
Stimmt, guck mal, was die Evo kostet.
Ich habe mir vor ein paar Jahren eine 2 TB Evo geholt für damals noch 700 Euro.
Da war das ganz neu.
Total beknackt eigentlich.
Die habe ich jetzt immer noch.
Aber war eigentlich viel zu viel Geld.
Kannst du die USV empfehlen?
Ja, prinzipiell schon.
Mit der Ausnahme halt, dass die USV kaputt gegangen ist.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob man das der USV anlasten kann.
Dass die Batterie nach irgendwie 5 Jahren mal kaputt geht oder so, ist okay.
Was ich nicht verstehe ist, warum geht die ganze USV aus,
wenn die Batterie leer geht, obwohl der Strom noch an ist.
Ich vermute mal, das ist ein konstruktionsbedingtes Problem.
Dass wahrscheinlich die ganzen Rechner, die dranhängen,
nie quasi, also immer durch die Batterie gespeist werden.
Die Batterie gleichzeitig geladen wird oder so.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Designproblem von dem Ding ist.
Ob das bei anderen USVs in der Einsteigerklasse besser ist.
Weil normalerweise hätte ich jetzt eigentlich erwartet,
solange das am Netz hängt und das funktioniert,
dann geht die USV nie aus, auch wenn die Batterie kaputt ist.
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich irgendein konstruktionsbedingtes Problem.
Das an sich kann ich dir empfehlen, die hat jetzt 5 Jahre super funktioniert.
Dass wenn die Batterie kaputt geht, aber einfach der Kram ausgeht,
ist ein bisschen doof, obwohl der Strom am Netz ja da ist.
Was macht der neue Serverraum? Kommt dazu noch ein Video?
Ja, da mache ich wahrscheinlich wirklich ein Video zu.
Moment, wo habe ich das passiert?
Moment, wo habe ich das passende Emote?
Ne, also ich mache da wahrscheinlich wirklich ein Video zu,
aber da ist noch nicht viel umgebaut.
Black Mesa zu Ende spielen, das letzte Level ist kacke.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich euch das zumuten soll.
Also das muss man ja sagen, der End-Boss-Fight in Black Mesa ist gut,
aber die 1-2 Levels davor sind nicht gut.
Und die ziehen sich viel zu lange.
Das Video zum Server auf der Arbeit, ja das haben wir aufgenommen,
aber ich habe es jetzt halt noch rumliegen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sich das im günstigen Segment so sehr unterscheidet.
Ich habe ja eine APC-USV.
Ich habe ja beides.
Die habe ich aber gerade nicht angeschlossen, die APC-USV.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sich das im günstigen Segment so unterscheidet.
Ich meine, Marken-Fanboy zu sein allein bringt ja nichts.
Vielleicht ist das einfach eine konstruktionsbedingte Eigenschaft im Low-Budget-USV-Bereich,
dass die Dinge halt nicht umschalten so richtig.
Sondern die Geräte immer aus der Batterie speisen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das intern funktioniert,
aber das ist der einzige Grund, wie ich mir erklären kann,
dass trotz funktionierendem Strom das ganze Rack ausgegangen ist.
Ah ja.
So.
Was wollen wir denn zuerst gucken?
Also wir haben zur Auswahl...
Wir haben zur Auswahl Crazy-Sniper-Clips Battlefield 3.
Wird mal wieder Zeit.
Ach ja übrigens, es haben 14 Leute was eingeschickt.
Das können wir uns nachher auch noch angucken.
Denkt dran, wenn ihr...
Ich zeige euch das mal im Chat.
Wenn ihr richtig geile Battlefield-Clips habt...
Ich habe vor, eine Battlefield-Top-Plays-Montage-Video zu machen.
So mit 10 Minuten.
Und es haben 14 Leute was eingeschickt.
Davon war dreimal ich zum Testen.
Also sagen wir mal, 11 Leute haben was eingeschickt.
Davon waren ein paar Clips dabei, die fand ich jetzt nicht so gut.
Aber auch ein paar richtig geile.
Es reicht aber noch nicht ganz für ein Video.
Das heißt...
Ich bräuchte schon nochmal...
Sagen wir mal so 5-6 Clips mehr.
Richtig gute Battlefield...
Bad Company 2, Battlefield 3, Battlefield 4.
Äh...
Deswegen auch Battlefield 5 und 1 Clips.
Aber richtig gute.
Nice Gebäsche.
So 30 Sekunden bis 2 Minuten.
Ähm...
Dass ich da eine Montage draus machen kann.
Von der Hexe habe ich schon was.
Von der Hexe habe ich schon 2 Sachen.
Das heißt wenn ihr richtig geile...
Basher Battlefield Clips habt.
Dann ähm...
Könnt ihr die einschicken hier unter dem Link.
Was ich gerade gepostet habe im Chat.
Und schreibt euren Channel rein, wenn ihr verlinkt werden wolltet.
Nein Overwatch Clips gehen natürlich nicht.
Hab von Unity Media jetzt eine Gigabit Leitung.
Gibt es als Angebot.
Ich weiß...
Das da, das wollte ich mir vielleicht auch noch holen.
Weil da können ja auch die Bestandskunden umsteigen.
Ich meine...
Das Verhältnis ist schon ein bisschen Affig.
Muss man mal ehrlich sagen.
100 Down.
1000 Down.
50 Up.
Wonka Corona.
Ähm...
Ist halt ein komisches Verhältnis.
Man müsste das mal ausrechnen.
Ich vermute mal.
Dass die 50 MBit Upload.
Gerade mal für die TCP Bestätigungspakete reichen.
Bei einem 100 MBit Download.
Was kostet...
Also ich habe ja hier aktuell dieses komische.
Was habe ich denn überhaupt?
Ne, ich habe ähm...
Kombipaket.
Das da bräuchte ich dann.
Da habe ich aber überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Sternchen.
Der Preis setzt sich zusammen.
Blablabla.
So.
Was ich jetzt nicht verstehe ist.
Ah.
Da kommt noch der Kabelanschluss dabei.
Das heißt ich bin auch...
Ich bin nicht wirklich billiger als jetzt.
Ne.
50 Euro.
Da kommen nochmal 20 Euro ungefähr für den Kabelanschluss dabei.
Also bin ich bei 70...
Bei 70 Euro.
Doch es ist immer noch ein bisschen billiger.
Vorausgesetzt es gibt einen richtigen Dual-Stack-Anschluss dazu.
Weil aktuell bezahle ich ja 2x Power-Upload.
Weil sie mich gebetet haben.
Ähm...
Für einen Dual-Stack.
Ein bisschen billiger könnte es sein.
5 Euro billiger oder so.
Also richtiger Dual-Stack Braumer.
Ich brauche es aber mit Fernseher.
Nicht für mich.
Aber ohne Fernseher.
Dann müsste man das Fernseher irgendwo anders herkriegen.
Und das macht es auch nicht einfacher.
Oder...
Ich logge mich einfach nachher immer in das Kundencenter ein.
Und gucke was die mir so empfehlen.
Ok.
Komm wir gucken uns mal eine Runde Battlefield Vantage an.
Also wie gesagt.
Wenn ihr geile Battlefield Clips habt.
Macht Ausrufezeichen Battle Plays.
Im Chat.
Und dann könnt ihr euch das Video anschauen.
kill, also irgendwas cooles halt einfach
es müssen auch keine 30 Sekunden
sein, wenn das ein 20 Sekunden Clip ist, der halt richtig
geil ist, ist auch okay
aber ein paar mehr Clips
brauche ich schon noch, da ich da ein Video draus machen kann
sonst funktioniert das Ganze nicht
ok, und jetzt muss ich natürlich
die üblichen Sachen sagen, wie immer
dass der Kommentator jetzt gleich wieder das gleiche
erzählen wird
hä?
ich hab jetzt nichts gesehen, was da passiert ist
ach, noch gar nichts
NA Aim
oh nice
wie das die Gegner einfach nicht
wie das die Gegner einfach nicht interessiert hat, dass sie
beschossen werden
ist laut genug, oder soll ich ein Ticken lauter machen?
bisschen lauter, bisschen lauter können wir machen, ne?
jetzt ist es ein bisschen zu laut
jetzt haben wir doch gerade schon
ok
das erste Clip ist ein 5-Mann-Sniper-Clip mit einem Kollateral auf zwei Menschen in dem Rippenboot
jetzt, in Battlefield 1 und Battlefield 5 ist das Sniperen etwas einfacher
da war ein Kollateral dabei
ich hab bloß gesehen, dass der drei mal geschossen hat und drei Leute sind umgefallen
freust du dich auf die PS5?
ich freu mich auf die PS5, genauso wie auf die Xbox Series X
die sind so ein Scheißen haben, Microsoft, ey
insofern, dass ich hoffe, dass die Standards, was Technik angeht, dadurch wieder steigen werden
auf die Konsole selbst jetzt nicht so sehr
die aktuelle Konsolengeneration hat mich
dazu gebracht, dass mir Konsolen ziemlich wurscht sind
das Final Fantasy 7 Remake wird verkackt werden
können das nicht mehr
aber in Battlefield 3 war es sehr schwierig
und das Clip ist eines der besten, die ich je gesehen habe
auf Battlefield 3
mit einem Sniper-Rifle
jetzt werden wir auf etwas gehen, das ein bisschen mehr Infanterie-Fighter ist
das ist das Talar-Markt
das ist Azadi Palace, ok
er benutzt den G3A3
eine Waffe, die ich selten auf Battlefield 3 verwendet habe
aber nachdem ich das 5. Clip gesehen habe, habe ich es wirklich nicht verwendet
mehr wichtig, ich will auf dieses Map kommen
wie unglaublich sieht Azadi Palace all diese Jahre später aus?
die ganze Farbe-Palette des Maps
ist wirklich cool
der Fakt ist, dass es eines dieser urbanen Umgebungen ist
wo du dich um die Gegner befindest
die Vertikalität
weißt du was das coole ist an den Battlefield 3 Maps
selbst an diesen zerstörten, also die ganzen Epicenter
wie hieß das DLC? Aftermath?
DLC Maps, die waren ja alle so kaputt
trotzdem hatte dieses Spiel auf diesen Maps
eine gewisse Struktur
wo du dir überlegen konntest, von wo Gegner kommen
und wo Gegner spawnen und sowas
also was, was in Battlefield 5 teilweise
überhaupt nicht möglich ist
obwohl die Map total kaputt ist und offen
hatte die eine gewisse Struktur
die Maps waren durchdacht, ja
boah, die Map habe ich so selten gespielt
die Gegner sind wieder komplett braindead, Alter
und kriegen nix mit
da checken die nicht, dass einer neben denen steht?
anscheinend nicht
ah, die werden dann weggesplittet
der hat aber glaube ich keine Slug Ammo gehabt, oder?
oder war das 870 mit Slugs?
ne, das war ohne Slugs, oder?
je, was ist das?
PS3, PS4, es sieht, es sieht
ne, von der Auflösung her ist das wahrscheinlich PC
aber es ist sehr verschwommen
hohoho, ok
da war halt auch wieder
aber, aber er hat nicht, er hat nicht
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
er hat erwischt, oh na, ah, ah
nein, knapp, knapp
wer hätte das geklappt mit dem, mit dem Flugzeug?
das wäre geil gewesen
Vierer, da kann ich gleich was zu sagen
all of that guy's teammates with his M416
and this is a big point stack
over four and a half thousand points
I think it may be a tough spot
also, theoretisch ist die beste Waffe die M16
aber meine Lieblingswaffe ist die M416 in dem Game
5,000 Tore to the end
just incredible stuff
oje, Mario
Dienst Corona, man
Metro kannst du die Gegner
wenn, wenn du beim Metro einmal gut geflankt bist
du kannst die so wegsprayen
das ist einfach, das habe ich in keinem anderen Game
auf keiner anderen Map in dieser Art und Weise je gesehen bisher
The return of Bruno Santos
a player that I personally, as I say every time he's featured
looked suspicious
but everyone else has told me he's completely legit
he gets a lot of clips from this one position on Caspian Border
so I'm starting to feel as if he's played a lot of hours on the game
and he's just mastered this sort of long range sniping
he knows all the ranges
okay, das war Glück
also, also
ja gut, ich meine es war gut predicted
aber, dass der jetzt genau in dieser Art und Weise weiter rennt
das war schon Glück
The game was he got was a lot of clips that he's getting
enjoy a few really awesome only in battle fields
warum dreht er sich immer so verrückt um?
warum dreht er sich immer so komisch um?
A-Bot versteckt
wegen dem Score
nee, wahrscheinlich, dass er nicht gehittet wird oder so, ich weiß nicht
aber die Range hat er schon gut drin, muss man sagen
ich hätte es ja 30x vorbeigeschossen, aber ich bin ja auch kein Sniper-Man
im Battlefield
außer in Bad Company 2
Bad Company 2. Bad Company 2 ist das einzige
Game, wo ich Sniper gemaint habe.
Allerdings nicht als Sniper,
sondern als mit Sniper quickscopen
im Nahkampf.
Ego, Schritt zur Seite nach dem Schuss verstehe ich,
dass man nicht gehittet wird.
Ich meine, treffen du da schon gut, ja?
SV 98,
ja, beste.
Der cooler Feed ist das schon.
Er steht aber wahrscheinlich
sein ganzes Leben da oben
an dem einen Spot und snipert
in die Map rein.
Boah, das war nice, der war nice.
Also die Prediction war wirklich nice.
Boah, cool.
Die Gegner.
Base drop off the edge
is my favorite part, but this is a really interesting
kind of Operation Locker style
part of the map with the three lanes,
the choke points. I think it's really, really
fun. Just an awesome clip though.
Look how many kills he's got so far.
And he just continues, terrible,
the enemy team.
Irgendwie hat sich das geil angefühlt,
wenn du mit so einer Bolt-Action ohne Scope was killst.
Next up a clip
from Kravzer01,
a really epic
Prediction RPG on Operation Firestorm.
What?
Oh!
War das
predicted?
Wartet mal,
sieht er den überhaupt?
Das war im Leben
nicht predicted.
Ich meine,
vielleicht hat er,
hat er ja wirklich gedacht, ey,
der fliegt jetzt hin,
aber trotzdem, also das ist schon, da ist schon sehr viel Glück bei.
Three points under control.
Someone on his team has to break free.
Aber so Clips sind halt gerade das Geile.
So Clips sind halt gerade das Geile.
Und das sind Sachen, die halt in Battlefield 3
und 4 und Bad Company 2 auch passiert sind,
die ich so in Battlefield
1 und 5 halt nicht mal gesehen habe.
Das waren halt diese,
diese krassen Sachen, die halt nur so
in Battlefield passiert sind.
Und ungescriptet.
... exactly that,
using a mixture of his M16A3
and as you'll see, his Magnum
blasting through and creating a gap
for his team to move up.
A really awesome Clip.
Ha, ne, der lebt nicht mehr.
Oh, da stehen sie!
Alter!
WTF? Was ist mit den Gegnern los?
Seid ihr, seid ihr komplett
matt im Kopf oder was?
Die Gegner waren echt komplett
kein Los.
... und finally today we're finishing off
with two Clips from Magnite.
This guy is a very talented Battlefield
3 player, two infantry Clips that I think
you'll very much enjoy. The first he's gonna
be using the AN-94.
Close quarters action, lots of enemies
surrounding him. Fortunately for him,
two of them, as you'll see, just don't know
what's going on at all.
A delayed double with the Rex saves
him in that position as he looks to
get this objective. And just
before he manages to start capping it,
he does, eventually, get taken down.
Wie er klickert, wie er klickert, äh.
Wie schade ich die Tastatur wärste.
The second Clip he sent in is with the
SCAR-L. Once again, some close quarters
action, trying to... SCAR-L? Ich bin mir gar nicht
sicher, ob wir das Ding jemals gespielt haben, Battlefield 3.
...troll an objective, whilst being surrounded
by the enemy team. A lot of kills
in a short space of time.
Das, ist das Karkant? Oder was ist das für ne Map?
... ist das Karkant? Oder was ist das für ne Map?
Ja, ich glaub schon.
Ob das ist Karkant?
Karkant.
Bam. Wegschneiden.
Thanks for watching this episode of the Battlefield 3 Top Plays.
If you did enjoy, leave a like down below.
If you didn't, feel free to leave a dislike.
Remember to send your clips in to battlefieldtopplays
at gmail.com, and I'll catch you
in the next episode. Ja, wie gesagt, wenn ihr bei mir
Top Plays einsenden wollt, ausrufe ich euch in Battle Plays,
und dann, wenn ich genug hab,
so 5, 6 Sachen fehlen noch, da mach ich ein Video zu.
So 5, 6 Sachen fehlen noch, da mach ich ein Video zu.
Schon neue Clips, ja wie gesagt, insgesamt hab ich 14 Stück.
Also, 11, 11 hab ich, 11 hab ich.
Drei waren ja von mir zum testen.
Das juckt mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Was hat man hier sonst noch zu bieten heute?
320 TB in a normal case.
Das wollte ich mir mal angucken, weil,
ich bastle ja selber gerne,
und ich bin da ja immer recht kritisch,
was andere Leute zusammenbasteln.
Ich mein, das ist natürlich immer nur
Show, aber
mich interessiert trotzdem, ob da was Nutzbares bei rauskommt.
Natürlich muss er,
also eins muss man Linus lassen,
die Sellout-Überleitungen sind
die besten.
Die besten auf Youtube.
Auf Twitch muss ich sagen, hat Danced Gaming
die besten Überleitungen, was Sellout angeht.
Ja, das Time to Kill Update,
ich habs ja nur am Rande mitbekommen,
weil ich Battlefield 5 nicht spiele.
Wie siehts da jetzt eigentlich aus?
Ist das jetzt wieder raus?
Oder was machen die da eigentlich?
Wenn man heute ein Battlefield
spielen möchte, wäre dann
Battlefield 3 oder 4 besser. Also, wenn du heute
ein Battlefield spielen möchtest,
dann solltest du tatsächlich, so doofs klingt,
Battlefield 5 spielen,
weil sowohl Battlefield 3 als auch Battlefield 4
haben halt nicht mehr so viele Spieler.
Battlefield 4 hat noch
deutlich mehr als Battlefield 3,
aber wenn du ein Battlefield spielen willst,
was halt aktiv gespielt wird,
musst du eigentlich Battlefield 5 reden.
Ja, Bad Company 2 hat glaube ich
noch ein oder zwei aktive Server.
Aber wir gucken mal, was sie dazu so zusammenbauen.
Mehr Platten.
Was? Was soll denn das sein?
Achso!
Das ist so ein externes
USB-Ding oder was?
So was kommt bei mir jetzt gar nicht hin.
Und USB muss man
nicht mit anderen Usern sharen.
Das ist dafür überhaupt nicht gedacht.
Du machst die Platte per USB dran
und wenn du Sachen mit anderen Usern sharen musst,
dann machst du das über eine Softwarelösung oben drüber
und nicht über USB. Fuck.
Übrigens, was wir an einem der nächsten
Streams ausprobieren müssen, ist ein aktuelles
Android auf dem Raspberry Pi 4.
Ich hab da jetzt ein paar Videos zu gesehen
und das könnte wirklich praktisch sein.
Erstmal der Sellout.
Warte, du kennst das iJustine Video nicht mit Linus.
Doch, ich glaub das hab ich irgendwann mal geguckt.
Normales Android.
Gegen den LineageOS.
Das ist das Case.
Das Case würde ich mir im Leben nicht als nass hinstellen.
Also, ich kann euch erklären warum.
Erstens, weil ich in meinen Rack
keinen Tower rein bekomme.
Ich mein,
das könnte mit Ach und Krach
19 Zoll sein.
Und man könnte es hochkant irgendwie
vielleicht mit einer Schiene montieren.
Müsste man sich mal angucken.
Ob das ist.
Und außerdem
stelle ich mir es ziemlich schwierig
vorher hier ordentliche Hotswap Rahmen
reinzukriegen.
Oder generell ordentliche Wechselrahmen reinzukriegen.
Das ist eine F4, oder?
Was für ein Gehäuse ist es?
Ich hab nicht aufgepasst.
Irgendein Fractal Define.
Also das Gehäuse ist gut.
Das Gehäuse ist gut.
In den letzten drei PC Generationen
hatte ich hier nur Fractal Design Gehäuse.
Aber für eine Nass?
Weiß ich nicht.
Bei mir käme es halt nicht in die Tüte,
weil ich will die Sache in meinen Rack stecken.
Der Define 7 XL hält bis zu
18 3,5 Inch Harddrives.
Die Reviewers Guide sagt
14 Max.
Und es ist bouldert.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Ich frag mich, wie oft sie das aufgenommen haben,
bis das funktioniert hat.
14 Max. Und es ist bouldert.
Das haben sie bestimmt dreimal gefilmt.
Der McCree, der Schraubendreher.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Oh.
Los geht's.
So, jetzt möchte ich
meine Fans wieder konfigurieren,
bevor ich die Harddrives in dieses Ding starte.
Jetzt sind wir bereit, die Harddrives zu installieren.
Aber ich habe noch mehr komplexe Informationen gefunden.
In der User Guide.
3,5, 2,5 Universal Drive Position 18.
Welches ist es, Fractal?
Also für dieses Projekt...
Das hängt wahrscheinlich davon ab,
wie man das bestückt, könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Also wahrscheinlich
kannst du mit einem Lüfter raus dann irgendwie
vier Drives zusätzlich machen oder so.
Die Gehäuse sind wirklich gut.
Aber wie gesagt, ich würde mir irgendwie
kein Gehäuse mehr
aufs Rack oben drauf stellen. Wozu?
Wozu habe ich ein Rack, wenn ich ein Gehäuse oben drauf stellen muss?
Und Tower oben drauf stellen muss.
Und außerdem
mag ich keine
Rechner mehr
beziehungsweise halt kein NAS mehr
ohne Hotswap-Möglichkeit.
Hast du deinen PC selber
zusammengebaut oder hast du da einen gekauft
und dann modifiziert?
Ich baue die immer selbst zusammen.
Ich sehe nicht viel dabei.
16T gibt es mittlerweile schon.
Ich glaube, da hatten wir doch letztens mal geguckt
und die waren verhältnismäßig ultra teuer.
Zumal ich ja auch absichtlich
etwas langsamere
Platten wollte.
Dass die nicht so viel Strom brauchen,
genau.
Ich habe aktuell so eine drinnen.
Irgendetwas mit
Hawk oder so.
Weiß ich nicht, Seahawk?
Skyhawk?
12TB?
Ja.
So eine habe ich aktuell drinnen.
Bin mir allerdings nicht ganz sicher,
ob es exakt die ist.
Aber eine 12TB, 12TB
und so.
Und das schöne an der Platte war,
dass sie halt recht wenig
Strom braucht.
Wenn das die ist mit nur
5400 Umdrehungen, dann ist das die
richtige.
Sieht man jetzt hier gar nicht, ne?
Weiß nicht.
Irgendjemand wie viel Umdrehung das Ding braucht?
Weiß ich.
Für meine Zwecke ist das halt super.
Das Ding braucht nicht viel Strom.
Das ist generell
wird auch nicht warm.
Ansonsten sind wahrscheinlich die
Ironwolf Dinger besser.
Wenn man wirklich viel Performance braucht.
Was ist bei den Ironwolf Platten überhaupt anders?
Kann ich dir aus dem Kopf nicht sagen.
Ich vermute mal,
dass die ein bisschen anders
selektiert sind.
Und dass eventuell
die Technologie ein bisschen anders ist,
wie sich quasi
wie sich die Platten überschneiden.
Weil es gibt ja so diese Platten, wo
wie nennt sich das?
Wo sie quasi mehrere Platten irgendwie
übereinander haben.
Wo sich dann quasi, ne nicht mehrere Platten übereinander,
wo dann quasi mehrere Sektoren irgendwie
ineinander sind.
Dass du mehr Kapazität auf die gleiche
Fläche kriegst.
Ich vermute mal, da wird sich das ein bisschen in der Bauweise unterscheiden.
Aber
genau müsste man jetzt nachgucken.
Kann ich dir so nicht sagen.
Shingi Kuro
Stufe 1, 8 Monate lang.
Huge, big brain Sub.
Muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich nicht noch mehr Subs übersehen hab.
Ähm
Ne, zum Glück nicht.
Noch mal Glück gehabt hier.
Achso, du wolltest noch was zu wichtigen Programmen
auf dem neuen Rechner sagen.
Vielleicht sogar insbesondere bezogen auf zwei
Two in one Geräte.
Also, wenn ich was neues installiere.
Wir gehen jetzt mal von Windows aus.
Ja, unter Linux sieht das Ganze eh schon wieder ein bisschen anders aus.
Oh, Corona.
Ähm
Also das erste, was ich immer drauf mache,
nachdem ich ein Windows installiert habe, ist ganz klar ein ordentlicher Browser.
Ohne einen ordentlichen Browser
geht gar nichts.
Es ist egal was, sei es ein Chrome, sei es ein Firefox,
irgendwas, was nicht
Internet Explorer oder nicht Edge ist.
Da sind wir
das Zeug da drauf machen.
Und das nächste, was drauf kommt, ist gleich dann ein Adblocker für den jeweiligen Browser.
Das ist so die Basics.
Da tut sich erstmal nichts.
Der neue Edge ist doch auch ordentlich.
Jeder wie er will.
Ja, bei mir kommt meistens ein Firefox als erstes
drauf mit Adblock.
Also mit Dings hier, mit U-Block.
Oder ein Chromium oder ein Chrome oder so was.
Aber auf jeden Fall erstmal einen Browser drauf.
Mit Adblock.
Und danach, so blöd es klingt,
deinstalliere ich erstmal Zeug.
Also das erste, was ich mache, ist,
ich deinstalliere mal so viel Scheiße,
die bei Windows dabei ist,
wie sonst was.
Also wenn da Candy Crush und Geschiss dabei ist,
kommt das erstmal runter.
Also sprich, das erste, was ich installiere, ist eigentlich,
ich deinstalliere.
Danach, genau, der Tribolon hat Recht,
danach kommt Keypass drauf.
Dann kommt bei mir immer
CMD drauf.
Mit
Scoop
als Paketmanager.
Und mit Scoop installiere ich mir dann
Sachen wie
also alles, was ich so
brauche an Entwicklertools.
Und
dann kommt auch noch Keypass drauf,
damit ich meine Passwörter
angucken kann.
Das war es im Großen und Ganzen schon.
Mehr kommt standardmäßig gar nicht drauf.
Auch nicht so viel drauf.
Das sind halt Sachen,
die ich jetzt brauche.
Das trifft allgemein nicht zu.
Und ganz ehrlich, das reicht auch.
Mehr braucht man erstmal nicht.
Ja, das installiere ich alles über Scoop.
PDF Reader braucht man nicht mehr.
PDF Reader kannst du im Browser machen.
Wie macht man das mit Keypass
bei den mobilen Geräten?
Das macht man über irgendeinen Sync-Mechanismus.
Ich mache es über Nextcloud.
Allerdings verwende ich
meinen Keypass schon eine Weile
nicht mehr mobil.
Nutzt du englische Tastatur?
Ne, mache ich nicht.
Keine englische Tastatur.
Ich habe deutsches Tastatur-Layout.
Wo speichere ich so eine Keypass-Datenbank?
Auf der Nextcloud.
Aber das ist egal.
Es muss kein Nextcloud sein.
Ich bin auch mit Nextcloud in letzter Zeit
nicht mehr allzu zufrieden.
Ich wollte eh schon mal gucken, was es sonst noch so gibt.
Achso, nur die Sprache ist englisch.
Das ist die deutsche Tastatur.
Das kann irgendein Sync sein.
Vollkommen egal was.
Mails mache ich über Thunderbird.
Mit Thunderbird mache ich
Mail und
Kalendergedöns.
Allerdings in letzter Zeit verwende ich
quasi Thunderbird nur noch
für Mails, weil ich
jetzt für Notizen und To-Do's
das Ding verwende.
Es ist die
eine der wenigen Elektron-Anwendungen,
die ich benutze.
Das Schöne daran ist, das ist eine
Notizverwaltung und ein To-Do-Programm
in einem, komplett kostenlos.
Gibt es für Mac, für Windows,
für Linux, für Android und für iOS.
Und das ist auch der große Vorteil davon.
Es gibt es wirklich. Das ist die einzige
richtige Cross-Plattform
To-Do-Notizlösung, die ich kenne.
Die sich auch easy mit
self-hosted
Server syncen lässt.
Dafür ist das wirklich gut.
Und seitdem ich das verwende und
seitdem die auch
Betriebssystem-unabhängige Notifications
haben, also sprich
du kannst ein To-Do eintragen und kannst
sagen, hier benachrichtige mich
heute Abend um 18 Uhr, dass ich einkaufen muss
und ich synke das, dann funktioniert
die Notification unter allen Betriebssystemen.
Das ist wirklich sehr praktisch.
Und seitdem ich To-Do's mit
Notifications
hiermit verwende, verwende ich
so gut wie gar nicht mehr
meinen CalDAV Kalender.
Eigentlich gar nicht mehr.
Weil ich festgestellt habe,
To-Do's, ich habe
quasi zu 99%
keine Termine im eigentlichen
Sinn, wo ich sage, okay
am 1.8.
bla bla bla ist das und das.
Das einzige, was ich habe,
was ich noch im CalDAV Kalender habe, ist
der Müllkalender für Hanau
und ein paar Geburtstage, dass ich nicht
vergesse. Das ist alles.
Die Sachen, die ich für mich machen muss,
die mache ich alle als To-Do mit Zeit
und nicht mehr als Termin.
Weil die meisten
Termine sind ja im Endeffekt,
nicht alle, aber die meisten Termine sind ja
eigentlich Sachen, die man erledigen muss.
Das mache ich da drüber. Deswegen verwende ich eigentlich
CalDAV und
Thunderbird nur noch ziemlich selten
für Kalender-Geschichten.
Keine To-Do-App, keine
Aufgaben, mehr Freizeit. Ah, yes.
Exzellent Logik.
Exquisite. Gibt es eine Möglichkeit
über eine Web-Anwendung auf
KeyPass zuzugreifen? Ja, es gibt ein paar
Browser-Addons,
die für dich Formulare ausfüllen
können.
Ich glaube, es gibt auch
Web-Anwendungen für
KeyPass, aber
wenn man es online verwenden möchte,
also im Browser und quasi
einen zentralen Server haben möchte,
der...
Wenn man einen zentralen Server haben möchte, auf den man
zugreift für Passwörter, also wenn man das quasi
nicht synchen möchte, sondern
quasi online haben will, dann würde
ich eher sowas hier in der Richtung empfehlen.
Das ist halt so die grundsätzliche Frage,
die man sich stellen will. Möchte man was, was
man offline hat, erstmal prinzipiell
offline hat und bei Bedarf
syncht, oder möchte man quasi
so on demand was haben, was
quasi als Web-Applikation
läuft. Das sind so die zwei unterschiedlichen
Sachen, ja. Also wenn man was haben will, was
offline ist und was man selektiv syncht, wenn man
es braucht, dann nehme ich KeyPass
und wenn man was haben will, was
online immer verfügbar ist, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich
das hier nehmen, aber ich finde den Ansatz
mit KeyPass immer noch
praktischer für mich,
weil ich da beruhigter schlafen kann.
Und dazu
kommt, dass ich meine Passwörter gar nicht
so großartig synchen will. Ich will das
daheim verwenden, wo ich mich bei den meisten Sachen
einlogge und fertig ist.
Und KeyPass hat für mich einen riesen Vorteil
im Vergleich zu allen anderen Passwortmanagern.
Es gibt es schon ewig
und es hatte nie großartige Sicherheitsprobleme.
Es sieht altbacken aus, ja.
Keine Frage.
New Database.
Masterpasswort 123456.
123456.
Huge Password.
Okay, yes. Skip.
So.
Oh guck mal, der Michael, wie kommt denn der hier in unser Passwortmanagement?
Eben noch
im Twitch-Chat und jetzt schon im Passwortmanager.
Es sieht
altbacken aus im Vergleich
zu den Anwendungen, die heute
so am Start sind, ja.
Aber, ähm,
an sich funktioniert das wunderbar.
Ah, da hast du hier Internet.
Da sagst du hier, ich will ein neues Passwort anlegen.
Jetzt für, keine Ahnung, sagen wir mal Google,
Google Mail. Da merkst du
den Username, äh,
twitchblub at
gmail.com
Passwort kannst du dir hier, generiert
der dir standardmäßig schon ein. So kannst du dir auch hier unten
verschiedene andere Passwörter generieren.
Der macht dir halt standardmäßig eins rein. Kannst natürlich
dein eigenes auch reinschreiben.
So, mein aktuelles ist, ähm,
mein aktuelles Passwort ist Alex123456.
Dann kann man, das ist übrigens alles
verschlüsselt hier drin. Eine URL für
Gmail brauch ich nicht. Ich mein,
weiß jeder.
Was ganz praktisch ist hier unten, äh,
Notes. Die sind auch alle komplett
verschlüsselt. Wenn man zum Beispiel,
ähm, wenn man zum Beispiel, äh,
geheime Fragen
und geheime Antworten für spezielle Dienste
vergeben muss, dann schreib ich die hier
immer unten rein. Machst du nach dem Motto,
äh, Haustier,
so erste Frage ist Haustier
und es war keine Katze.
Zweite ist, äh,
Geburtsort ist
Offenbach. So, und da schreib ich
immer noch unten rein, wenn ich da irgendwelche
geheimen Fragen hab, ähm,
weil spätestens die Dinger,
die weiß wirklich
keine Sau mehr nach nem Jahr.
Das kann sich wirklich keiner,
das ist, vergiss es, ja.
Jaja, ich bin in Offenbach geboren.
Wie Haftbefehl.
Hehe. Wow.
Tf.
Ich hab grad den Deckel von meiner T-Kanne
ins Glas geschmissen.
Easy clap, ja. Ich muss mal kurz ausleeren.
Wartet mal.
Wieder, wieder am Start.
Warum kein Keypass XC?
Weil. Hat keinen tieferen
Grund. Ich weiß gar nicht, was der Unterschied
ist. So.
Gut.
Also es ist total simpel im Endeffekt.
Sieht zwar altbacken
aus, aber ist wirklich praktisch.
Ähm, man kann hier auch irgendwie
automatisch Sachen
eintippen lassen, aber das verwende ich alles gar nicht.
Ich mach da oldschool copy und paste und gut ist.
Und es gibt dafür auch, ähm,
Addons für den
für den Browser,
dass man Formulare ausfüllen kann und sowas.
Das ist schon nicht, ist nicht übel.
So, ich muss jetzt mal
Chat hochscrollen, weil ich ja die Hälfte
übersehen hab.
Außer, dass sich der Chat lustig drüber macht,
dass ich in Offenbach geboren bin.
in Offenbach, Leute.
Der Asitoni
kommt auch aus Offenbach. Ja, das stimmt.
Kannst du mal
einen 4K-Monitor für 3 bis 400
für 300 bis 350,
nee.
Kenn ich mich null aus aktuell.
Ja, das mit Bitworn hab ich
ja gerade gesagt, was da so die Unterschiede dazwischen
sind. Für mich ist ein riesen Vorteil
von Keypass,
dass ich den Kram schon seit,
keine Ahnung, 12 Jahren oder so
verwende und das nie größere Sicherheitsprobleme hat.
Wo ist Offenbach?
Nee, war Frankfurt.
Mit Autotime hab ich mal mein Passwort
für Amazon auf Discord. Excellent.
Excellent.
Wer ist denn der Asitoni?
Das musst du mal auf YouTube suchen, dann weißt du,
wer der Asitoni ist. Der Asitoni hatte
das Problem, der war 10 Jahre zu früh.
Hätte der Asitoni heute angefangen
mit solchen Videos auf YouTube, der hätte
3 Millionen Abos.
Max, würdest du dir
einen Zoom-Tech einmal anschauen?
Okay.
Ach, das ist ein Streaming.
Das ist ein Streaming-Dienst. Ja, das können wir,
aber nicht jetzt. Können wir uns irgendwann mal angucken.
Kennst du den? Nein, kenn ich nicht.
Quatsch.
Ich mein, wir könnten ungefähr gleich
alt sein, eventuell. Ich glaub, der ist
ein bisschen älter.
Also dürfte nicht so viel älter sein.
Würdest du einen Nass ins Internet
hängen oder dich mit einem VPN zum
Heimnetzen? VPN.
Nass nicht ins Internet hängen.
Welche Nextcloud-Alternativen
kennst du? Ja, also das
Gesamtpaket, was Nextcloud bietet.
Ja, also mit der Web-Oberfläche und den
Plugins gibt es dazu keine
weiteren, quelloffenen Alternativen
in diesem Funktionsumfang.
Wenn's rein um den Sync geht, gibt's noch ein paar Sachen.
Ja, C-File zum Beispiel.
Aber rein von den
Features mit dem Webinterface und den ganzen
Plugins und so zusammen gibt es keine Alternative.
Rein für den Sync hast du Syncthing,
hast du, du hast C-File, du kannst dann
natürlich auch ganz klassisch über irgendeinen
Samba-Share-Mountain, da gibt's ganz viele verschiedene Geschichten.
Es gibt auch irgendwelche Crypto-Bittorrent-
Syncs und sowas, da gibt es jede Menge
Sachen. Rein für die Sync,
für diese
Sync-Problematik.
Sehen wir uns noch die eingesandten
Battlefield-Clips an? Könnten wir machen.
Können wir eigentlich nachher noch machen,
oder? Die Clips,
die die Leute eingeschickt haben für
die Battlefield-Montage, Montage.
Können wir uns nachher eigentlich noch
angucken. So, gucken wir uns erstmal das
Linus-NAS weiter an.
Erinnert mich nochmal dran, dass wir uns nachher die
Battlefield-Clips angucken, die schon eingeschickt wurden.
Also ich weiß, dass du auch schon
was eingeschickt hast, N-Drops.
Habe ich schon gespottet
alles.
Das ist echt nicht übel,
ne? Also bisher, eins muss man
ja den Festplattenherstellern lassen. Festplattenhersteller
und auch den
RAM-Herstellern.
Ich hatte bisher
noch nie Probleme,
eine Festplatte und einen RAM-Riegel umzutauschen.
Noch nie.
Selbst wenn die schon aus der
Garantie raus waren. Bisher habe ich
immer neue Sachen gekriegt.
Ich bin kein Freund von Helium HDDs,
wie siehst du das?
Weder noch. Ich habe da weder
schlechte noch irgendwie herausragende
Erfahrungen mitgemacht.
Also aktuell im Stand
wäre es mir egal, was da drin ist.
Also Festplattenhersteller
haben bisher noch keinen Akt
gemacht und auch RAM.
Ich hatte mal vor Jahren,
da hatte ich von Corsair
das waren auch
265 MB Riegel waren das.
Da hatte ich so ein Media Center PC.
Ich war wahrscheinlich in Deutschland einer der ersten, der einen Media Center PC
an einem Röhrenfernseher hatte damals schon.
Das ist wirklich ganz, ganz lange her.
2005 oder so.
Und den haben wir auch eine Weile verwendet und
irgendwie nach sieben Jahren oder so
ist der 256 MB
RAM-Riegel von Corsair
verreckt und den haben die damals verkauft
mit Lifetime Warranty.
Diesen RAM.
Und da habe ich nach sieben Jahren
den geschrieben und habe gesagt, hier Leute,
der RAM ist
kaputt.
Die haben absolut keinerlei Anstalten gemacht.
Die haben mir sogar eine 512 Riegel geschickt,
weil sie gesagt haben, 256 haben sie nicht mehr.
Nach sieben Jahren.
Ich meine gut, man kann sagen, wenn da
Lifetime draufsteht, dann sollten es halt Lifetime
sagen, ja.
Aber, dass das so
problemlos funktioniert, fand ich auch gut.
Auch WD, bei WD habe ich auch schon einige
Festplatten zurückgeschickt, gab es nie
Probleme. Nie.
Also das muss man sagen, das klappt gut.
Der Wohnwagen ist auch da.
Boah.
Tja, das Problem
hast du nicht, wenn du sie in einem
gescheiten Rahmen einbaust.
Anstatt sie einfach so in irgendeinem
Ding zu legen.
Also auf die Idee bin ich
ehrlich gesagt noch nie gekommen.
Meine Festplatte
mit Klebeband festzumachen.
Sind es 3,5 Zoll?
Oder sind es 2,5 Zoll Festplatten?
Ich hätte am Anfang gesagt 3,5 Zoll,
aber, ach ne, hier unten sind die SATA
Anschlüsse. Das sieht bloß so komisch
aus, ne? Ne, das sind 3,5 Zoll.
16. Okay,
keine Dokumentation hat über 16
gesagt. Was zur Hölle?
Ohoho.
Nun, das ist passiert. Wir sind auf 19
Fahrzeuge, was mich ein bisschen
überlegt, wie weit wir gehen können.
Aber guck mal, Leute, das ist eines
der Probleme, wenn man die Dinger
nicht ordentlich
in den Rahmen einbaut,
beziehungsweise halt so ein normales
Gehäuse mit 19 Platten bestückt.
Aber angenommen, du hast dann, es ist egal,
irgendein RAID,
mein RAID 5 wirst du über 19 Platten
nicht machen. Mindestens
ein RAID 6 oder wahrscheinlich besser ein RAID
10 oder RAID 50 oder was auch immer.
Keine Ahnung, was sie vorhaben zu machen.
Wobei Linus ist ja so mit UnRAID immer ganz
dicke. Wenn du im laufenden
Betrieb dann mal eine Platte
wechseln willst, oder wenn du überhaupt eine Platte
wechseln willst, ist es halt deutlich
angenehmer, einfach
den Wechselrahmen zu nehmen,
Klick, Platte rausziehen, neue Platte rein,
reinstecken, geht wieder, anstatt
das Gehäuse, also anstatt den Rechner
wahrscheinlich abstöpseln zu müssen,
den Rechner auf den Tisch stellen zu müssen,
aufmachen zu müssen, die passende
Platte zu suchen und
auszubauen. Deswegen
mag ich
das nicht mit,
wir nehmen einfach ein normales Gehäuse und
mauten so viele Platten, wie wir haben.
Welches Programm nutzt ihr, um Backups vom System
zu machen? Idealerweise ohne selbst tätig
zu werden. Das hier. Das
Beste.
Geht auch unter Windows.
Ist aber reines Kommandozeilenprogramm.
Big.
Walkbackup, das da.
Das ist auch recht beliebt.
Das hat auf Github
6000 Sterne ungefähr, also das ist
keine Kacken-Software, die niemand verwendet.
Außerdem hat der Maintainer das beste
Avatar-Bild überhaupt.
Das da.
Das verwende ich.
Also für Linux ist natürlich optimal.
Da funktioniert das alles
direkt, out of the box.
Unter Windows ist aber auch kein Ding.
Unter Windows kannst du es
entweder über WSL
verwenden oder es gibt glaube ich
sogar mittlerweile einen kompletten Installer-Pack
für Windows. Also es funktioniert unter Windows
auch problemlos. Unter Windows
ist es minimal langsamer als unter
Linux, weil irgendwelche,
zumindest war das vor ein paar Jahren so,
wo ich mich da zum letzten Mal intensiv mit
beschäftigt hab, seitdem geht's halt einfach.
Weil irgendwelche Python-Libraries
unter Windows keine Native
Extensions haben,
oder ist es langsamer.
Kein Schimmer, was genau. Aber das ist nicht so viel langsamer,
als dass es Probleme machen würde.
Und das Schöne an Borg ist,
dass es quasi das Beste
aus allen Welten vereint.
Es lässt sich super automatisieren,
weil es eben ein Kommandozeilen-Tool ist,
was bei Backup wichtig ist.
Wenn du Backup nicht automatisch machst,
machst du fast nie Backup.
Das ist das Problem dabei.
Es ist inkrementell,
also es kann Voll-Backups, es kann inkrementelle Backups,
es ist standardmäßig
vollverschlüsselt, was auch eine wichtige
Geschichte ist. Und das beste Feature
ist, es kann
inkrementelle
Backups, die
standardmäßig vollverschlüsselt sind,
inklusive, und jetzt kommt's,
Deduplication und Kompression.
Und das in Kombination ist echt
Big Brain umzusetzen.
Deswegen hat das vorher auch keiner gemacht.
Was natürlich den riesen Vorteil hat,
ich spare unglaublich viel Platz durch
Deduplication. Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel
einen, sagen wir mal, ich
backupe, Backup 3,
ganz billig Beispiel, ich backupe 3
Windows-PCs.
Und da sind ja sehr viele Dateien doppelt.
Und durch Deduplication
speichere ich die nur einmal, anstatt dreimal.
Was bei normaler Software halt
bei normalem Backup eben nicht so ist.
Je nachdem, wie man
das hier macht, hast du natürlich auch
keine Vorteile dadurch, wenn ich jetzt quasi für jeden
Rechner ein eigenes Repo mache,
dann geht das nicht, weil
Deduplication ist Repo-basiert.
Aber auch wenn ich verschiedene
Heimatverzeichnisse von meinen Usern backupe oder so,
das ist wirklich clever gemacht.
Und dann macht das Deduplication
auch nicht auf Dateibasis,
sondern immer in 4K-Blöcken.
Das heißt, man kann damit auch wunderbar
Images backuppen.
Also sprich, ich kann auch einfach
mein VM-Image backuppen
und
oder irgendwelche ISO-Geschichten
oder was auch immer
und es wird auch ordentlich Deduplicated.
VM ist auch gut
für VMware-Zeug, ja.
Aber ich finde so generell, zum einfach
benutzen, vor allem, wenn man viele Linux-Kisten hat,
wenn man zumindest einen Linux-Server hat,
auf den man backupt, dann ist das
hier optimal.
Und das in Kombination mit
Rclone
ist eine ganz tolle Geschichte
für Cloud Sync.
Also sprich, was man machen kann ist,
man macht mit Borg seine
Backups von
allen möglichen Rechnern, die man so hat.
Und mit Rclone, wenn man das machen will,
kann man noch einen Offsite Backup machen
auf irgendwelche
Cloud-Anbieter-Dienste. Die unterstützen fast alles.
Und die Kombination ist
wirklich ziemlich gut.
Das da für Backups lokal
und wenn man es dann in die Cloud syncen will,
guckt euch mal an, was die
alles für
Backends unterstützen.
Das ist wirklich nice.
Wobei Offline, also Offsite Backup,
ich habe ja vor einer Weile
Offsite, immer, habe ich ja immer gesagt,
habe ich euch ja auch immer im Stream erzählt,
so nach dem Motto, macht Offsite Backups,
ich habe jetzt seit 2 Jahren oder so, läuft mein Offsite Backup nicht mehr
und ich habe es auch überlebt
bisher. Ich meine, ich habe ja genug
Backups von meinem Zeug, allerdings
sollte mal das Haus abbrennen
oder so, da habe ich halt ein Problem.
Offsite bei meiner Oma,
das ist natürlich noch besser, wenn man einfach
irgendwo einen Standort hat, wo man hin
Backupen kann oder so. Aber viele haben das
halt nicht und
machen halt Offsite Backup Verschlüssel
in die Cloud. Das ist auch
eine Valid Strategie.
Das ist auch okay, das kann man auch machen.
Man muss halt gucken, dass es ein ordentliches Passwort ist,
eine ordentliche Verschlüsselung, aber das macht Airclone
für einen schon. Und das in Kombinationen
ist wirklich top. Kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Ja, wenn man,
wenn man, du, aber 4er
Backup ist auch für Noobs nicht so kompliziert.
Du kannst dir mal ein Tutorial Video
zu angucken, das hält sich in Grenzen.
Natürlich, wenn man gerne einen GUI hätte und dort
irgendwas auswählt, ähm,
ist das nix.
It sort of leads me to
wonder how much farther we can go.
Wie er da immer seinen stylischen,
seinen stylischen Flip macht. Übrigens,
Leute, ich weiß, ich unterbreche das
wieder als oft, aber, wo wir grad beim Thema
äh, Schraubendreher und
und, äh, Werkzeug sind. Ich hab mir zwei neue Sachen
gekauft. Richtig nices Zeug.
Und zwar hab ich mir einmal gekauft, ein wäre
Tool Check Plus.
Das Ding ist huge.
Das ist ultra praktisch.
Ähm, das ist, mal gucken ob man hier irgendwie
von der Seite was sieht.
Das kann man sich an Gürtel
schnallen.
Kann man sich an Gürtel schnallen. Man sieht jetzt die Schnalle nicht so
wirklich, weil die keine gescheiten Fotos von der
Rückseite haben. Ähm,
da ist ne Schnalle für'n Gürtel an der,
an der Rückseite. Und man hat
alles was man braucht.
Ähm, und das ist für, für 53 Euro
ist das wirklich okay. Ich mein, klar,
es wäre Zeug, das ist immer teuer.
Du kriegst wahrscheinlich die gleichen Sachen
beim Lidl oder so. Für, äh,
20, 15 Euro
oder so. Ähm,
aber nicht in so nem schönen
Pack. Und das geile ist an dem
Ding. Und das ist wirklich nice.
Ähm, das ist
wirklich nice. Du hast Bits für fast alles
was man so braucht. Ja?
Man hat, man hat Torx.
Man hat Torx in den üblichen Größen.
Man hat diese,
ich weiß nicht, wie heißen diese Dinger?
Diese, äh, Security Torx da.
Weiß nicht wie die heißen da. Was man teilweise braucht
zum Handys aufmachen und Dinger. Die mit dem Clips
in der Mitte. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie, wie nennen die sich
da hier? Die da, die ich grad nennen.
In der Mitte hab. Die, die Torx
mit dem Loch in der Mitte meine ich.
Ähm, keine Ahnung wie die heißen.
Ist aber auch ganz praktisch, wenn man sie hat.
Man hat, ähm,
Sechskant-Dinger. Man hat, äh, Kreuzschlitz.
Man hat Normale.
Also das, das Bitset ist schon mal
cool. Und das richtig
Gute da dran ist. Man hat noch ein paar
Nüsse in den üblichen Größen. Allerdings
was es halt richtig cool macht ist, man hat
oben noch ne, so ne,
so ne, so ne Knarre
dabei.
Kleine. Hier sieht mans.
So ne kleine Knarre dabei.
Und so nen Vera-Kraft-Form, äh,
Hand-Handle.
So, und das, und das in Kombination,
äh,
und das, und das in Kombination ist
wirklich nice. Und die haben das auch so gebaut,
wie man hier sieht. Also sprich, wenn man das am Gürtel hat,
wenn man das am Gürtel hat, man kann
das alles quasi vom Gürtel aus
rausnehmen und zusammenbauen. Ohne dass man
das irgendwie abmachen muss. Das hier neben
ist nen Schalter. Das hier neben ist nen Schalter.
Weil standardmäßig sieht das
nicht so aus, sondern es ist alles
bombenfest. Und erst wenn man
den Schalter hier neben hochklappt, da wo das
Vera-Logo drauf ist,
ähm, dann klappen die Bits vorne raus.
Das wollte ich mir schon
seit ner Weile holen, jetzt hab ich mir mal bestellt.
Das ist wirklich ein super,
ein super Werkzeugset.
Und, ähm, man kommt, man
kommt fast, also,
man kommt, würde ich sagen, im Heimgebrauch
mit diesem Werkzeugset
fast aus.
Ja, was natürlich nicht drin ist, ne
Zange oder irgendwie, oder auch ein
Seitenschneider oder kommt irgendwie, natürlich nicht.
Aber, ähm,
für alles, wo man schrauben muss
und wo man auch ein bisschen Kraft braucht, im Heim,
im Heimbereich, kommt man damit locker aus.
Ja.
Es fehlen, es fehlen noch einige Dinge, aber
für alles, was man schrauben muss, ist man damit im
Heimbereich eigentlich ziemlich gut, ziemlich gut
aufgestellt. So, und dann hab ich mir
noch eine Sache dabei gekauft,
nur weil das wollte ich mir auch schon öfters mal holen.
Hab ich jetzt, hab ich mir jetzt endlich,
endlich mal bestellt. Und zwar,
okay, ähm,
für die,
wenn man noch ein bisschen mehr braucht,
noch hier so einen, äh,
das ist, die Pavera ist, sind
die, sind die roten Dinger,
sind quasi für Elektro,
die sind irgendwie, glaub, bis 1000 Volt
äh, isoliert,
zugelassen und getestet
und die grünen sind die normalen. Aber,
im Prinzip, man kann beides für beides verwenden,
ja. Die haben halt bloß
diese zwei unterschiedlichen Geschichten.
Da hab ich mir nochmal ein Set gekauft, mit, äh,
unterschiedlichen, unterschiedlichen
Schraubendre, Drehoren
dabei, ähm,
die man hat, wo man auch ein bisschen mehr Reichweite hat,
weil die Dinger ein bisschen länger sind, äh,
und hier nochmal ihre, ihre komische
Zyklop-Knarre, also sprich den Kopf,
da oben kann man drehen, gar nicht, ob man,
jetzt sieht man hier, da kann man, jetzt kann man
quasi oben drehen von,
kann man dann quasi 15 Grad
kippen, 90 Grad und irgendwie in die
andere Richtung, ist halt auch äußerst praktisch.
Ja.
Und man kann das Ganze noch ein bisschen verlängern,
ja. Also, sehr nice,
ja. Die zwei Sachen.
Und, ähm, in Kombination
mit allem anderen Geschiss bin ich dafür
jetzt eigentlich ziemlich gut, ähm,
bin ich damit jetzt eigentlich ziemlich,
ziemlich gut aufgestellt, ja.
Ähm, also ich wüsste
jetzt nicht, was ich für mein Heimwerkerzeug in
nächster Zeit noch brauchen würde.
Hast du jetzt eigentlich einen Dremel? Ja, hab ich auch.
Hab ich mir auch
einen gekauft, aber schon vor einem Monat oder so.
Oder vor zwei
Monate. Den hier,
hab ich mir gekauft. Warte mal, zeig ich dir.
Äh, ja.
Das kleinste, was
die hatten. Ich wollte mir eigentlich
erst ein günstiges China-Ding
kaufen, da hab ich mir gedacht, komm, scheiß drauf.
Brauchst du eh nicht so oft.
Brauchst du eh nicht so oft, nimmst du mal den günstigen
davon. Ähm,
aber ich hab den gekauft, der auch noch ein ordentliches
Set an Werkzeugen dabei hat.
Dann, was man damit schön machen
kann, ist zum Beispiel
einen PCI-Express
Einfach-Slot hinten
aufschneiden, damit man eine 16-fach-Karte
reinmachen kann. Ich weiß nicht, wie es
richtig heißt, ob Knarre oder Ratsche besser
ist. Ich glaube, es geht beides.
Knarre,
Ratsche, Unterschied. Ohoho.
Ah, die Knarre oder Ratsche. Okay.
Ähm, anscheinend
ist das beides valid.
Handwerkermann und Hackermann
in einem. Manche Sachen brauchen wir halt.
Und
ihr wisst ja, ich bin viel am Basteln
daheim. Da braucht man
ordentliches Werkzeug und
Knatsche.
Der war gut.
Ja, aber gutes Werkzeug kann man nicht genug
haben. So sieht's aus.
Gutes Produktplacement. Ja, es wäre schön,
wenn es Produktplacement wäre, damit ich wenigstens Geld
bekomme. Hast du auch noch
einen Elektrikerkoffer? Nö.
Gucken wir weiter.
Weiß gar nicht, wie ich da jetzt drauf gekommen bin.
Man kann es gut
bei 20 nennen, oder? Ich meine,
Terabyte Rohkapazität in einem
200 Dollar Fall. Lass uns beginnen, über
einige unserer anderen Komponenten zu sprechen.
Ja, das ist ein
Strix Gaming
Motherboard oder was auch immer. Wozu?
Aber was es auch ist, ist ein gutes
Value Board mit viel Memory
Expansion, was wichtig sein könnte, wenn wir
VMs oder andere Serverfunktionen
auf unserer NAS runtern wollen. Also man muss sagen,
so, also, man braucht
jetzt für eine NAS nicht ultra
viel RAM, ja.
Das einzige, was mir einfallen würde, ist, wenn man
ZFS machen will und dann aber auch
nur, wenn man
da irgendwie super
High-Performance-Geschichten machen will. Also ZFS
kommt auch mit etwas weniger
RAM aus. Da siehst
du, im Internet hast du Anleitungen, wo die Leute
sagen, unter 48 Gigabyte
RAM und ECC-Speicher
musst du ZFS gar nicht
verwenden, was natürlich kompletter Blödsinn ist. Das
funktioniert auch mit weniger RAM und das funktioniert auch ohne
ECC-Speicher. Das wird dadurch auch nicht
schlechter als andere Filesysteme.
Da wird viel Panik
geschoben, ja.
Aber ansonsten braucht man für ein einfaches NAS,
wenn man da, keine Ahnung, macht sich da irgendwie
ein stinknormaler Ubuntu-Server
drauf und
dann einfach ein Software-Array drüber.
Das braucht jetzt nicht hier die
Milliarden an RAM oder so.
Und das Board hat
RGB, ja. Dadurch wird es natürlich schon mal schneller.
Das ist richtig.
Ja, wahrscheinlich
will das Betriebssystem
auf die M.2
SSDs machen.
In Headless-Mode
without a
graphics card installed
and without an APU
installed, where you would be able to use the
onboard graphics. So that saves
us some money, because even though we're gonna
need a graphics card in order to configure
our system, we don't actually
necessarily want to leave one in there,
unless we have some purpose.
Like we want to use GPU
hardware acceleration for media encoding
for a Plex-Server or something like that.
So we're going with a second-gen
Ryzen 2600.
Das kann auch sein, dass sie das irgendwie als Cache
beziehungsweise als Write-Gedöns
für ZFS verwenden wollen,
die M.2. Aber ich gehe eher davon aus, sie wollen das
Betriebssystem auf die M.2 machen.
Non-X. Because it's using
the original Zen-Architecture instead of Zen 2,
those individual cores
are not as fast.
Now, we could go with something
heavier, if we intend to use this thing
again as a
media server that's gonna have to do heavy
video encoding or whatever the case may be.
Wie gesagt,
wir haben 10G
Netzwerk
gemacht hier
mit einem
bisschen besseren Atom.
Our intent for the build today
is to just have it be a file
server, and this is gonna be plenty
of horsepower for that.
Now, I did consider going Intel
for this build, but even though we're using regular
unbuffered memory, one of the things
that pushed me to AMD was their
unofficial support for ECC
or error checking memory on their
consumer processors.
Geht das? Geht das? Das ist echt cool,
wenn das funktioniert.
Our support from the motherboard, and conveniently
this one happens to support it, as well as
costing a little bit more.
Das Kollege hat seinen YouTube-Channel verkauft.
Warum verkauft er seinen YouTube-Channel? Der Typ, der hat so viel
krass viel Kohle. Warum muss der überhaupt
noch was verkaufen? Echt?
Hat Kollege seinen YouTube-Channel verkauft?
Echt?
Das sieht doch immer noch...
Oh.
Vielleicht wurde der auch
nicht verkauft. Vielleicht hat ja
der krasse Hackermann zugeschlagen.
Ich habe mir auch mal gewünscht, dass ich
den AMD Box Cooler
mit dem RAM
ausprobieren kann.
Und dann, solange meine Thermals
und Akustik gut sind,
stecke ich mit dem.
Und wenn nicht, dann kann ich
immer noch nach unten upgraden.
Eine Sache, die ich extra verwendet habe,
die normalerweise ein Splurge-Item ist,
aber in diesem Fall einen großen Sinn macht,
ist eine moduläre Befestigung.
Warum sagen wir das nicht?
Um eure Hände auf
bestimmte Kabel für den Power-Supply zu bekommen.
Gut, das ist 16.
Und wir haben beide.
Einen weiteren Harnes,
sowie einen weiteren Plug auf unseren modulären
Power-Supply, um unsere anderen vier
Drive zu handeln.
Gut, Linus, jetzt beim Stromkabel einstecken
zuzugucken, ist jetzt nicht so spannend.
Der Link des Instagram
leitet zu einem Hackermann.
Deswegen habe ich den Instagram
nicht angeklickt, weil ich nicht wusste,
wo ich da rauskomme.
Ich bin in der Warehouse,
also wir haben genug,
auch wenn du als End-User einen
zusätzlichen haben würdest.
Oder man nimmt einen SATA-Extender,
wobei, das weiß ich nicht, ob das ganze
supported ist, und ist natürlich ein bisschen
komplex.
Also extra, extra
PCI-Karten sind schon besser.
Da hat er Recht.
Da hat er Recht, aber die meisten,
Raid-Cards kannst du einfach umstellen,
dass die eben keinen Raid machen.
Dass sie einfach das ganze durchschleifen.
Und die LSI-Controller,
die kannst du in der Regel sogar flashen,
auf einen HBA-only
Modus.
Was sogar preis-leistungsmäßig
vor ein paar Jahren ein super Geheimtipp
war, dass man sich günstige
LSI-Raid-Controller gekauft hat,
die dann auf HBA-Mode umgeflasht hat.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das heute so ist, aber
da konntest du teilweise irgendwie 200-300 Euro sparen.
Wenn du eine Raid-Card nutzt.
Eine andere Sache zu beachten,
wenn du diese kaufst, sind die Konnektoren.
Einige von ihnen haben nur die
normalen SATA-Konnektoren, die du
kennenlernen würdest. Und dann plugst du sie rein,
und dann hast du ein Octopus, das Kabel kommt raus,
und dann plugst du sie in deine Geräte.
Aber andere benutzen Konnektoren, die
mehr für SATA- oder SAS-Backpläne
ausgestattet sind. Also Mini-SAS-HD
oder SFF-8087 sind einige ziemlich
übliche.
Kann man aber auch nehmen.
Das ist überhaupt kein Ding. Also wenn du Mini-SAS hast,
kannst du da
ohne Probleme
einen Konnektor dran machen, wo dann
vier oder fünf SATA-Ports
rauskommen. Ich glaube, sowas zeigt er jetzt hier auch
gleich. Sieht so ein bisschen nach dem aus, was er in der Hand hat.
Also Mini-SAS kann man...
Umgedreht geht das nicht.
Aber von Mini-SAS zu SATA funktioniert.
Was gibt es da für gute
und günstige? Hab da noch ein paar SAS-Platten über.
SAS-Platten daheim lohnen sich in der Regel nicht.
Die sind in der Regel ziemlich klein, laut,
und verbrauchen viel Strom.
Aber wenn du doch welche hast,
jeder x-beliebige, jeder x-beliebige
Controller
im passenden Anschluss sollte es da eigentlich tun.
Ich kann dir jetzt aber kein Modell
aus dem Kopf sagen.
Also in meiner 4-AE-Serverkiste
habe ich von LOSI einen, was ist es,
8004 oder 8008
oder... Boah, fragt mich nicht.
Die Bezeichnungen sind jetzt
nicht so griffig, dass man die nicht merken kann.
Und dann, uff,
auf der anderen Seite
hast du den Octopus.
Oh, ja, das sind eigentlich 8 Octopus.
Okay, also es sind 4 pro Konnektor.
Kaufen von solchen Karten auf Ebay
kann ein guter Weg sein,
viel Konnektivität zu deinem System zu erzeugen.
Nur eine Sache zu beachten, Leute,
SAS-Platten funktionieren mit SATA-Platten,
aber nicht umgedreht.
Genau.
Das finde ich gut, dass er das nochmal sagt.
Ist ja das, was ich vor 5 Minuten auch schon mal gesagt habe.
Da muss man gucken.
In die eine Richtung geht es, in die andere geht es nicht.
Wisst ihr, was ich nicht kapiere?
Der baut den Kram ja gar nicht,
um sie zu verwenden, immer die Rechner.
Ich glaube, das ist einfach nur, dass er Content hat.
Was ja vollkommen legitim ist.
Würde ich auch so machen.
Aber was ich bei Linus immer cool finde,
das sind ja alles Kulissen hier hinten.
Und der hat eine Kulisse,
die sieht aus wie in der Küche.
Also sprich, viele Leute auf YouTube
nehmen Videos in ihrer Küche auf
und versuchen, dass die Küche nach Technik aussieht.
Und bei Linus hat er ein Studio mit Technikraum,
wo er die Technik nach Küche aussehen lässt.
Wo er die Technik nach Küche aussehen lässt.
Ja, ich mache keine Videos, das stimmt.
Anscheinend will er doch hier drauf
das Betriebssystem machen.
Weil dann werden die M2 wohl doch Caches.
Obnoxious, what?
What do you mean obnoxious?
Warum muss er da temporäre Grafikkarte reinmachen,
haben die auf dem Mainboard keine Grafik?
Ausgang.
So, I'm not that familiar with Proxmox
and I wanted to show people,
how you might configure a system like this in Proxmox.
Ich würde es überhaupt...
Wozu Proxmox?
Ich denke, der will ein einfaches NAS da draus machen.
Der braucht doch kein Proxmox.
Wozu? Wozu nen Proxmox?
Er gibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Da brauchst du keinen Proxmox.
Da machst du dir entweder was Fertiges drauf
für NAS oder machst dir irgendwie einen Ubuntu Server drauf,
installierst, machst dann RAID,
installierst den Samba und fertig.
Proxmox ist total...
fast schon kontraproduktiv für nen NAS jetzt.
Das heißt, wir haben einen VDEV Pool,
also können wir einen haben, der RAID-Z3 ist.
Obwohl, wenn du mehr Drives dazugeben willst,
dann musst du 20 mehr Drives dazugeben.
Ich meine, in einer idealen Welt
würde ich wahrscheinlich
vielleicht...
Was ist denn ZFS-RAID 3?
Ist das RAID 60?
Oder was ist das?
Wie schreibt man das?
RAID-Z3...
Kann man sich mal schlecht merken,
die RAID-Level.
Versus RAID 5?
Drei Paritätsplatten.
Okay, dann ist das sowas wie RAID 7
oder so.
Es ist kein Mirror über Stripes
oder Stripes über Mirrors oder so.
Das sind einfach drei
Paritätsplatten.
Was man bei 20 Platten natürlich
problemlos machen kann und wahrscheinlich sogar sollte.
Dann ist das wirklich sowas wie
RAID 7. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob es so ein RAID 7
überhaupt gibt.
Okay, dann ist zumindest eine ordentliche
CPU, wenn das Ding richtig Performance haben soll,
nicht verkehrt, weil die ganze
Paritätsberechnung und sowas, das braucht wahrscheinlich
schon ein bisschen was.
Vor allem, wenn man dann noch Software-RAID macht,
Software-RAID, Paritätsberechnung,
dann ist wahrscheinlich eine ordentliche CPU
nicht verkehrt.
Ich habe eine VM auf meiner NAS,
ich habe einen Plex-Server,
ich habe viele verschiedene VMs, nur um all diese kleinen Dinge zu machen.
Home-Automation und in Proxmox
kannst du das wirklich einfach machen.
Du kannst eigentlich Container erschaffen,
die immer noch in der Host-OS funktionieren.
Bestimmt, aber wie gesagt,
wir haben ja Proxmox im Stream auch mal ausprobiert.
Ich bin halt mittlerweile auch schon so weit,
dass ich sage, hey,
es nimmt zwar ein bisschen Arbeit ab
und ist auch schön,
wenn man ein Web-Interface hat,
aber wenn man weiß, was man machen will, ist es immer noch am Anfang.
Man installiert sich einfach ein Ubuntu-Server-System drauf
und macht die paar Sachen selbst.
FreeNAS hätte ich auch keinen Bock drauf.
Wie gesagt, machen Ubuntu-Server drauf,
es kommt ja sogar mittlerweile schon
out of the box mit ZFS.
Fertig.
Sammler drauf, gut ist.
Also, wenn ich ZFS verwenden will,
dann muss ich viel Geld verdienen.
Das ist ein bisschen Dreck.
Nicht viel, aber...
Aber wenn ich ZFS optimal verwenden will,
in einer Art, die von Experten,
die viel über ZFS wissen,
empfiehlt ist,
dann spende ich eigentlich mehr auf Memory-Upgrades,
wenn ich mich nicht um die Virtualisierung kümmere.
Das ist nicht so, wie ich das in der ersten Zeit konfiguriert habe.
Dann würde es mich kosten,
einen Unraid-Lizenz in der ersten Zeit zu kaufen.
Und Unraid hat einige Performance-Gottes.
Also, wenn man Turbo-Rate verlängert,
das ist schlecht.
Und auch, wenn man es konfiguriert,
um einen Drive zu füllen,
dann der nächste,
dann bedeutet das, dass jedes Projekt
von dem individuellen Drive,
von dem es ausgelöst wird,
I.O.-Bottleneck werden kann.
Ich habe auch gedacht,
er verwendet Unraid.
Die stehen neuerdings total auf Unraid.
Also, wie gesagt,
die einfachste Variante ist,
sich einen nackigen Ubuntu-Server,
ein SMS einzurichten
und einen Sammler draufzuhauen.
Fertig.
Das braucht eine halbe Stunde oder so,
dann läuft das.
Inklusive Installation.
Ja.
Ich werde Netdata installieren,
damit wir das Array anschauen können.
Es ist schön, dass es so viel Raum
für Kabelmanagement auf dem Hintergrund gibt,
aber in dem Fall, dass man
so einen dünnen Kabel hat...
Also, der hat da so viele Lüfter drinnen,
wahrscheinlich wird das nicht so warm.
...eine Art und Weise,
auf das Seite-Panel zu drehen.
Das ist nicht so toll.
Es hält, aber...
Oh!
Sieh, das ist, worüber ich rede.
Mit Fest-Knipsen?
Warte mal!
Das ist die Kraft für die Geräte!
Oh, warum ist es so dünn?
Ich habe vorhin missgesprochen.
Ich sagte, das wäre 200 Dollar.
Das ist 200 Dollar ohne Tempered-Glas-Side-Panel.
Was wir natürlich nicht brauchen,
für so ein Build.
Wir benutzen Netdata,
um die Disky-Systeme zu kontrollieren.
Wie? Netdata?
Mag ich überhaupt nicht.
Die Daseinsberechtigung
erschließt sich mir nicht mit Netdata.
Das macht keinen Sinn.
Jetzt, dass wir geupdatet sind,
müssen wir unsere Unraid-Array erstellen.
Die Parody-Disks hier
sind die Kapazität,
mit der wir aufgeben müssen,
um Daten zu verlieren.
Wie? Jetzt haben sie doch Unraid?
Warte, eben haben sie doch noch Proxmox gehabt.
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt.
Eben hatten sie doch noch Proxmox?
Habe ich nicht aufgepasst?
Unraid auf Proxmox,
das wäre ja komplett irgendwie...
Ich fand die Konfiguration vorher
mit ihren drei Parody-Drives
deutlich besser.
Man darf nicht vergessen,
20 Festplatten sind ganz schön viel.
Bei 20 Festplatten
kann es durchaus öfters vorkommen,
dass eine kaputt geht
und alle anderen
müssen perfekt lesbar sein,
dass man recoveren kann,
wenn dann nicht noch
eine zweite kaputt geht.
Also die Chance
bei zwei Parody-Drives
ist wahrscheinlich
nicht so groß.
Gering, aber
ich würde lieber drei nehmen
bei 20 Platten, ganz ehrlich.
Es gibt ja irgendwo diesen schönen
Raid-Ausfall-Rechner.
Muss man jetzt mal eigentlich schauen.
Aber ich würde mich mit drei Parody-Drives
irgendwie wohler fühlen
bei 20 Platten.
Aber aus meiner Erfahrung,
vor allem, wenn man mit sehr großen Daten arbeitet,
wie man es vielleicht macht,
wenn man Fotos reingestellt hat,
kann es ein bisschen auf der dreckigen Seite sein
und ich würde es nicht wirklich dafür verwenden.
Was ich dafür verwenden würde,
ist, wenn ich Virtual Machines
aufnehmen wollte, würde ich all meine VMs
aus einem Raid 1 Set von SSDs
auswählen, die ich in meine M.2-Schlösser plugge.
Oh cool,
sie haben eine neue Feature gebaut,
aufgrund meines Feedbacks.
Was auch immer er da gerade treibt.
Also, wenn wir denken, unsere Clips
könnten nicht größer als 100 GB sein,
dann müssen wir uns darauf achten,
dass wir das inklicken.
Nun, Nikolas hat mir versprochen,
dass das funktionieren wird.
Aber Nikolas hat mir auch zweimal
das falsche Motherboard mitgebracht,
als wir das CPU-Repair-Programm gemacht haben.
Hier ist unser Problem.
Unsere Chassis-Fans fahren auf 700 RPM,
was schön und ruhig ist,
aber es ist einfach nicht genug,
um genug Luft durch all diese...
Man kann es doch garantiert dynamisch einstellen.
Also unterschiedliche Hochregeln.
Was ist das für ein Videobearbeitungsprogramm?
Weiß das jemand von euch?
Was ist?
Was die da verwenden?
Die Premiere?
Ja.
Warum genau haben sie da jetzt einen 10G-Adapter dran gemacht?
Achso, ja, weil parallel. Sie wollen ja ganz viel parallel machen.
Okay, das leuchtet mir ein.
Warum nicht?
Ich wäre eher überrascht, wenn das nicht funktioniert.
Was soll daran nicht funktionieren?
So, es funktioniert gut.
Ja, und wie warm waren jetzt die Platten? Haben sie das gesagt?
Naja, es kostet ordentlich.
Guck mal, allein schon so eine Platte kostet mindestens 500 Euro.
Also sagen wir mal, 5.000, 10.000, oh, das wird aber teuer.
10.000, naja, sagen wir mal so 12.000 Euro müsste das kosten, das von ihm.
Das ist ungefähr über den Daumen gepeilt.
Jetzt hast du die Auswahl. Kaufst du dir ein NAS mit 320TB oder kaufst du dir den neuen Get-on-my-Level-Montana-Pleck-Rechner?
Fragen über Fragen.
Das klingt wie viel Geld.
Aber wenn du es mit einem off-the-shelf-NAS vergleichst,
dann wirst du mehr als 1.000 Dollar für einen mit nur 8 Bays bezahlen.
Und es könnte Spektrums haben, die viel schlechter sind als dieser.
Wobei wir einen 6-Core-Prozessor haben, 16GB RAM, 10GB Netzwerk,
20 Hard-Drives...
Überleg mal, für nur, ich glaub nur 3.500 Euro kriegt ihr einen Klo, der euch den Hintern abspült.
Was ist euch lieber?
2 M.2s und 2 mehr SATA-Drives.
Ja, Linus, ist ja gut.
Das kommt an, was Software für uns am besten funktioniert.
Also, ob du Unraid, FreeNAS, Proxmox oder was auch immer du fliehst,
das ist ein guter Startpunkt, wenn du ein Start-out-Editor bist
und du mit 4K-Fotografie oder wahrscheinlich sogar 8K-Fotografie arbeiten willst,
auch wenn du ein kleines Team hast.
Okay, jetzt kommt's sehr laut.
Ich krieg immer eskaliert über so ein Zeug, ey.
Was haben wir hier sonst noch so?
Was empfiehlt uns YouTube denn noch?
Was? Inferno Wings.
Oh, das klingt scharf.
Das hatten wir schon, das hatten wir schon.
Ey, das, das da, taugt das?
I paid Amazon to upgrade my computer.
Ah, das gucken wir uns das mal an.
Das klingt so ein bisschen nach, wir bestellen uns Leute von Amazon,
die angeblich meinen Rechner upgraden und halt mich scammen.
Is all you need to build a computer a screwdriver?
Yeah.
Yeah?
How do you know how much of a pace to put on?
Have you heard of this motherboard brand, MSI?
MSI, it's a good brand.
They're famous? Okay.
Yeah, I'd be totally lost if I was trying to do this.
Okay, this might be the dumbest idea I've ever had, but today we're going to see if Amazon can install my new motherboard into my gaming PC.
So you know, like, when you check out, you know, when you go to, like, buy something on Amazon, a PC part specifically, it sometimes gives you that option for expert installation, where someone will actually come to your house and do it for you.
Ey, ich würd mir im Leben, ich würd mir im Leben nicht, äh, nen, nen, nen, nen, nen random Technikmann bestellen von Amazon, der einmal im Rechner rumfuddelt.
It was like 81 dollars.
Außer dem, außer dem.
Es ist ganz schön teuer.
Na gut, es ist ein Mainboard, also es ist ein Mainboard.
Das heißt, das verstehe ich, dass es teuer ist.
Da muss ich ja mehr oder weniger den ganzen Rechner auseinanderbauen.
Das ist schon okay.
Okay.
Ja, 기대 mich zum nächsten Mal.
Vielen Dank.
Erstmal, erst mal sell-out.
Nein, hab ich nicht.
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Video-Server, schick mal einen Link.
Was hat er geschrieben?
Okay, das ist der Techniker für das Amazon-Ding.
Okay, wann er am Start, wann er an den Start kommt.
It will cost more.
Das ist, das Scam geht schon los.
Das Scam geht schon los, ja.
Man schließt über Amazon ab, inklusive Treiber-Installation und allem.
Und das Erste, was er dir schreibt, ist, es kostet mehr.
Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an die Inder auf Fiverr,
mit denen ich mal getestet habe, wie gut sie denn was programmieren können.
Die auch geschrieben haben, für 15 Euro machen wir dir eine komplette ASP.NET-Anwendung.
Und als ich ihnen dann geschickt habe, was ich haben will,
habe ich gesagt, nee, das kostet 700.
Ich habe es euch ja gezeigt, ey.
Estimated, der Estimated heißt ja, dass es ungefähr hinkommt.
Also Estimated 80 Euro heißt nicht, es kostet 150.
Das kostet 90, okay, okay.
90 ist okay, wenn es Estimated 80 ist, ja.
Aber 150 nicht.
Hier der acht optedicke 23.
Meine
Frage, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie er aus scheint die Schaut, wie schaut, wie schaut der normalerweise aus?
Ich hab keinen Schumber, ich habe das nicht.
Ich hab keine Ahnungidiieur.
Hä, das sieht doch immer so aus.
What?
Das ist doch kein Unterschied zu sonst.
Das sieht ganz genauso aus wie immer.
Die Mütze.
Ja, die Mütze ist das Einzige.
Das sind wieder so Ami-Zeiten.
Was ist das?
14 Uhr bis 17 Uhr, oder?
Das ist 14 Uhr bis 17 Uhr.
Das heißt, um 16.15 Uhr hat er ihn angerufen, wie es aussieht.
Wow.
Und wie lange braucht der?
Wie lange braucht der?
Drei Stunden?
Dreieinhalb Stunden?
220?
Amazon hat gesagt 80 Euro.
80 Euro hat Amazon...
Also Estimate, da würde ich jetzt sagen, okay, 90 Euro, meinetwegen 100 ist ja noch okay.
Wenn Amazon sagt 80, aber das ist ja das Dreifache.
Das ist fast das Dreifache.
Hast du gesagt, es wäre 220 Dollar für meinen Job?
Ja.
Weil ich auf Amazon geschaut habe, sprach es um 81 Dollar und es sagt, es hat Fahrradinstallationen.
Ich verstehe.
Also es könnte 81 Dollar sein, aber der Techniker könnte an dein Computer schauen und sagen, es sind wirklich 500.
Okay, das macht Sinn.
Ja, das macht Sinn.
Ja, er hat wirklich Sense gemacht.
Klingt gut.
Danke, danke.
Was ist das für eine echte Scheiße?
Warte mal hier.
Lass uns mehr Details finden.
Vielleicht gibt es hier eine gute Präsentation.
Okay, also was sagt es?
In ihrer Verteidigung sagt es, dass die 81 Dollar ein Estimat sind.
Sie sagen dir, dass es ein Estimat ist und subject to change.
Aber was passiert, wenn du darüber hüpfst?
Es sagt, wie funktionieren Estimate?
Pros basieren ihre Estimate auf einem standardischen Skop von Arbeit.
Und 9 aus 10 Kunden sehen keinen Veränderung im finalen Preis.
Ich schätze, ich bin einfach wirklich unglücklich.
Du hast die Chance, die Service-Details zu überprüfen und den finalen Preis mit deinem Pro zu bestätigen, bevor die Arbeit beginnt.
Was total verrückt ist, ist, dass wenn das das Estimat ist für all diese...
Für den Preis hat er sich wirklich das Mailbot zweimal holen können.
Oder eine bessere CPU oder eine Grafikkarte oder sonst was.
Diese sind alle die Services, die ich für meinen Job benötige.
Wie ist die echte Figur, die der Techniker beurteilt hat, fast dreimal so viel?
Warum sollen wir ihn nennen und herausfinden?
Ich hatte eine Frage über...
Irgendwie hat sich der Typ am Telefon gerade ein bisschen angehört wie so ein indischer Scammer.
Oder?
Ich meine, kann es nicht sein, weil der Fall vor Ort ist, aber hat sich ein bisschen so angehört.
Ich denke, es war ungefähr 220 Dollar oder so etwas.
Wow.
Ja.
Wow, das ist viel.
Was er gesagt hat, war, dass...
Moment, hat er jetzt bei Amazon angerufen oder bei dem Anbieter von dem Techniker?
Ist das der Techniker-Anbieter oder ist das Amazon?
Amazon Support? Ah.
Okay, okay.
Kapiert.
81 Dollar ist ein universales Blanket-Preis.
Amazon puts on a variety of their components
and that it's ultimately up to the technician to determine the scope of the project
and change the price accordingly.
Yeah, that's correct, but I think that is excessive.
220.
Let me call the...
And I call your bargain around 10 to 15 minutes.
Immerhin, immerhin kümmert sich der Support drum.
Speak with the...
From another provider.
It's not fair because I'm your computer.
Was?
Moment, ich blick immer durch.
Almost like replacing...
Ja, das ist schon richtig, wenn man das Mailboard tauscht, aber das müsste doch Amazon auch klar sein.
This job is very dedicated.
That's why they consider that the price has to be almost...
When I paid the 81 dollars on Amazon, it says that that service is included in the 81 dollar estimate.
Do you know what I mean?
Yes, I understand that we have to change that because this other technician told me almost the same thing,
that...
This job is more work that we wanted in the...
In the...
Na, zumindest gibt Amazon zu, dass da halt Mist steht.
Das ist doch schon mal nicht schlecht.
Ich meine, dann weißt du wenigstens, woran du bist.
Und wahrscheinlich hätte Amazon auch keine Schmerzen gehabt, wenn du jetzt gesagt hättest,
ey, nee, lass mal cancelen, will ich doch nicht haben.
What you're basically saying is that it's really Amazon's quote of the 81 dollars that they estimate is completely false.
And way off.
Yeah.
I see.
So this is really Amazon's issue.
I was thinking maybe it was one of the technicians...
Yes, at the beginning I think that it was that technician is taking...
Well, in this case it's also asking too much for my end, but...
Yeah, right.
The other technician told me that the first price is around 160 dollars.
Also genau das Doppelte, exakt das Doppelte.
Aber mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich würde keinen random Dude an meinem Rechner rumschrauben lassen,
aber das ist auch was anderes.
Es geht ja hier drum, dass irgendwelche Casual-Leute nicht in der Lage wären, sich selbst ein Mainboard einzubauen.
Yeah, oh my jeez.
Maybe someone higher up on Amazon needs to change that 81 dollar price tag then, you know.
In this case, what I can do for you is that I can buy 50 dollars as promo certificate.
Also eins muss man ja sagen, ja.
Also die geben sich, der Amazon Support gibt sich schon Mühe, ja.
Also ich habe auch schon ein paar Mal bei der Amazon Hotline angerufen.
Die ist ja ein bisschen versteckt in Deutschland.
Bis man die findet.
Die Amazon Hotline, die haben mir bisher auch immer gut geholfen.
Die 220, die...
What you're telling me is that that's probably the best you could do is bring down the cost from 220 to 170,
which is still more than double the estimate that I was told.
Okay.
Sorry for that.
It's just a hard pill to swallow, you know.
Yeah, I completely understand.
Ja, jetzt mach nicht so eine Schleimhaut.
Schau, sag einfach ja.
Ich will wissen, was der Techniker macht.
This whole thing is just getting stupider by the minute.
They're telling customers they can expect to pay roughly 80 dollars for a specific list of services,
when in reality they could be paying up to twice that or more.
Nowhere on Amazon's page does it say, hey, these are estimates, but you might be paying double.
That's just absolutely dishonest.
Wenn das Amazon schreiben würde, würde das wahrscheinlich auch keiner machen.
It probably already has led to so many infuriated and confused customers.
And the best solution that Amazon...
The best solution that Amazon has come up with is to give them a $50 credit towards their Amazon account.
So in the end, I'll have to pay the full $220...
Na, immerhin, immerhin.
In Deutschland hätten viele Anbieter gesagt, so nach dem Motto, ja, wenn sie das nicht wollen, dann kommen wir halt an dich.
...but I'll be receiving a $50 credit towards my Amazon account, which brings my total cost to $170,
which is still more than double the $81 I was expecting to pay.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Wie gesagt, der ist wirklich sehr dedicated.
Also der ist voll bei der Sache, der Techniker.
Oh, ich muss mal kurz hier die Heizung anschalten.
Auf volle Pulle.
Sie kühlen.
18,7 Grad.
Hey.
Hey, yes, how are you?
Carl.
Thanks for coming back.
Zwei Stunden, Alter, was macht der denn da?
Na gut, es ist eine Wasserkühlung, es ist Wasserkühlung.
Wenn du ordentlich aufpasst, okay, aber zwei Stunden ist schon krass viel.
Jetzt schaltet er bestimmt ein, aber es geht nicht mehr.
...and the job is complete.
So let's talk about how it went.
For starters, it probably goes without saying that your mileage may vary here,
depending on the technician that you get.
Each one's probably going to be a little different,
but this was my experience.
So, when George, we'll just call him George,
when George arrived, he was immediately professional.
George sieht irgendwie ein bisschen,
ein bisschen Kokona aus.
Er ist sehr freundlich. Es hat eigentlich meine ganze Meinung über ihn geändert,
erst nach dem Verabschiedungsschaden. Ich werde ihn immer noch halten,
weil ich denke, es hätte besser behandelt werden können. Aber als er hierher kam,
war es wie ein komplettes 180 Grad. Und mein ganzer Wunsch, als ich untergebracht war,
war, dass ich lernen wollte. Ich wollte ihn die ganze Zeit schädeln.
Wissend das, war er tatsächlich sehr hilfreich auf dem Weg. Er zeigte mir kleine Dinge,
gab mir Tipps und erhielt sein Wissen in einem Bereich, in dem ich
Interesse daran hatte, mehr darüber zu lernen.
Wenn du den CPU installieren möchtest, wird er gescheitert.
Also, du musst...
Das finde ich gut, dass er das dem erklärt. Das ist doch top.
...ein bisschen weniger.
Ah, ich verstehe.
Okay.
Außer, dass wir unser erstes Verabschiedungsschaden verabschieden mussten,
war alles über den Techniker aus der Sicht einer Kunden-Service-Stand-Point
in Bezug auf Freundlichkeit und Professionalität 100 Prozent auf dem Punkt.
Wenn er die technischen Sachen betrachtet, als er das System erst sah,
musste ich einen Test-Boot mit einem Monitor verbinden,
um sicherzustellen, dass es richtig funktioniert.
So, dass er, wenn er seine Arbeit beendet und das System nicht postet,
er weiß und kann bemerken, dass es kein vorhandenes Problem mit dem System war.
Also habe ich es gebootet. Natürlich hat es funktioniert.
Es wurde in Windows gebootet. Kein Problem. Das war alles, was er sehen musste.
Also hat er den System geschlossen, die Peripherale ausgestattet und gearbeitet.
Das erste, was er gemacht hat, war, das Motherboard abzuschalten.
Er hat die Grafikkarte, die Memory, den AIO, den Wasserblock entfernt.
Er hat die CPU im Motherboard befestigt, als er das Ganze aus dem Case entfernt hat.
Sobald das Board raus war, habe ich ihm das neue Motherboard und die CPU angeboten.
Das ist wiederum ein Ryzen 9 3900X und ein MSI B450 Tomahawk Max.
Tomahawk Max.
Er hat mir nur eines gefragt. Er hat gesagt...
Du hast bemerkt, dass die CPU mit dem Motherboard kompatibel ist, oder?
Ja. Und ich habe das so geblieben.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, ja, aber du wirst einen BIOS-Update brauchen, um es richtig zu funktionieren.
Ich habe das nur von einem normalen Joe, einem nicht technisch gewachsenen Kunden gehört,
der das nicht wissen würde.
Ich habe wirklich nur sein Wissen getestet.
Um zu sehen, ob er mir das fragen würde.
Aber er hat es nie getan. Er hat nur gefragt, ob es kompatibel ist.
Ich habe gesagt, ja.
Also hat er weitergearbeitet.
An einem Punkt hatte er ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten, das Board in das Case zu befestigen,
weil er das I.O. Schild umgekehrt hat.
Aber ich habe es nicht herausgefunden.
Ich habe es ihm selbst herausgefunden, was er schnell gemacht hat.
In etwa 30 Sekunden oder so.
Oh mein Gott, ich habe das hier geschaut.
Oh, war das nach hinten?
Ja.
Ich habe es umgekehrt, das Board ist rein.
Er hat es umgekehrt.
Und dann hat er einfach angefangen, Dinge zu befestigen.
Er hat das AIO umgekehrt.
Ich wollte zurück auf die CPU gehen.
Er hat ein riesiges...
Wohohoho.
Pfff.
Er hat so eine runde Wärme, da hast du drauf gerotzt, Alter.
Das ist schon ordentlich.
Na gut.
Mehr schadet ja selten, ne?
Läuft halt ein bisschen eben raus, aber...
Ich habe noch nicht die Temps geschaut.
Ich bin mir sicher, sie sind in Ordnung.
Aber ich denke, es war ein bisschen gratuitös.
Es war wie Verge-Status.
Ernsthaft.
Sobald das Board auf den Stand-Off wurde,
hat er versucht, Dinge zurück in das Board zu befestigen.
Aber weil es ein anderes Board ist,
mit seinen Verbindungen in verschiedenen Bereichen,
als das letzte Board,
musste er einige Dinge zurückdrehen,
passen Kabel durch,
verschiedene Auslösungen,
die sie ursprünglich durchgeroutet haben,
und so weiter.
Aber er hat das alles mit wenig Schwierigkeiten gemacht.
Es gab einen Witz, den er hatte.
Er hatte keine Ahnung, was mit einem USB-Kabel zu tun hat,
das vom AIO-Waterblock
zum USB-2.0-Header auf dem Board geht.
Ist das ein weiterer Fan-Kabel?
Nein, das ist ein USB-Kabel.
Ich habe es nicht gesehen.
Ich musste ihn hier in die richtige Richtung bewegen,
ich habe ihm nicht genau gesagt, wo es war,
aber ich habe meinen Finger auf den AIO gelegt
und dachte mir, vielleicht kommen hier Kabel raus.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das...
Ist das das Strom?
Ist das das Stromkabel für die Wasserkühlung?
Oder was ist das für ein Stromkabel,
für ein USB-Kabel, was der da hat?
Das habe ich jetzt nicht kapiert.
Ah, das ist Strom.
Okay, dann ist es Strom für die Wasserkühlung.
Und dann hat er seinen Finger genutzt
und hat sich um die Seite des Wasserblockes gefühlt,
um zu sehen, ob es Porte gibt,
und dann hat er den Micro-USB-Port gefunden
und hat gesagt, oh, ich glaube, es geht hier hin.
Und das war das erste, was er mir vorher gesagt hat,
dass er nicht so oft auf Gaming-PCs arbeitet.
Die meisten seiner Klientel,
ob es durch Amazon oder wo auch immer,
sind Mac-Händler oder Apple-Händler.
Moment, Moment, Apple-Händler?
Apple-Händler kaufen sich Einbauservices?
Da kannst du doch überhaupt nichts einbauen dran.
Was willst du an Apple-Rechnern großartig einbauen?
Früher konntest du da einen RAM-Riegel reinstecken.
Ich glaube, das geht heute noch nicht mal mehr.
Da gibt es doch überhaupt nichts zu bauen.
RAM geht das noch, okay.
Dongle-Service, genau.
Das braucht man unbedingt.
Ich habe die beiden Memory-Sticks in den falschen Dim-Slots installiert.
Ich habe das gerade auf dem Backpunkt bemerkt,
aber ich habe nichts gesagt.
Und es scheint, dass ich nicht gebraucht habe.
Wir werden das in ein bisschen Zeit zurückgehen.
Aber nachdem das,
denke ich, sind wir schon bereit, loszulegen.
Bevor wir über Booting sprechen,
wollte ich anzeigen,
dass er den Kabel-Management-Takt gemacht hat.
Auf der Rückseite ist es eigentlich nicht so schlecht.
Er hat einige Zip-Tie, einige Tweezers, ausgemacht.
Diese klaren sind die, die er gemacht hat.
Und er hat einfach nur einen kurzen Routing-Takt gemacht.
Es sieht eigentlich ein bisschen besser aus,
als es vorher war.
Also, er hat nicht gesagt, dass er das macht.
Bis jetzt ist es doch gar nicht ganz okay.
Ich sehe da überhaupt keinen Unterschied,
außer dass hier die Dinger so sind und da mal so.
Aber ansonsten sehe ich da keinen Unterschied.
Also, wenn wir hier drüber schauen,
dann sehen wir, dass wir ein paar Dinge festgenommen haben.
Wie die Kabel hier,
siehst du, wie die Dinger miteinander über΄heben?
Das war nicht so, wie es vorher war.
Aber wenn er nicht angemacht wird,
auf Gaming-PCs zu arbeiten,
dann ist das wohl nicht so.
Das macht dem Kabel jetzt nichts.
Wir werden ihm als ein potenzieller Eyesore zeigen.
Er merkt nicht,
dass das ein Kabel-Trainer ist,
der die Kabel gerade drüber und überheben soll.
Dinge wie das.
Der Wasserblock-Takt,
vielleicht hätte es besser geroutet gewesen.
Hätte er diesen Kabel durch hier geroutet,
oder so etwas.
Aber für 220 Dollar, also der Typ hat zwei Stunden da rum gemacht, da sind 220 Dollar eigentlich vollkommen in Ordnung.
Also bis jetzt würde ich nicht sagen, It's a Scam, der Techniker hat doch.
Ja, boah.
Das ist aber cool, das ist cool, dass das Mainboard einem das sagt, ohne Scheiß.
Früher hat der Kram entweder einfach nur gepiepst oder es ging und war halt performance-mäßig nicht optimal.
Das ist cool, dass er einem das sagt.
Du hast ja was ich mich frage, wenn er das Bios hätte flashen müssen, ja, und der Rechner hätte nicht funktioniert, wie hätte er sich einen USB-Stick gemacht zum Bios flashen?
Oder kann man aus dem Bios, oder kann man aus dem Bios rausflaschen?
Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass man das Bios flashen kann.
Wenn die CPU drinnen ist, mit der es nicht bootet. Also müsste der die CPU nochmal wechseln.
Der hätte länger gebraucht als eine halbe Stunde dafür.
Ja, XSUNNY kann man machen, allerdings wenn die CPU drinnen ist, wo der Rechner nicht mehr bootet, kann man ja halt nicht ins BIOS.
Bootet er mit der falschen CPU auch ins BIOS?
Aber wenn er jetzt bis ins BIOS booten kann, dann funktioniert die CPU ja.
Keine Ahnung, hab ich noch nie gemacht.
Klingt erstmal jetzt unlogisch, dass wenn das Menü...
Wenn man die CPU nicht supportet, dass er dann überhaupt bootet.
Würde mich auch wundern, wenn er bootet.
Kommt man nicht sogar ohne CPU ins BIOS? Nö.
Dann wird angezeigt, dass keine CPU installiert wurde. Wie wollen die das machen ohne CPU?
Wahrscheinlich hängt es ein bisschen davon ab.
Vielleicht hängt es ein bisschen davon ab.
Ich würde es nicht.
Ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn Mainboards nicht heute noch einen kleinen Controller drauf hätten, um Fehlermeldung anzeigen zu können, wenn die CPU nicht geht.
In den eigenen Chip bringt der nichts. Du brauchst deine eigene CPU.
Flashen ohne CPU geht halt auch nicht.
Irgendjemand muss ja den Kram berechnen.
Das Flashen machen.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es vielleicht schon Mainboards gibt, die irgendwie einen kleinen Controller drauf haben.
Der quasi auch...
...funktioniert und das Mainboard managen kann, wenn keine CPU drin ist. Würde mich nicht wundern.
Ich meine, bei Sorbern ist das gang und gäbe. Da gibt es ein komplettes Management Interface.
Was unabhängig vom Rest funktioniert.
...because he didn't do any driver installation or have to do a clean install of windows or anything like that.
He did deduct $20 off of the total price, which meant I paid $200 out the door to have my motherboard and CPU upgraded.
From start to finish it took him about an hour and 45 minutes to complete the task.
...from start to finish it took him about an hour and 45 minutes to complete the task.
...which I thought was perfectly reasonable, definitely a lot faster than the initial three hours he had quoted me.
Also ganz ehrlich, man muss mal sagen, it's a scam.
Also der Techniker war doch jetzt echt nicht schlecht, oder?
Jetzt mal Chat.
Der hat 2 Stunden rumgebastelt, am Ende hat es 220 Euro gekostet.
Und Amazon hat vorher auch zugegeben, es ist Mist, was sie hingeschrieben haben.
Sie haben ihm noch einen Gutschein gegeben.
Also, das macht mir ganz okay, macht einen guten Eindruck.
Also ich sehe jetzt da nicht das große Problem drin.
Am ehesten, am ehesten noch ein Scam von Amazon.
Aber so wirklich Scam insofern ist es auch nicht, weil sie haben ihm das sofort gesagt.
Sie haben ihm das sofort gesagt, noch bevor.
Ein Scam wäre es gewesen, wenn er das gemacht hätte und danach gesagt hätte, ey, jetzt hätte ich gerne 220 Euro.
Also eigentlich ist daran nichts Scam.
Näh.
Näh, näh.
So, was wollen wir als nächstes angucken hier?
Wollen wir uns nochmal den Test zum Plague Mesa Remake angucken?
Allerdings, wie gesagt, wir müssen uns, eigentlich müssen wir uns den Test nicht angucken, weil wir haben es selbst durchgespielt im Stream schon.
Also fast, fast durchgespielt.
Äh, was hast du denn beim Link bekommen?
Äh, what?
Wann, wo?
Näh.
Hab ich nicht.
Battlefield.
Ich glaube, das Video haben wir schon mal geguckt.
Von 2017.
Spying on the Scammers.
Oh, das ist ja ein ewig langes Video.
Ach, das ist, das sind irgendwelche indischen Scammer, die hier gebetet werden.
So, Heizung wieder aus.
Dennoch, Leute, die Seite mit den Flaschen habe ich gesehen, dass das auch ohne CPU funktioniert.
So, dann lassen wir uns mal von Level Cap, den habe ich schon ewig nichts mehr geguckt, von erklären, warum Battlefield 3 so nice war.
Gibt's viele, gibt's viele Punkte, warum Battlefield 3 nice war.
Mal gucken, was Level Cap dazu sagt.
Ist Level Cap eigentlich noch angesagt?
Großartig, was hat er so, was macht er aktuell für, für Games?
Was macht er aktuell für Games?
Division.
Division, igitt.
Battlefield 5, Rainbow Six.
Wie gab's denn da sonst noch? Es gab Level Cap und wie hieß der andere Dude, Jack, Jack Frax, ne?
Gab's da noch früher, wo die so Battlefield-mäßig voll am, voll am Start waren.
Oh, der Mesh ist gefeatured.
Äh, gibt's den, gibt's den anderen noch?
Was, was macht der so, was macht der so?
Warface.
Fuck.
Okay, der ist anscheinend noch deutlich angesagter als der andere.
Der macht's auch ein bisschen, der hat, der hat ein bisschen, bisschen mehr Variation drin, ne?
Der macht Modern Warfare, der macht Battlefield, der macht irgendwie ein bisschen, bisschen Star Wars Gedöns, Pupke, CSGO, Rainbow Six, der hat ein bisschen mehr Variation drin.
Hey Leute, Level Cap hier. Heute machen wir ein bisschen ein Throwback-Video. Wir werden Battlefield 3 anschauen.
Ich hab schon ganz vergessen, wie wir das hier anhören.
Ähm, über die Improvements kann man sich jetzt streiten.
Äh, schon gelesen, dass 2020 zwei neue Fachrichtungen zum Fachinformatiker dazukommen.
Ne, ne, hab ich nicht gelesen.
Oh Leute, wir müssen übrigens später noch einen Test machen.
Und zwar, es gibt jetzt von der Telekom, der Telekom Karriere, Karriere Matcher oder sowas, gibt es von denen?
Ähm, Karriere Matcher.
Da kann man nämlich, äh, im Vorfeld...
Der Karriere Matcher, das müssen wir, das müssen wir gleich mal machen.
Da kann man, da muss man nämlich ein paar Fragen beantworten und kriegt dann raus, ob man zur Telekom passt.
Den machen wir gleich, den machen wir gleich nach dem Battlefield-Video.
Wie, ob, ob wir die Magenta-DNA haben, genau.
Was war das andere? Die Magenta-DNA?
Und, ähm, was war das andere?
We love Magenta, we are Magenta.
Ne, wie, wie, wie, wie?
Wie hieß der andere Hashtag?
Die hatten so zwei richtig Fremdschämen, äh, Fremdschämen, äh, Fremdschämen-Hashtags am Start.
Magenta-DNA und was war das andere?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Ich, keine Ahnung.
Okay, was? 2020 gibt es neue, neue Fachinformatiker, äh, ähm, Richtungen.
Fachrichtungen oder, wie soll man das nennen?
Neuordnung IT-Berufe, okay.
Zeig mal her.
Ähm, okay, oh, es gibt, es gibt tatsächlich noch, Heiser, ach, gibt's das, gibt's das ab, gibt's das heute?
Fachinformatiker, hier, neue IT-Berufe.
Zum 1. August 2020 werden die...
Äh, okay, also, was gibt's denn?
IT-Systemkaufmann, IT-Systemelektor, IT-Fachinformatiker, gut, das werden immer weniger, ja, das macht keiner, macht auch keiner gerne.
Ja, Update nach 23 Jahren, stimmt, das ist schon uralt, ne.
Also, ich hab mal das hier gelernt, vor 5, 13, 13 Jahren, schon bis hierher.
Ähm, okay, und wo, wo steht jetzt, was es gibt?
Bin ich jetzt blöd? Wo steht's denn, was ist, was ist?
Ach, hier, hier.
Wer hätte einfach, wer hätte einfach mal so eine Tabelle machen können?
Heiser, Alter, wie, das kann auch kein Mensch erkennen auf den ersten Blick.
Okay, ähm, der Ausbildungsbüro Fachinformatiker, der bisher in den beiden...
Fachrichtungen Anwendungsentwicklung und Systemintegration gewählt werden kann,
wird um die beiden Fachrichtungen Daten- und Prozessanalyse und digitale Vernetzung ergänzt.
Gut Job, IHK, man hat anhand des Namens schon mal keine Ahnung, was es sein soll.
Das habt ihr gut gemacht.
Ähm, anstelle der bisherigen Zwischen- und Abschlussprüfung werden Ausbilder künftig eine sogenannte gestreckte Abschluss...
What?
Oh, oh, oh, das wird für, das wird für einige ziemlich sacken, Alter.
Oh, oh, oh, das wird für einige ziemlich sacken.
Das heißt, dass auch die Leistungen der Zwischenprüfung zur Abschlussnote beitragen.
Oh, das ist für, aber das ist, Leute, seid beruhigt, das ist nur für welche, die neu anfangen anscheinend.
Das ist nur für Leute, die neu anfangen.
Ich glaube, für Leute, die dieses Jahr noch anfangen, letztes Jahr angefangen haben, ist das egal.
Ähm, das ist für manche schlecht.
Aktuell ist die Zwischenprüfung absolut irrelevant.
Du kannst in der Zwischenprüfung nur 6 haben und das ist vollkommen wurscht.
Aktuell ist die Zwischenprüfung nur dafür da, dass man sehen kann, wie gut man mit IHK-Prüfungen durchkommt.
Äh, Matt, es ist alles an der Ausbildung easy.
Es ist nichts schwieriges, an keinem, aber trotzdem fallen Leute durch.
Berufsschule ist, Berufsschule ist, ist wirklich...
Easy as fuck.
Easy.
Und auch die Ausbildung an sich, rein was die IHK will, ist easy as fuck.
Das, was es kompliziert macht, ist je nachdem, was die Firma, wo du bist oder der Betrieb von dir will.
So.
Äh, also was schreiben die hier?
3 Jahre ist normal.
Teil 1 der Prüfung mit 20% Gewichtung.
Prüfungsbereich 1.
Einrichten eines Artikels...
Ist das euer Ernst?
Sind die bei der IHK...
...jeglichen Realitätsbezug verloren?
Einrichten eines IT-gestützten Arbeitsplatzes.
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Das hat doch mit dem Inhalt, was Fachinformatiker heute machen, absolut nichts mehr zu tun.
Klar, du hast natürlich immer noch die ein oder anderen IT-Support-Leute.
Aber 98% der Leute haben damit überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Einricht...
Oh, meine Fresse, Alter.
Eure Parallelklasse ist...
...fast voller First-Level-Supporter.
Mein Beileiter.
Okay, also, was gibt's Teil 2 der Prüfung?
Betriebliche Projektarbeit.
Gut, das ist ja normal.
Das war ja früher auch so.
Berufsspezifische Aufgabe.
Wieso?
Ich brauch den Kotz-Emoji.
Ah, hier kommt die Beschreibung.
Hier kommt die Beschreibung, was die alles machen.
Also, Anwendungsentwicklung und Systemintegration.
Die gab's ja schon.
So, was machen die Neue?
Digitale Vernetzung.
Arbeiten mit der Netzwerkinfrastruktur und den Schnittstellen zwischen Netzwerkkomponenten und Cyber...
Was ein Satz.
Cyberphysisch...
Was ist mit der IHK eigentlich los?
Ich mein, es ist ja nicht so, als hätte...
...als gibt's in der IT-Welt nicht schon zu viele Buzzwords und Bullshit-Sätze.
Aber das da ist doch nicht mal ein Buzzword.
Das ist irgendwas, was sich die IHK ausgedacht hat.
Diese Bezeichnung hab ich noch nie...
...nie gehört.
Noch nie im Leben hab ich diese Bezeichnung gehört.
Und ich mach das schon seit über 13 Jahren.
Ich hab's noch wirklich noch nie gehört.
Cyberphysischen System.
Was soll das überhaupt sein?
Ich kann mir da nichts drunter vorstellen.
Niklas2, der Benutzer, hat bereits für 5 Monate abonniert.
Huge Brain, Dankeschön.
Huge Sub.
Cyberphysischen System, was auch immer.
Sie vernetzen und optimieren Systeme und Anwendungen auf IT.
Sie sichern Daten gegen unerlaubte Zugriffe und vermeiden behebende Systemausfälle.
Das ist eigentlich genau das, was du hier unter anderem als Systemintegrator auch lernen solltest.
Guck, vernetzte IT-Systeme.
Was auch immer.
Was auch immer sich die IHK da überlegt habt.
Oh, es gibt einen Wikipedia-Eintrag für Cyberphys, ernsthaft?
Es gibt ernsthaft einen Wikipedia-Eintrag dafür, krasser Scheiße.
So, äh, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Fachrichtung, Daten- und Prozessanalyse.
Das klingt mir so nach, will ich, als ob ich das auf keinen Fall machen will.
Ähm, entwickeln auf Basis der Verfügbarkeit sowie Qualität und Quantität von...
Was?
IT-technische Lösungen für zunehmend von Daten angetriebenen digitalen Prozessen.
Okay, nochmal.
Fachinformatiker, Fachinformatikerinnen der Fachrichtung.
Daten- und Prozessanalyse entwickeln auf der Basis der Verfügbarkeit sowie Qualität und Quantität von Daten
IT-technische Lösungen für zunehmend von Daten angetriebenen digitalen Produktions- und Geschäftsprozessen.
Ah, yes, exzellent, exzellent, alles klar, alles klar, da weißt du sofort.
Also das ist, Leute, wenn ihr sowas lernen wollt und es fragt euch in Zukunft einer
und was, was, äh, stellt euch das an?
Was, äh, stellen Sie sich von Ihrem Ausbildungsberuf, was, äh, was stellen Sie sich in Ihrer Ausbildung so vor?
Da sagst du, ja, also ich über, ich, ich stelle mir vor, als Fachinformatiker der Fachrichtung Daten- und Prozessanalyse
entwickle ich auf Basis der Verfügbarkeit sowie Qualität und Quantität von Daten in Zukunft
IT-technische Lösungen für zunehmend von Daten angetriebenen digitalen Produktions- und Geschäftsprozessen.
Da sagen die, bam, sie haben den Job, ganz klar.
Das ist ein Geschwätze, ey.
Das ganze IHK-Zeug ist so unglaublich unsinniger Crap, äh.
Äh.
Das Ganze ist komplett sinnlos, lernst du nix.
Der ganze IHK-Apparat ist voll für'n Arsch.
Ich hab schon, ich hab schon oft genug erzählt, wie sie mich durch die Abschlussprüfung haben durchfallen lassen,
weil ich angeblich meine Dokumentation nicht abgegeben habe und, ähm, obwohl ich sie eingereicht hab.
Ja, ich hab, ich hab schon öfters erzählt, den ganzen Scheiß, ja.
Die ganze Kackladen, ja.
So, wir gucken uns jetzt das Battlefield-Video fertig an.
Wir ignorieren die IHK jetzt einfach.
WWL-Geblubber, ja, genau so liest sich das.
Ich hab dazu übrigens auch mal ein Video gemacht, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Mal gucken, ob der ähnliche Sachen sagt wie ich.
Ihr habt dazu auch ein Video gemacht, fällt mir gerade ein.
Mal, wann war, wann war das?
Februar 2018.
Wie, wie viel Aufrufe hat meins?
Hallo, Jungs und Mädels.
81.000 und wie viel hat...
Okay.
Level-Cap hat das Zehnfache.
Na gut.
...
Gucken wir mal. Ich mach's schon mal auf.
Gucken wir uns das nächste Mal an.
When Rush was good. Oh ja.
Du meinst das hier, ne?
Hi guys.
When Rush was good.
Ja, tja, da hat er recht.
Mittlerweile ist Rush
Ist Rush überhaupt im Game?
Es gab ja mal diese
Es gab ja mal Rush
kurzzeitig. Ich weiß nicht, ob das immer noch so
drin ist.
Sune fragt, ich nutze
derzeit, oder sagt, ich nutze
derzeit PhoneGap, um eine App
zu basteln. Stehe nun vor der
Frage, wie und welche Datenbank
ich nutzen möchte.
Bin mit nur HTML und
JavaScript. Ich hab PhoneGap noch nie
verwendet.
Local Storage?
Wenn das reines JavaScript ist?
Ich hab's noch nie verwendet. Kein Schimmer.
Ich verwende immer gerne
SQLite, wenn das so eine simple
Geschichte ist. SQLite ist für simple Sachen
eigentlich so das Beste.
Ich weiß aber nicht, wie es mit SQLite
für Apps und
für Apps aussieht.
Keine Ahnung. Ehrlich, legit kein Schimmer.
Wenn es aber HTML
JavaScript ist, das ist fast wahrscheinlich
nur ein Browser in der eigenen
Browser als App ist, kann sich einfach
Local Storage irgendwas speichern.
Ich meine das Video, das dir bei YouTube
oben rechts, Hype and Masterpiece
Hype and Masterpiece
Das ist das, was ich
mehr oder weniger auch über das Game gesagt hab
in meinem Video, wo es um das Thema ging.
Einfach, dass das Game genau zur
richtigen Zeit rauskam und die Erwartungen
erfüllt hat. Und es hat
kaum ein Battlefield Game
so lange so einen Hype gehabt wie
Battlefield 3 am Stück und so viele
interessierte Spieler. Die Spieler
waren in Battlefield 3 eingeloggt
bis zum Tag, wo Battlefield 4 released wurde
und danach ging es abwärts.
Ich würde auch Battlefield 3 sagen, wobei ich
hin und her gerissen zwischen
Bad Company 2 und Battlefield 3, aber
wahrscheinlich würde ich auch Battlefield 3 sagen.
... really revived the Battlefield
franchise for me in a very
big way and I like
so many things about the gameplay.
First of all, the damage model in the
game was simple, it was straightforward,
it was incredibly quick, which
made the importance of peeking and map
knowledge kind of a priority.
Das stimmt, hat er recht.
... very important in Battlefield 3.
All the weapons did so much more damage in this game compared to previous Battlefield games that you had to be on point.
Not only did you have to react quickly to your enemies, but you weren't really going to mess around with things like grenades or other gadgets unless it really made sense.
I wasn't often switching to my grenade mid-firefight.
I would only throw my grenade from behind cover when I know my enemies didn't have line of sight on me.
Because when somebody has line of sight on you in this game, you don't last long enough to throw a grenade.
You die incredibly fast.
And I really liked this focus on the gunplay.
It made it so that you weren't dying all the time to grenades or silly gadgets, but you really had your priority on weapon mechanics, aiming for the body, aiming for the head.
Now, of course, this could go away depending on the map.
Ja, Headshots waren so ein bisschen problematisch in Battlefield 3.
Vor allem hier, wenn die Leute über Sachen drüber gesprungen sind, weil halt die Gegner komplett hin und her gejumpt sind mit den teilweise schlecht interpolierten Animationen.
Der ist hier drüber gesprungen und hat dann gemacht zick, zick, zick.
Und dann...
Da konntest du nicht wirklich gescheit aimen.
Deswegen, im besten Battlefield 3 war einfach irgendwo, irgendwo draufsprayen auf den Körper und, und...
Gut war.
...Operation Metro was a bit of a clusterfuck to say the least.
And there are certainly lots of grenades in C4 in that game.
But at the same time, a decent amount of shooting mechanics as well.
Now, another thing that I think this game did an incredibly good job of was the armor versus infantry balance.
Ja, das stimmt.
You couldn't just hop into an M1 Abrams and expect to go on some sort of crazy kill spree.
You actually had to have...
Das stimmt.
...to do well with the tank, which I always appreciated.
A good engineer could solo a tank who wasn't very good at driving a tank.
You would do this often, in fact.
A lot of novices would get in the tanks, not really understand that they had to work together with their team in order to push up,
use friendly infantry to cover them, have a secondary gunner in their tank to hop out and repair at the key moments.
There was so much more teamwork involved with tanking in this game than there was in, say, Battlefield 1.
Und das ist etwas, was ich wirklich, wirklich genieße und genieße, wenn ich zurückkehre.
Ja, ja, Serious World, das stimmt.
Das lag auf jeden Fall auch an den Maps, aber auch das Handling von den Panzern.
Muss ich sagen, in Battlefield 4 auch.
Aber ich fand's auch cool, so Sachen mit Canister Shell und Main Gun switchen und sowas.
Man konnte ja dann auch switchen auf den Gunner Seed und solche Geschichten.
Am besten war natürlich, wenn du noch einen dabei hast, der dich repariert hat.
Also die Leute, die ja aktiv Panzer gespielt haben in dem Team, die haben ja dann auch teilweise...
...Zwei Panzer.
...Zwei Leute gehabt, die repariert haben.
Das war schon cool.
Und du konntest ja auch, wenn du richtig nice warst, konntest du ja auch mit deinem Tank Javelins ausweichen.
Konnte ich nie.
Ich geb da Videos zu.
Also man konnte Javelins ausweichen mit seinem Panzer, wenn man das richtig getimt hat.
Und das war aber wirklich schwer.
Man konnte nicht mit großen Zeugnagel oder Dmr machen, mehr als mit einem anderen.
Aber ich fand auch, dass sich die Zerstörung in Battlefield 3 auch richtig angefühlt.
Ja, sie war nicht so übertrieben, dass man gesagt hat Man brauchen jetzt feste Punkte auf der Map, die Revolution machen, sondern sie war halt einfach da, aber halt nicht so übertrieben in your face um geil zu sein, sondern sie war einfach da und hat gut funktioniert.
Man konnte auch nicht alles killen, was auch sehr sinnvoll war, weil die Struktur der Map musste vorhanden werden.
vorhanden bleiben.
Also, ne, das war ja im Prinzip
die Zerstörung von Bad Company 2
zu Battlefield 3 war ja
insofern an manchen Stellen ein Rückschritt, dass man
keine Häuser mehr einstürzen lassen konnte.
Ähm,
bis auf manche, ne, manche Häuser,
wobei, ich glaube, manche Häuser
gingen in Battlefield 3 kaputt
zu machen, oder?
Ich glaube, manche Sachen gingen noch
kaputt, aber die, also,
Häuser mit einer Treppe gingen definitiv nicht
kaputt. Alle Häuser mit einer Treppe
wusstest du, die sind safe vorm Einstürzen. Du konntest
nur die Mauern kaputt schießen.
Und, ähm, das fand ich eigentlich
ganz cool. Bad Company 2
war halt nice, dass du die Häuser einstürzen lassen konntest,
aber du hattest in Bad Company 2 oftmals
das Problem, Bad Company 2 hat halt viele
relativ große
Natur, äh,
naturbezogene Maps, also hier
Waldparaiso oder Pornwall, das halt
ähm, sehr, sehr Environment
basiert und wenn da halt alle Häuser weg waren,
da war halt flach, da ging nix mehr.
Und das war hier
eigentlich ganz gut.
Ja, Eureka-Harbour-TDM ist
auch so ein Ding, ja genau.
Ich fand auch den, ich fand auch den
Medic-Spam in Battlefield 3 gut.
Ich mein, es war so, es war,
es hatte Nachteile,
muss man auch klar sagen.
Dieses Dauer-Rats-Train-Geschichte
war nicht jedermanns Fall in Battlefield 3.
Was ich allerdings gut fand, und was so noch
kein anderes Battlefield-Spiel gepackt hat,
dadurch, dass,
dass Medic eigentlich
so pauschal erstmal, wenn man nicht wusste, was man
picken sollte, oder nicht situationsbedingt
gepickt hat, hat man Medic gepickt,
oder Assault gepickt, immer. Das war
so erstmal die, die, die, die beste
Allround-Klasse in dem ganzen, wenn nicht
die beste Klasse im ganzen Spiel.
Ähm, und dementsprechend
war halt auch an jeder Ecke irgendein
Medic am Start, und ich wurde in keinem
Battlefield-Spiel davor und in keinem
Battlefield-Spiel danach so oft
wiederbelebt wie in Battlefield 3.
Und das hat dem Teamplay und dem Fluss,
und der Geschwindigkeit, und alles echt gut
genommen.
Das stimmt.
Das stimmt. Suppression war auch immer
einer der Faktoren, wo ich gesagt hab, die könnten wir ein bisschen
zurückschrauben. Die fand ich auch zu übertrieben.
Ähm.
Erinnert ihr euch noch, erinnert ihr euch noch an die Taschenlampen
am Anfang?
Die, die so als sie ins Gesicht
geleuchtet haben, als wäre vor die gerade die Sonne aufgegangen.
Battlefield 3 machte es
am besten, oder am schlechtesten, äh,
abhängig von deiner Perspektive.
Und dann hatten sie auch, äh, wirklich, äh,
blaue Sonnenlampen, oder Sonnenlampen,
die auf deinem Bildschirm auftauchen würden.
Die Devs, oder eher der Künstler,
wollten wirklich, dass dieses Spiel
wie ein Film aussieht, und das kann
auf eine Art cool sein, außer wenn
du ein Spiel spielst, das höchst taktisch ist
und skillorientiert ist, und die
visuellen Effekte sind einfach nur
im Weg von deiner Fähigkeit und Strategie.
Und das haben sie viel in Battlefield 3 gemacht.
Wahrscheinlich eine der größten
Begrüßungen dieses Spiels während
ihres Lebens waren die Dinge wie die blaue Tinte
und die Sonne und die Solarflasche.
Was?
Äh. Ah, eben hat's grad
ein bisschen Frames getroppt anscheinend.
Naja, Unity Media wieder.
... und all that kind of stuff.
Now, something that is kind of funny to go back to...
Äh, um die Frage zu beantworten, hier von Michael eben
im Chat, ähm,
er hat gefragt, Max, würdest du es einem
empfehlen, den PC ab und zu neu
aufzusetzen, also komplett platt machen,
halt? Nö. Warum?
Wenn alles funktioniert, gibt's überhaupt keinen Grund.
...
in Battlefield 3,
it was kind of ridiculous
comparing the classes to each other.
Especially in TDM, everybody's
playing the assault class.
There's almost no
reason for any other class.
The fact that games like Battlefield 1
have tried to put a much bigger emphasis
on the other classes and the teamwork aspect
of it is a good step
in the right direction. In addition to that,
some of the nuances that I think we take for
granted in Battlefield 1
do become quite annoying when going
back to the old titles, now that you're
used to the new system. One of the things
that probably annoyed me the most was
the fact that if you're not shooting a suppressed weapon
in Battlefield 3, you pop up on
the minimap with all of the enemies.
This is the same as it was in Battlefield 4 as well.
Über das Spotting in
Battlefield 3 konnte man sich echt streiten.
Also das Spotting auch in Bad Company 2,
das war schon hart OP. Wenn du Leute
teilweise durch den Rauch gespottet hast und du
quasi weniger Gegner
beschossen hast, du hast
mehr Dreiecke beschossen als
Gegner. Durch Büsche, durch
alles durch. Das war
wirklich ein bisschen fragwürdig.
Battlefield 1 thankfully
did away with this system. Since there are no
suppressors in Battlefield 1, there wasn't
anything you could do to mask yourself on the minimap.
But I hope they carry this practice forward
even if they do reintroduce suppressors
in some sort of modern Battlefield game
as it was sort of an overpowered
mechanic or it just put a huge emphasis
on minimap gameplay rather
than actually just looking on your screen
to try and find the enemies. Player movement
in this game also feels a little bit glitchy
at times, often trying to jump up on
objects or over ledges or curves.
Wobei ich halt dieses
checken, quasi so die Informationen
die man hat und im Kopf halt
quasi so routen
und wie man am besten lang geht,
fand ich nicht schlecht.
You get stuck on a lot of things.
Ja, guck mal, hier weißt du, hier weißt du zum Beispiel,
der läuft jetzt da oder läuft da.
Das heißt, du gehst dahin und schaust,
dass du beides abdeckst. Also, das hat er auch,
das hat er auch seinen Charme, dass du mehr
Informationen über die Minimap hattest.
Definitely been refined a lot in more modern
Battlefield games. But one thing that I definitely
appreciate about this is that the
ADAD spam is pretty much
non-existent in Battlefield 3.
You can't sidestrafe back and forth
quickly at all, which means when players
see each other, they have to stop or they have to
jump and then stop and really
focus on gunning the other person down.
So there's not going to be a lot of dodging in
Firefights. It's about position, placement
and peeking at the right time as
opposed to fancy footwork. So
overall, the Battlefield franchise has made
considerable improvements
over the years. Battlefield 1
feels light years beyond this
game in terms of performance,
netcode, visual quality.
There's so much stuff that has really
come a long way in the franchise.
But I still like Battlefield 3 the best,
simply for the gun, but
I like the extremely
fast time to kill, the fact that
arms don't have a multiplier so that
you can down your opponents
in a very predictable way, allowing
one soldier to take on three, four,
even five opponents
if they're on point. I really liked
...
Oh ja, bester, bester.
Damavand Peak Rush.
Ja, war doch nice.
Gebe ich ihn zum Kostenteil recht?
So, das gucken wir jetzt nicht alles noch.
Willst du?
Hunger, Alter.
When Rush was good.
Wir können jetzt nicht nur
auf 5 Battlefield-Videos gucken,
da sitzen wir noch 3 Stunden da.
Wir wollen noch den Telekom-Karriere-Matcher machen.
Wir machen jetzt den Telekom-Karriere-Matcher.
Telekom-Check, please.
Ja, machen wir.
Da brauchen wir die passende Musik dafür.
Da kann ich mich nicht konzentrieren bei.
Wir machen wieder Sand ran.
Aber irgendwas
mit ein bisschen mehr
Wupp-Wupp.
Irgendwas mit ein bisschen mehr
Ein bisschen mehr Wupp-Wupp.
Bisschen mehr Wupp-Wupp.
Ja, okay.
So.
Warum ist ein Chrome blau?
Weil es ein Chromium ist und kein Chrome.
Ich glaube, wir haben mittlerweile 5 Browser drauf.
Wir haben einen Edge drauf.
Wir haben den neuen Edge drauf.
Den neuen Edge, weiß gar nicht, wo der jetzt ist.
Wir haben den alten Edge, den neuen Edge,
den Internet Explorer,
wir haben Vivaldi, wir haben Chrome,
wir haben Firefox und wir haben Chromium.
6 Browser.
Mehr Browser, besser.
Bitte wählen Sie eine Sprache.
Alles klar, auf geht's, Leute.
Deutsch.
Herzlich willkommen zum Kern.
Du kennst seine Hauptinteressen.
Gib einen Code ein, du gelangst direkt zur Pass...
Was?
Hä?
Ach, wenn man schon mal gemacht hat und sich das gemerkt hat.
Wie wäre es, wenn die einem einfach einen Link geben,
dass man seine Result-Seite bookmarken kann?
Okay, Start.
Start.
Ich finde die Seite schon mal...
Oh, toll.
Kann das sein, dass ich meinen Browser eingestellt habe auf...
Die Seite sieht wirklich...
Alter!
What the fuck?
Alter, das sieht das kacke aus.
Ich habe den letzten schon mal durchgeklickt,
da sah er noch anders aus.
Telekom, Karriere, Twitter.
Ich muss mal gucken,
weil ich habe den ja schon mal...
Telekom, Karriere.
Ach, heute ist ja Grill Day.
Okay.
Match.
Ist das die richtige App?
Okay, das ist anscheinend das Ding.
Das letzte Mal sah das Ding auch ein bisschen anders aus.
Responsive Design.
Gleich einfach nicht für den Desktop machen, ja?
Und vor allem, man kann das noch nicht mal richtig skalieren?
Okay.
Ich freue mich, dass du da bist.
Ich bin gespannt.
Was hältst du davon,
dich intensiv mit technischen Geräten zu befassen?
Also zum Beispiel Computer-Incident-Apps programmieren.
Sehr gut.
Ach, man kann da unten gar keinen Text eintragen.
Das sieht so aus.
Genau mein Ding.
Wie stehst du dazu,
Artikel und Beiträge für Medien zu verfassen?
Also zum Beispiel für Zeitschriften,
Zeitung, Online-Magazine, Radio oder TV?
Warte mal, Leute.
Das ist nicht der Karriere-Matcher,
den ich das letzte Mal angeklickt habe.
Die haben wahrscheinlich eine neue Version davon.
Telekom?
Ja.
Ah, der Kultur-Matcher ist das jetzt.
Ah, okay.
Leute, ich habe es verwechselt.
Ich habe es verwechselt.
Es gibt wohl den Karriere-Matcher
und den Kultur-Matcher.
Es gibt beides.
Was ist mit euch los, Telekom, Alter?
Okay, da machen wir den Kultur-Matcher danach auch noch.
Also.
Okay, also was machen wir jetzt hier?
Wie stehst du dazu,
Artikel und Beiträge für Medien zu verfassen?
Also zum Beispiel Zeitung,
Zeitschriften, Online.
Ja, privat mache ich das gerne,
aber nicht für die Telekom.
Aber machen wir mal.
Machen wir mal.
Machen wir mal so.
Guck mal hier, random, Mann.
Wie sie hier einen auf Messenger machen.
Das soll wahrscheinlich besonders hip sein.
Hättest du Lust, rechtliche Fragenstellungen zu machen?
Nein.
Wie groß ist dein Interesse,
eine wissenschaftliche Theorie eingehend zu studieren?
Kommt drauf an, aus welchem Sammelmittel.
Wie wäre es damit,
mit kranken und hilfsbeschäftigten Menschen
zu helfen?
Menschen allgemein helfe ich nicht gerne.
Ich habe meinen Zivildienst gemacht
in der Behindertenwerkstatt.
Ich bin immer noch der Meinung,
dass das eine der besten Sachen war,
die ich je gemacht habe.
Aber
meinen Jobinhalt will ich damit nicht
bestreiten.
Außerdem generell Menschen helfen nicht.
Ich will überhaupt nichts mit Menschen zu tun haben.
Wie fändest du es,
wissenschaftliche Untersuchungen zu planen,
durchzuführen und auszuwerten?
Ich will, ich will irgendwas programmieren.
Ich will irgendwas basteln.
Ich will...
Mal gucken.
Was sonst noch kommt.
Was hältst du davon,
Geschäftsideen zu vertreten
und sie durchzusetzen?
Oh, nee.
BWL, äh, Kram, geh mal fort.
Wie stehst du dazu,
Bilanzen und Geschäfts-
an eines Unternehmens zu-
Uääh!
Hättest du Lust,
einer künstlich-
künstlerischen oder kreativen Arbeit nach-
Ja!
Das ist-
Das ist jetzt die Frage, ne?
Das ist, was die meisten BWL-Leute nicht kapieren.
Programmieren und, und, äh,
ähnlich gelagerte Sachen,
sind künstlerische und kreative Arbeiten.
Das meinen die aber nicht.
Das kapieren die bloß nicht.
Die meinen wahrscheinlich hier irgendwelche Sachen,
Design, Malen, sonst was.
Wir machen jetzt mal so, ähm,
aber ich weiß, dass sie das damit nicht meinen.
Ich weiß, die meinen Marketing,
oder irgendwelche Design-Geschichten oder sonst was.
Garantiert.
Dabei trifft das auf Programmieren ganz genau so.
Ganz genau zu.
Wie groß ist dein Interesse,
Menschen mit persönlichen Problemen zu berei-
Geh mir fort, Menschen, Alter.
First Level.
Geh fort.
Und wie wäre es damit,
die Funktionsweise von technischen Geräten zu erkunden?
Ja, das ist gut.
Wie fändest du es,
Werbemittel kreativ zu gestalten,
so wie Bilder an-
Pfff.
Nee, eher, eher nicht so.
Was hältst du davon,
eine Ablage und Ordnungssystem für-
Bäh.
Nö, nö, nö.
Wie stehst du dazu,
handwerklich zu arbeiten?
Zum Beispiel-
Ich bastel ganz gerne rum,
aber den ganzen Tag irgendwelche Sachen
auf der Baustelle machen müsste ich nicht.
Ich hätte damit aber keine Schmerzen,
als im Rechenzentrum oder sowas zu machen.
Vollkommen in Ordnung, ja.
Jein.
Hättest du Lust,
Kunden von einem Produkt zu überzeugen?
Nein.
Wie groß ist dein Interesse,
in einem Labor-
oder Forschungsinstitut zu arbeiten?
Nein.
Komm, prüfe an, was die da so machen.
Und wie wäre es damit,
den wirtschaftlichen Erfolg
eines Unternehmens zu steigern?
Ey, wenn das, was ich mache,
dazu beiträgt,
dass der Laden mehr Kohle macht,
ist doch gut.
Das Problem ist aber,
die meinen damit,
ich soll irgendwelchen BWL-Shit machen.
Jeder, der irgendwo arbeitet
und was macht,
sollte ein gewissen-
ein gewisses Interesse daran haben,
ähm,
den wirtschaftlichen Erfolg
eines Unternehmens zu steigern.
Letztendlich hängt ja auch,
vor allem, wenn man seinen Job gern macht,
dein eigener Arbeitsplatz irgendwie mit da dran,
dass es den Laden noch eine Weile gibt.
Okay, wir machen,
wir lassen es mal so.
Wie fändest du es,
Kinder und Jugendliche-
Och, geh weg.
Naja, gut.
Ich meine, ich mache das mit unseren Azubis
auch öfters mal,
aber scharf drauf bin ich nicht.
Ich muss sagen,
wenn wir mal Azubis haben,
macht mir das Spaß,
aber drum reißen würde ich mich nicht wirklich.
Vor allem nicht Kinder.
Azubis okay,
aber Kinder und Jugendliche zu betreuen,
zu unterrichten,
klingt eher nach einer sozialen Geschichte,
da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Für mich sind ja Azubis auch Jugendliche,
weil Azubis sind vielleicht 20,
aber für mich sind 20-Jährige auch Kinder mittlerweile.
Also, rein von der-
Das ist, das ist-
Ich weiß noch,
wie ich, wie ich selbst 13, 14 war,
habe ich gedacht,
Alter, mit 20 bist du übelst alt
und jetzt mit 35 denke ich,
mit 20 ist kein Unterschied zwischen 16 und 20.
Boomer, ja.
So, wieder da.
Ähm, okay, weit-
Oh, es ist fertig.
Geschafft.
Im nächsten Trailer hältst du dann über drei,
deine drei stärksten Interessensgebiete
weiter zu deinen Hauptinteressen.
Okay, auf geht's.
Ah, yes.
Technisch praktisch.
Korrekt.
Künstlerisch kreativ.
Wenn es Programmieren ist,
wissenschaftlich forschend.
Dein RIASEC-Code ist Rai.
Rai.
Bäh.
Weiter.
Hast du dir dein Code gemerkt?
Nein.
Rai.
Das ist mein Code.
Weiter.
Rai.
Okay.
Alles.
Oh, das ist komisch.
Und wie sieht's in Frankfurt aus?
In Frankfurt gibt's nix.
Rechtsreferendar in der Wahlstand-
Wollt ihr mich veräppeln?
Praktikant?
What?
Was?
Was ist das auschuckles?
Rai.
Wunderbar.
그래도,
sieht gut aus.
GUYS.
Kann man da jetzt auch einfach sagen, kann man nicht sortieren?
Nee, okay.
Dann machen wir jetzt noch den Kulturmatcher.
Kommen wir noch den Kulturmatcher.
Also, was sagt der Telekom Kulturmatcher?
Okay, der ist schon mal für Desktop ausgelegt.
Zwar nicht so ganz, aber halbwegs.
Der Kulturmatcher.
Scheint ja richtig nice zu sein, irgendwie.
Ich wollte schon immer mal Praktikant im First Level bei der Telekom werden oder so.
Herzlich willkommen zum Kulturmatcher.
Es ist die DNA einer Firma.
Magenta DNA.
Was will der, was muss ich?
Okay, weiter.
Wie viele Fragen sind's?
Das waren gar nicht so wenige.
In meinem Wunschunternehmen soll gelten, jeder ist seines Glückes Schmied, das Schicksal entscheidet.
Äh, weder noch.
Die Antworten sind total behindert.
Was ist das für eine beknackte Antwort?
Das Schicksal entscheidet schon mal gar nicht.
Und jeder ist seines Glückes Schmied ist bei den meisten Firmen auch nicht so.
What the fuck?
Okay, das ist, was ich haben will.
Also, ehrlich gesagt, ehrlich gesagt, weder, weder noch.
Weil das Schicksal entscheidet ist ja schon mal komplett beknackt.
Was soll das, was soll das überhaupt bedeuten, ja?
Ähm, jeder ist seines Glückes Schmied bedeutet, soll das jetzt bedeuten, wenn ich mich besonders einschleime, dann ist das so?
Ich würde eigentlich, also in meiner, also, die perfekte Welt für mich wäre, dass es klar formulierte, ähm, Ziele gibt, was man haben möchte.
Ja, also sprich, dass die Firma sich...
So ungefähr festlegt, so nach dem Motto, das und das wollen wir.
Das und das wollen wir.
Und wenn man dort quasi dafür, dazu entscheiden beiträgt, dass diese Erfolge verwirklicht werden, dann, ähm, sollte das auch entsprechend, äh, honoriert werden.
Also, ich tendiere mal eher so in die Richtung, weil das Schicksal entscheidet ist kompletter Blödsinn.
Was soll das überhaupt bedeuten, das Schicksal entscheidet, ja?
Äh, links, ja.
Machen wir mal so, machen wir mal so.
Ja.
Lass uns mal gucken.
Okay.
Wie viele Fragen sind es denn eigentlich?
Steht das irgendwo?
In meinem Wunschunternehmen soll gelten, Kompromisse machen, Ecken und Kanten...
What the fuck, Alter?
Was fragen?
Ah!
Was, 2 vor 49, wo steht das?
Ach, da...
Oh!
49!
What the fuck?
Okay, da müssen wir ein bisschen schneller, da müssen wir ein bisschen schneller sein jetzt.
Das dauert ja sonst ewig.
Und bei mir gibt es gleich Mittagessen.
Ich hab nicht mehr so viel Zeit, Leute.
Okay, Kompromisse machen, Ecken und Kanten haben.
Das eine schließt das andere doch überhaupt nicht aus.
Man sollte nicht, man sollte nicht bei jedem Scheiß Kompromisse machen, weil dann kommen am Ende auch einfach technisch total Shit-Lösungen raus, ja?
Ähm, aber das eine schließt das andere doch überhaupt nicht aus.
Bei alles und jedem Kompromisse machen ist total bescheuert.
Es gibt, es gibt Sachen, die sind objektiv besser als andere.
Für das, was man haben will.
Ey, ich, ich lass jetzt einfach neutral in der Mitte.
Okay.
Gegen den Strom schwimmen, go with the flow.
Das kann man doch überhaupt auch nicht so allgemein sagen.
What the fuck?
Was ist das?
Go with the flow gegen den Strom.
Es ist teilweise notwendig, je nachdem was es ist, dass man auch mal sagt, ey.
Ähm...
Das passt so nicht.
Das sollten wir anders machen.
Aber am besten ist natürlich, ähm, wenn man, wenn man was gefunden hat, was gut funktioniert, dass dann auch alle mitmachen.
Es ist, ey, keine Ahnung.
Was ist das für, was ist das für ein Schwachsinn?
Familiares Arbeitsumfeld oder professionelle Distanz.
Da muss ich sagen, ähm, ich finde es blöd, wenn Firmen auf, ähm, wir sind eine große Familie und wir haben uns alle lieb machen.
Weil unterm Strich ist es so, man arbeitet nicht so sehr, weil der Chef sein bester Freund ist oder, oder irgendwie der, der, der, der CEO, da man mit dem so dicke ist, sondern man arbeitet da, weil man Kohle kriegt.
Und man darf dort arbeiten, weil sie was von einem haben.
So, also, so nach dem Motto, wir, wir haben uns alle lieb, ist schwachsinnig.
Das hält genau so lange, bis irgendwas nicht mehr funktioniert, ja.
Ähm...
Prinzipiell ist mir professionelle Distanz lieber, ähm, weil ich keinen Bock hab auf irgendwelche komischen, ähm...
Äh, Events und wir feiern uns und sind die geilsten, das hab ich schon oft genug.
Aber auf der anderen Seite muss man sagen, mit den Leuten, mit denen man quasi so im gleichen Boot sitzt und mit denen man tagtäglich arbeitet, die man auch schon seit teilweise 10 Jahre kennt, dann ist es eindeutig eher das hier.
Aber ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, ich möchte das überall so haben.
Ich hab keinen Bock, dass, dass der Vorstandsman morgens um die Ecke kommt und sagt, ey, magst du alles haus, was geht, was hast du am Wochenende?
Pfff, Pfff, Pfff, Pfff, Pfff.
Ich will zu meinem Vorstand professionelle Distanz und zu den Leuten, denen ich tagtäglich arbeite, baut man so...
Will ich nicht, dass es gilt, sondern baut sich sowas mit der Zeit auf.
Bescheuerte Frage, Alter, weiß ich das.
Pünktlich Schluss machen, erst Schluss machen, wenn alles erledigt ist.
Ganz ehrlich, Leute, pünktlich Schluss machen.
Ich sag, ich sag, ich sag euch sowas, wie man es so schön nennt heutzutage, Work-Life-Balance, beste, wichtigste, worauf man achten muss.
Ich hab übrigens gerade auf meiner Tastatur ein bisschen Tee gegessen.
Der kippt, ich muss gerade mal sauber machen.
Ey, du hattest mal steuerbare Relays vorgestellt, wie die Shelly One.
Die hier.
Die haben noch ein bisschen mehr, muss ich ein bisschen umgucken, wa?
Aber die waren's.
So, da muss ich euch ehrlich sagen, ja, pünktlich Schluss machen ist mir wichtiger, als erst Schluss machen, wenn Arbeit erledigt ist.
Weil das lädt dazu ein, dass man das nur noch macht.
Und es sollte prinzipiell gelten...
...in einer Firma, dass die Arbeit so verteilt wird, dass jeder mit der Sache auskommt, die im Arbeitsvertrag steht.
Äh, solche dran, acht Monate, dankeschön, huge sub.
Das sollte das Ziel sein.
Was nicht heißt, was nicht heißt, dass man, wenn es drauf ankommt, nicht auch mal was mehr machen kann.
Aber das muss, das muss in beide Richtungen gehen.
Ja, Cooper, das ist auch so, deswegen ist es ja auch so bescheuert, die Fragen entweder oder zu stellen.
Es kommt ganz drauf an.
Aber prinzipiell sollte es so verteilt sein, wer Überstunden machen will und da scharf drauf ist und da Spaß dran hat, soll es meinetwegen machen.
Aber die Koordination und die Arbeitsverteilung sollte so drauf ausgelegt sein, dass jeder mit den Stunden, die in seinem Arbeitsvertrag stehen, auskommt.
Deswegen ist das so wichtig.
Ähm, in meinem Wunschunternehmen soll gelten, allein arbeiten, man am effektivsten die besten Resultate erzielen beim Team.
Okay, ich weiß, was die hören wollen von der Telekom.
Ich weiß, was die hören wollen von der Telekom.
Von der Telekom wollen sie...
Von der Telekom wollen sie das hören.
Das wollen die von mir als Antwort hören.
Wäre ich da in irgendeinem Vorstellungsgespräch und die würden mich das fragen, wollen die das hören?
Meine persönliche Meinung dazu ist allerdings, das ist nicht 100% äh, immer true.
Es kommt drauf an, was.
Es kommt, es kommt drauf an, was.
Ähm, wenn man sich beispielsweise eine neue Technologie angucken muss.
Waren genommen, man programmiert was und man soll sich...
Ein neues Framework angucken.
Dann ist es ganz klar, dass.
Wenn man, wenn man den Kram kann und sich, äh, irgendwas überlegen muss, was insgesamt gut funktioniert, dann das.
Kann man auch, kommt komplett auf den Kontext an.
Kann man auch nicht, nicht beantworten.
Ich tendiere allerdings in den meisten Fällen eher dahin, ähm, wenn's um Sachen geht, wo man eben wie programmieren oder sonst was, wo man ein bisschen kreativ sein muss.
Dass man in Ruhe was machen kann.
Ähm, was nicht heißt, dass es nicht so...
Es ist Schwachsinn.
Es ist, es ist totaler Schwachsinn einfach nur.
So, ich bin wieder am Sch...
Ich hab gerade was, äh, zu essen gebracht gekriegt.
Da hab ich meinen ganzen...
Es steht hier mitten auf meinem Schreibtisch ein riesen Pott Reis.
Mit Hähnchen drin.
Ich kann kaum noch die Maus bewegen.
Okay, wir machen das einfach weiter.
In meinem Wunschunternehmen soll Abwechslung bereichern, das Leben Routine erleichtern.
Beides.
Das...
Oh Gott, was für eine bescheuerte Frage.
Oh mein, das tut weh.
Das tut weh.
Wir sind erst bei Frage 7 von 49.
Abwechslung bereichert das Leben.
Ja, ist so.
Ja.
Wenn man 15 Jahre den gleichen Scheiß macht jeden Tag, ist das kacke.
Allerdings, manche Abläufe ist gut, wenn da, wenn ordentlich beschrieben ist, wie es geht und wie man Sachen machen, machen sollte.
Zum Beispiel.
Wenn man, man genommen, man ist jetzt, sagen wir, Teamleiter, ja.
Und, ähm, wenn neue Leute anfangen in seinem Team, muss man, wenn, also, wenn, wenn die anwenden, wenn die...
Wenn die sagen, erster Arbeitstag, dann muss man im Vorfeld, ja, irgendwo einen Workflow oder einen Prozess aufmachen, wo es drum geht, ähm, dass Accounts eingerichtet werden, Firewall, Firewall-Freischaltung gemacht werden, sonst was.
Und da ist eindeutig das der Fall.
Ja.
Wenn man 15 Jahre das gleiche macht, ist eindeutig das, das ist totaler Bullshit, Alter, wer sich das ausgedacht hat.
In meinem Wunschunternehmen soll gelten, Arbeit als Verpflichtung, Arbeit als Erfüllung.
Kann man auch so nicht beantworten.
Ich meine, besser ist es auf jeden Fall so, wenn das die Regel ist, ja.
Aber, du kannst nicht nur Sachen machen, die dich erfüllen.
Das wird, nirgendwo, nirgendwo wird es das geben.
Und kann es auch gar nicht.
Kann es auch gar nicht.
Weil, wenn ich den ganzen Tag nur das machen würde, worauf ich Bock habe, dann kommt am Ende auch nichts Gescheites raus.
Das muss beides sein.
Natürlich ist es schön, wenn das hier überwiegt.
In meinem Wunschunternehmen soll gelten, jeder ist für jeden da, jeder ist für sich selbst verantwortlich.
Kommt drauf an, wenn ich die Leute, wenn ich die Leute mag, dann schon, ähm, wenn ich die Leute nicht mag, dann habe ich mit, pff, ah, Gott, das, das schmerzt.
Das, das schmerzt, diese, diese, haben wir jetzt nix.
Erlaubt ist, was hilft, Lügen haben kurzen Beine.
Okay, ähm, was die Telekom hören will, ist wahrscheinlich das hier.
Aber, wenn man ehrlich ist, und ja, mir wär's, mir wär's auch lieber, wenn man keinen Scheiß, äh, wenn man keinen Scheiß erzählen muss, ja.
Also, wenn's da drum geht.
Was ich gerne haben würde, dann eher sowas.
Manchmal wird man nicht drum herum kommen, die Sachen ein bisschen geschönt zu verkaufen, das ist klar.
Ja, also, äh, wenn ich einfach nur sagen kann, 99% Verfügbarkeit, und die Leute sind damit, äh, zufrieden, ist natürlich besser, wie wenn ich sagen muss, ja, aber wir rechnen, wir rechnen planmäßige Wartungsarbeiten raus.
Das ist nicht wirklich Lügen, das ist, äh, äh, taktisch geschickt die Sache verkaufen, ja.
Ähm, das Problem ist nur, was es bei den meisten Läden ist, was sie nicht wahrhaben wollen.
Und was bei der Telekom bestimmt nicht anders ist, im Prinzip sind die Leute, die am meisten Bullshit erzählen, oftmals die, die damit halt auch gut, gut, gut zurechtkommen, ja.
Telekom will rechts, macht links, vermute ich auch.
Machen wahrscheinlich die meisten so.
Machen wir's mal so.
In meinem Wunsch, und dem soll gelten, an morgen denken im Hier und Jetzt, äh, beides, beides.
Vollkommen.
Es, es gibt so viele Läden, die da, die, die das nicht hinkriegen.
Ähm, du hast...
Aktuell was, was läuft, was dafür zuständig ist, dass, äh, du nen Job hast, ja.
Also mal angenommen, man betreibt nen Portal für...
Man betreibt YouTube, zum Beispiel.
Man betreibt nen Videoportal, ja.
Ähm, selbstverständlich ist unglaublich wichtig, dass man das hier macht, weil, wenn einem die User wegrennen, hat man keine Zeit mehr, das hier zu machen.
Man muss beides machen.
Man muss hier gucken, dass das stabil...
Läuft, dass das geupdatet wird, dass das gut funktioniert.
Und man muss sich auch überlegen, wie macht man das Ganze nächste Woche.
So, die Telekom möchte wahrscheinlich das hier hören.
Aber, wenn's um Punkt und Stabilität geht, macht die Telekom hoffentlich eher das.
Das ist auch wieder was, was man überhaupt nicht beantworten kann, weil beides seine Daseinsberechtigung hat und beides parallel existieren muss.
Ich ess mal übrigens ein bisschen Hähnchen nebenbei, weil...
Und es wird kalt.
So, ähm...
In meinem Wunsch...
...unternehmen soll gelten, Beständigkeit, Abwechslung.
Alter!
Ah, ah!
Das schmerzt, diese, diese Sachen.
Das ist alles kein Entweder-Oder.
Das ist alles, das ist alles kein Entweder-Oder.
Du kannst nicht jeden Tag was Neues machen, das geht nicht.
Du kannst aber auch nicht jahrelang immer das Gleiche machen.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Diese ganzen Sachen sind keine Entweder-Oder-Entscheidung.
Das hat sich garantiert irgendein, irgendein Personal...
...BWL-Mann, Mensch, Frau, äh, S, was auch immer, ausgedacht, dieses Quiz.
Das ist komplett bescheuert.
In meinem Wunschunternehmen soll gelten, bloß nicht zu überstürzen, Erfolg erfordert Mut.
Äh, wie wär's mit beidem mal wieder?
Was hindert einen dran, zu sagen, ja, wir wollen was Neues machen, aber sich erstmal zu überlegen, was macht man überhaupt?
Was hat das...
Oh Gott.
In meinem Wunschunternehmen soll gelten, ähm, Gewinn machen ans Gemeinwohldenken.
Ey, wenn's nach meinem Wunsch geht, sollen die alle ans Allgemeinwohldenken, solange ich nicht mitmachen muss, ist auch okay.
Ähm, solange ich mit den Leuten nichts machen muss, ja.
Ähm, natürlich sollten die Leute ans Gemeinwohldenken, allerdings, die Telekom, äh, denkt natürlich eher hier dran.
Also, also derjenige, der den Test erstellt hat, denkt eindeutig eher hier ran, als hier ran.
Mir persönlich ist es, also mir persönlich ist es vielleicht so einen Ticken lieber.
Aber, pff, was auch immer.
In meinem Wunschunternehmen soll ich vier Augen sehen, mehr als zwei, viele Köche verderben den Brei.
Ja, kommt, das ist wie die typische, so typische Fangfrage von vorhin, kann man so ohne Kontext gar nicht beantworten.
Jeder entscheidet selbst, klare Arbeit...
Beides! Beides! The fuck!
Ich brauch nicht wegen jedem Scheiß, eigentlich, der mir vorkaut.
Ich brauch aber auch nicht jeden Kram geregelt.
Wir machen jetzt mal ein bisschen schneller.
Ich will einfach nur gucken, was noch kommt.
Sehe ich zurück? Ich klicke jetzt einfach, ich will einfach nur gucken, was noch kommt.
Das Quiz ist richtig dumm, das machen wir nicht fertig.
Ich klicke jetzt nur schnell durch, was noch kommt.
Ähm, realistisch bleiben, ohne Vision, keine Orientierung.
Oh Gott, was ein, was ein Bullshit.
Klare Spielregeln, Freiraum.
Ne, geh fort, ich hab keinen Bock.
Geh weg.
Wir gucken jetzt ein Essen-Video, wir gucken jetzt ein Essen-Futter-Video.
Hot Dogs from Germany.
Was gucken wir jetzt? Ich brauche ein gutes Essen-Video, Leute.
Habt ihr, habt ihr eine Empfehlung für ein gutes, äh, äh, Food, Food-Video?
Schauen wir uns noch die Battlefield-Plays an.
Ja, machen wir, machen wir gleich, nachdem ich fertig essen bin.
Oh, ich hab letztens ein cooles Whisky, Whisky-Burger oder sowas.
Ja, oh, der sah gut aus, Leute, ey.
Der sah echt gut aus.
Warum auch was explodiert, versteh ich nicht.
Weil, weil Kokona,
extrem, Alter.
Da muss am Anfang was explodieren, ne.
Das ist, das ist echt der größte Kokona-Sender, den ich mir vorstellen kann, YouTube-Channel.
Barbecue-Pit-Boys.com
Today we're cooking up some smoked Whisky-Cheeseburgers.
Der redet, der redet schon so Kokona-Style.
Barbecue-Pit-Boys.com
Pit, and they're real easy to cook.
Yeah, yeah.
This recipe, you're gonna need some ground beef.
Die machen kein Geschiss, da kommen erst mal ein Kilo Hackfleisch rein.
And here we've got, uh, about three pounds of ground chuck.
And try to use chuck beef whenever you can.
Soll ich erst mal nehmen bei Wasser?
Now, we're gonna form these burgers in a cake ring.
And this is about a six-inch cake ring.
Wir sind Sojasauce auf dem Reis, Mann.
And, uh, you can get these at your local kitchen outlet or whatever.
Or, uh, just go down to the hardware.
Get yourself some heat duct or something, right?
Was leckt das?
Und, uh, we'll show you why.
Your legs?
Oh, MonkaS.
MonkaS.
Ay, ay, ay.
Oh, oh, oh.
Vodafone, please.
Jetzt geht's anscheinend wieder.
Geht wieder, oder?
Jetzt droppt nix mehr.
Ja, Vodafone, spackt wieder rum.
Aber ihr wisst ja, woran das liegt.
Das liegt bestimmt nur daran, dass mein WLAN doppelte SSIDs hat.
Wir packen das gelegte Fleisch ziemlich fest in diese Kek-Rings, richtig?
Oh, ja.
Nun, wenn ihr noch nie Smoked-Whiskey-Cheeseburgers gehört habt,
dann müsst ihr das definitiv nachschauen.
Das ist ein gutes Essen im Bett.
Nun, der Burger ist geformt.
Und was wir tun, ist...
Ah, erst mal ein paar Löcher reinstechen.
... mit ein paar Höhlen reinstechen.
Und wir gehen nicht nach unten.
Richtig?
Das ist fast drei Viertel des Wegs durch.
Und hier verwenden wir einen Holz-Scaler.
Jetzt haben wir hier etwas braunen Zucker.
Und wir werden es überall über den Topf spritzen.
So wie das hier.
Das wird gut.
Und hier haben wir etwas Hot Sauce.
Wir werden etwas Hot Sauce auflegen.
Und wählen Ihr Lieblings-Hot Sauce.
Hier haben wir etwas Hot Sauce.
Und natürlich könnt Ihr...
Ich kann das E-Mode nicht mehr weg machen.
Ah, jetzt.
Jetzt, ich musste das E-Mode wechseln.
Okay, alles gut.
So, perfekt.
Easy.
Ah, jetzt kommt das...
Ah, yes, exzellent.
Moment, Leute.
Warum kann denn nicht das erste Glas
voll machen, das zweite Glas, das dritte
und das vierte Glas? Warum muss der das so hin und her
schwenken?
Warum?
Will er die Hälfte auf den Tisch verteilen, oder was?
Nicht cool genug.
Bitte, guckt euch mal an.
Die halbe Flasche landet auf den Tisch.
Warum?
Warum, please?
...
Ich glaub, das passt richtig gut zusammen, ne?
Whisky und Zucker, das wird so richtig, richtig braune, braune, braune, braune, äh...
Ja, Kruste oben drauf dann.
...
Jetzt lassen wir die Burger für eine halbe Stunde sitzen, bis die Süße reinkommen.
In der Zwischenzeit schneiden wir einen Bellenpfeffer.
Wir geben ein bisschen Olivenöl drauf und heben es auf der Seite.
Jetzt sind die Smoker bereit.
Wir werden eine Temperatur von ca. 275°F fahren.
Hier haben wir einen Pund gebratenes Bacon.
Und wir werden es langsam auf dem alten Smoker anbraten.
Warum ist das eigentlich einen halben Meter Hackfleisch? Könnte man das nicht ein bisschen dünner machen?
Für diese Rezepte werden wir ein paar Portobello-Maschinen anbraten.
Haha, die Machete. Der schneidet immer alles mit der Machete.
Wir schneiden ein paar Zwiebeln und ein paar Zwiebeln.
Und wir werden die Pfeffer nur ein bisschen anbraten.
Und ich sage dir, richtig?
Du weißt alles darüber.
Ich bin wie ein Kumpel.
Nun, nimm ein paar SPG.
Nimm ein paar Zwiebeln.
Und ein paar gechoppte Zwiebeln.
Und hier haben wir ein bisschen extra Olivenöl.
Und wir werden es überall drüber schminken.
Oh, die Burger werden gut sein.
Gut.
Wir werden die Feuerwärme ein bisschen stärker steigen.
Die Temperaturen werden behalten.
Die Pfeffer kommen weiter.
Oh, ja.
Nun.
Etwa eine halbe Stunde ist vorbei.
Und wir werden diese Burger auf den Smoker stellen.
Ich glaube, das schmeckt richtig leiser nach.
Ja.
Wir haben her 친 die Pfeffer gut zum smelleden.
Wir wenn die cheated.
Sim tiếp, wir schneiden.
Ich glaube, das schmeckt sehr gut, oder?
Ich glaube wir презид auch.
vibrieren.
Oh,pperle, riechen.
Rieche conocen, was ihr ein homöopathisches Fans protections beseitiget hier gibt,
es ist Celsius.
Sie winschneimes Wachs des right.
Wooo!
Das wurde zurЭ
Also die Burger sind ja auch einen halben Meter dick.
Das braucht schon eine Weile.
Okay, der Waldboden kommt auch in den Grill.
Was? Wie heißt das?
Portabella?
Portobello?
Das sieht aus wie normale Champignons.
Pilz.
Kein normaler Riesen-Champion.
Gut, haben wir da was gelernt, Leute.
Oh, das schmeckt bestimmt gut.
Das ist...
Ey, das Ding ist eine Größe wie eine halbe...
Warte mal, zeig doch mal her, Junge.
Das ist wie so ein Kuchen,
was du aus dem Backofen holst,
von der Größe her.
Das ist ein riesen, mega fetter Burger-Patty.
Die Musik dabei auch schon.
Das ist echt...
Mehr Kokona geht nicht.
Das geht nicht.
Das ist einfach das...
Der Kokona-igste Channel überhaupt.
Jetzt fehlt eigentlich bloß noch,
dass sie mit einer Shotgun rumlaufen oder so.
Und noch ein kleines Stück Holz.
Halt diese Temperaturen richtig.
Okay, ich sage, es ist Zeit zu essen.
Die Burgers sind fast fertig.
Die Portabellos sind fertig.
Die Whiskas...
Die Burger sind fertig.
Ich frage mich, ob er das nochmal irgendwie durchschneit,
weil das kann doch kein Mensch essen.
Guck mal, das ist irgendwie echt ein halber Meter-Patty.
Also...
...to about a hundred and sixty-five degrees Fahrenheit internal.
And here we got some Swiss cheese.
And of course, use your favorite cheese,
but load it on.
Aber was hat der M da da, oder?
Heat up these buns a bit.
Ohne Scheiß, der Patty ist doppelt so groß wie das Brötchen.
Oh, I'll have this routinely.
We're gonna be eating...
...we're gonna be eating...
Nächstes Video wird das Hähnchen gegrillt, ha?
Ah, yes.
Erstmal eine Runde Mayonnaise drauf, so muss das sein.
Okay, die Brötchen sind größer, als ich gedacht habe.
Oh, das Ding ist drei Kilometer groß.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Brötchengröße zu Pattygröße.
Und da kommt ja der Rest noch oben drauf.
Das ist ja ein Riesenteil, ey.
Da überlebst du einen Monat in der Wildnis von.
Auch noch oben drauf.
Da muss ja noch die Paprika drauf.
Die Paprika. Die Paprika hatte er auch noch.
Würde ich jetzt auch essen.
Ich bin übrigens so lange nicht fertig, die ersten merke ich gerade.
It smells good.
Wie bekommt man das in den Mund? Das ist nicht die Frage, anscheinend.
Genau jetzt noch Cola dabei.
Aber es sieht echt gut aus.
Das muss man sagen.
Alter, wie das...
Wie das roter Spritz alles.
Ich meine, es sieht schon gut aus, ja?
Jetzt müssen sie gleich Daumen hoch machen.
Das machen sie immer so.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, Mann.
Immer yeah, yeah.
It smells good, yeah.
Yeah.
Barbecue Rips and Wings.
Oh, ich sag euch, ich hab eben noch aus Spaß gesagt,
also im nächsten Video machen sie das Hähnchen.
Anscheinend haben sie das wirklich gemacht.
Im nächsten Video kommt das Hähnchen dran.
Ah, nee, nee, nee.
Falsche Reihenfolge.
Okay, ich hab noch einen halben Teller zu essen.
Wir brauchen noch, wir brauchen noch was.
Bacon and Eggs Pan Fry.
Komm, wir gucken noch einen.
Barbecue Pit Boys.
Warum explodiert da was?
Das explodiert doch nur, dass es einfach noch mehr Kokona ist, oder?
Und warum fliegt der durch den Weltall?
Oh, Burgergrills.
Welcome to BBQPitBoys.com.
Today we're grilling up some bacon and egg pan pie at the pit.
20 Wege ein Steak zu grillen, okay.
We've got a few pounds of bacon here.
And we'll grill them up.
Because...
Because we're gonna need them for the recipe, right?
And it might take an hour, hour and a two,
at about 250, 275 degrees Fahrenheit.
Alright.
The bacon has been smoked.
And now let's show you what you need for this recipe.
You're gonna need some cheese...
Ein paar Eier.
Ein paar Eier verschwinden gering.
Okay.
Alter, krasse Kombi.
Bacon, Käse, Kartoffelchips und einen Riesenhaufen Eier.
Und eine Zwiebel.
Das ist eine geile Kombi, ja.
You're gonna need some potato chips,
a couple dozen eggs,
like I said, a few pounds of bacon.
Low carb ist das nicht, ja.
Some onion.
We have some maple syrup.
Alright.
Let's put this together.
Now, like I said, we pre-cook the bacon.
Not crispy, you want it soft.
Just like that, impliable.
Es gibt das, wenn es fertig ist.
Three quarters the way through, maybe a little bit more.
And what you do is you take a few strips.
And you roll them up, just like that.
Now, if you've never had bacon and egg pan pie before,
you definitely need to check it out.
Um ehrlich gesagt, hatte ich noch nie bacon and egg pan pie.
It's a great full meal, anytime you want.
Ho, ho, ho.
Routine overload.
Bacon and eggs.
It's good.
Alright, let's show you again how you do it.
Just take your bacon and roll it.
Maybe a few strips.
You can get...
You can get creative and figure out how to do it, right?
Okay.
Now, of course, this is pork belly.
Der rollt, der rollt bacon mit bacon quasi auf.
Es ist, wisst ihr, andere Leute nehmen bacon,
rollen da irgendwie ne Bohne oder so drin ein.
Aber da wird bacon aufgerollt, um bacon aufgerollt.
Ah, ihr versteht, was ich meine, ha?
Das hier musst du noch gucken.
Mal schauen, mal schauen.
Ich hab ja noch einen ganzen Teller Reis hier.
Alright, you know about that, right?
Again, we just start the roll.
Add another piece.
And we're gonna place them in a black iron pan.
This is about a 12-inch black iron pan.
12-inch, das sind...
25...
27 Zentimeter oder sowas, hä?
12-inch?
Ich sag 27 Zentimeter.
Ah, 30, 30 Zentimeter, okay, okay.
Ja.
Äh, fast.
Mit den Einheiten müssen sie halt noch üben.
Better roses, ha?
Hehehe.
Oh, man.
Now, we have in here approximately two and a half pounds of bacon, more or less, alright?
And this is what it looks like when you get it in the pan.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was da rauskommen soll.
Now, here we're...
Ich geh mal davon aus,
der schmeißt da jetzt wahrscheinlich...
Den ganzen Käse rein.
Und mach die Eier dabei.
Und dann werden sie das ganze kochen.
Oder grillen.
Und da dürfte dann so eine Art...
So ein mega fettes Frühstücksei bei rauskommen.
Bloß halt dreimal...
Zehnmal so dick.
Und mit Bacon.
So the eggs will not stick to this black iron pan.
Now, this recipe calls for some onion, like I said, so you can chop it up.
So you can chop it up.
Oh, ein bisschen Grünzeug.
Maybe a good size onion.
And now we're gonna break the eggs into the pan.
You wanna go sunny side up, right?
Oh, man.
And you're gonna need a lot of eggs.
Deswegen brauchen die da auch irgendwie Eier von 20 Hühnern.
Weil überleg mal, wenn du das voll machen willst mit Eiern, da brauchst du schon deine 30 Eier.
Like I said, you're gonna need a dozen and a half eggs.
Maybe two dozen.
Depends how big your eggs are, right?
And we got them sunny side up.
Oh, man.
Looks good.
Now, next step.
We're gonna add a diced onion.
Right to the top.
Nice layer.
And then we'll...
Jetzt kommt der Käse. Die haben ja noch Käse.
Back to the corn.
Die haben doch auch noch einen ganzen Pott voller Käse.
Da muss auch noch drauf.
Looks good enough to eat already.
And then we're gonna place them on the grill opposite the hot coals.
We're indirect heating.
This gives us a slow heat.
And we're running a temperature of about
275 to 300 degrees Fahrenheit.
Das ist echt halber Kakao da.
And here we're about halfway through.
We're just gonna spin the pan for some even cooking.
You may not have to do that.
Perfekt für den kleinen Hunger zwischendurch.
Eggs are setting up nice.
Now, while we're waiting for the eggs to cook,
we've got some potato chips here.
We've got some potato chips here.
Die hab ich ja schon ganz vergessen,
dass der auch noch in einem Eimer Chips hatte.
...this starch to this bacon and egg pan pie, right?
Jetzt kommen noch die Chips dabei, Alter.
Oh Mann, das wird gut, Alter!
Ich bin ja ein bisschen enttäuscht, dass der die Chips
Das wird gut, Alter!
nicht immer in der Machete klein macht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es Beilage ist.
Das kommt bestimmt noch oben drauf oder so.
Angie.
Dann erst einmal ins Krankenhaus.
Oh. Oh.
Nun haben wir hier etwas musicianisches Sono.
Und hier mergem wir es mit den Chips hin.
Und benutze e-a-as dein spacterkLouer Chefchef.
Und benutze e-a-ass dein spacterkLouer Chefchef.
Das kommt oben drüber.
Das kommt oben drüber,
das richtig knackig wird noch.
Heftig, heftig.
Ist daten.
Das Bacon-and-Egg-Pan-Pie
ist da.
Du musst wahrscheinlich
das Ding, musst du wahrscheinlich wirklich schneiden
mit der Machete, dass du überhaupt durchkommst.
Hahaha.
Die Musik dabei.
Die Musik.
Boah, das sieht aber gut aus.
Das sieht echt gut aus.
Würde ich mir jetzt auch gönnen.
Also gut, jetzt vielleicht nicht mal nach dem Riesenteil
der Reis, den ich gerade reingespachtel hab.
Beste.
Ja.
Wir sind fertig, Leute.
Ähm.
Wir gucken gerade noch mal zu, wie es aussieht hier mit dem Essen.
Den Rest tauscht man auch schnell rein.
Das sieht echt gut aus.
Besser als mein Reis mit Hähnchen hier.
Front of you.
We call this, but we call this,
Pitmaster Privilege.
You're just gonna have to make your own
Bacon-and-Egg-Pan-Pie.
Noch mal Sirup drauf, was sonst?
Was sonst?
Also Leute, eigentlich, eigentlich hatte ich folgendes vor.
Ich wollte, ich wollte ja schon vor
einer Stunde oder einer halben Stunde off
um Mittag essen und dann wollte ich eigentlich
nachher nochmal on kommen
und mit dem Raspberry Pie 4
äh,
ein aktuelles, äh,
Lineage Android drauf erzählen.
Allerdings, nachdem ich jetzt schon gegessen habe,
bist du am Pumpen oder wieso Reis mit Hähnchen?
Weil es gut schmeckt.
Das wollte ich nachher ausprobieren, aber
nachdem ich jetzt ja schon gegessen hab,
habe,
würde ich sagen, wir gucken jetzt noch ein,
gucken jetzt noch irgendein Video.
So zum Verdauen.
Wollen wir uns noch das,
oh, schlug auf. Wollen wir uns, ach,
Battlefield Plays, stimmt.
Wir müssen uns noch die eingeschickten Clips angucken.
Stimmt, stimmt, stimmt, stimmt.
Alles klar, machen wir.
Also Leute, ähm, wenn ihr geile
Battlefield Clips habt, macht Ausrufezeichen
Battle Plays, dann kriegt ihr nen Link
zu nem Formular, wo ihr die Sachen
einschicken könnt. Ähm,
ich brauch noch 5, 6, 7
richtig gute Clips, dass ich das Video machen kann.
Äh, wir gucken uns jetzt mal an,
was wir schon haben.
Wir gucken uns an, was wir schon haben.
So.
Erstes Gameplay, was wir haben
hier, ist von
FoxDZN.
Schauen wir mal. Ich hab die Clips
alle schon mal gesehen.
Ähm, und ich weiß, dass ein paar Clips dabei
waren, die nicht so übertrieben krass
waren. Schauen wir mal.
Der schießt jetzt den Heli mit dem RPG
ab. Jaaaa.
Ja, das
alleine geht nicht als Topplay durch.
Das alleine geht nicht als Topplay
durch. Da hätte jetzt schon noch ein bisschen mehr kommen müssen.
Das hat, das hat jeder schon.
Irgendwann mal hingekriegt. Ich meine,
das war schon ein nicer Schuss mit dem RPG und hast
ihn weggebasht, aber so ein richtig
überkrasser Topplay, würde ich sagen,
hättest du jetzt beispielsweise
3, 4 schon davon geschickt und
mit ein bisschen, mit ein bisschen, mit ein bisschen
mehr Pep, dann hätte es, denke ich, gut reingepasst.
Aber so ist ein bisschen,
bisschen wenig.
Ähm,
wen haben wir denn hier als nächstes? Den Tribolon
haben wir da.
ThePantsMan.
Bam. Oh, das war aber
knapp, dass du den getroffen hast.
Der hat aber, der hat, der ist aber auch gut
direkt über dich drüber geflogen, ne?
Ne, Michael, ich such mir die selbst aus.
Muss schon
wissen, was ich da nehme.
Wie, das war's? Ein Heli
abgeschossen mit dem Panzer?
Ach, da muss jetzt noch was kommen, ja.
Okay, das müssen wir ein bisschen, müssen wir
ein bisschen straffen für das Video.
Oder wobei, vielleicht kann ich noch ein bisschen was zu
erzählen.
Ist das PS4?
Boah, da fliegen sie in die Luft, ja.
PS4
PS4-Aim.
So, die Van hat schön gebasht.
Im Panzer.
Wobei ich sagen muss,
dass das in, also wenn du jetzt
den Heli noch erwischst, wenn du jetzt den
Heli noch erwischst, dann,
dann geht's als Top-Play durch.
Okay.
Ja, das lass ich mir einfallen.
Das, das lass ich mir gefallen, das ist okay.
Weil, weil ansonsten zwei,
zwei Heli-Abschützer und ein bisschen Infanterie-Kills
ist wirklich, is, is nice.
Dazwischen war halt relativ normales, sagen wir mal,
Panzer-LMG-Gameplay, was du halt
hier als Defender auch mal ganz gut an der Stelle hast.
Aber das geht durch, das ist gut.
Next.
Was haben wir als nächstes hier?
Ein Troll, der mir mein eigenes Gameplay
geschickt hat. Ja, sehr, sehr schön.
Ähm.
Nochmal der Tribolon, hätte ich dazu zu sagen.
Oh, das Sound ist nicht ganz zünk, aber das kann ich fixen.
Ich weiß, wer der Troll war.
Ja, du wahrscheinlich. Haha.
Ahem.
Ich mach alle Top-Plays, die ungefähr
gleich gut sind.
Granate rein und fünf Stück auf einmal?
Nee, keiner.
Ah, den Clip kenn ich, den hab ich schon mal gesehen.
Den haben wir uns im Stream schon mal angeguckt.
Ab hier wird's, glaub ich,
jetzt recht cool, ja.
Da werden sie weggesprayt.
Jawoll.
PS4.
Und noch die
Legehände gemacht. Ja, das geht als Top-Play durch.
Aber auch nur,
weil noch die Legehände dabei war, hier.
Objective Play.
Ahem. Nicht schlecht.
So, was haben wir sonst noch?
Dann hab ich noch zwei Clips von der Hexe
am Start. Die gucken wir uns auch
noch an.
Lass gucken, wo die waren.
Die kann man gleich nehmen, ohne zu schauen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Wahrscheinlich.
Zack.
Oh, das ist, das ist halt in allen
Shooter immer das Beste. Treppen warten
geht überall.
Sei es in Halo, sei es in COD, sei es in CS,
sei es in Battlefield.
An der Treppe, in your face, ballern geht immer.
Zack.
Oh, da werden sie weggesprayt.
Das ist schon ein nicer Streak
hier am Start.
Oh, da kriegen sie auf den Sack.
Sehr nicer Streak.
Guck mal hier, 1400, irgendwas Punkte.
Haha.
1600 Punkte.
Nice.
Der Ingame Chat, lol, ja.
So, dann haben wir noch
eins von ihm.
Hab ich irgendwas übersehen?
OT. Wie viel würdest du als
Einstiegsgehalt als C-Sharp Developer
fair finden in einem mittelständischen
Unternehmen mit 50 Mitarbeitern? Schließt es dieses
Jahr die Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker
Anwendungsentwickler? Kommt
ein bisschen drauf an,
was du kannst
und mit welchen Technologien du fit bist.
Weil mit C-Sharp kannst du alles
machen. Vom
Web-Anwendungs-Backend zu Desktop-Anwendungen
zu Mobile, alles. Kommt ein bisschen
auf den Bereich an und natürlich das wichtigste ist,
wo in
Deutschland du bist.
Aber so wirklich den Gehalt kann ich dir da jetzt nicht
sagen aus dem Kopf. Du kannst dich aber
orientieren an irgendwelchen Umfragen, die es gegeben hat.
Also,
also in Frankfurt,
in
Frankfurt,
also wenn du Frankfurt und Umgebung, sag mal
du bist selbst in Frankfurt,
wo du kennst dich gut aus,
in Frankfurt suchen sie händeringend Leute,
ist schwierig.
Boah, das kann ich dir
ich kann dir da wirklich jetzt nix
jetzt nix sagen, wo auf
was du als Grundlage nehmen kannst,
damit die dich nicht verarschen
können. Du musst immer ein bisschen woanders gucken.
Kannst du jetzt echt grad nicht sagen.
45k
oder so? Ich hab einfach nur mal
was gesagt, ich hab keine, also musst du mal nachgucken.
StepStone hatte vor kurzem
ihren Gehaltsreport. Ja, da kann man gucken.
Das ist nicht verkehrt.
Okay, nächstes Gameplay von der Hexin.
Was macht der denn da?
Singleschuss.
Warum spielt er Singleschuss?
WTF?
Werden die verarschen, die Gegner,
oder was? Ich glaub,
ich glaub, der will die Gegner verarschen.
Der sagt, ich bin eh so viel, ich auch nur euch eh,
ich kann euch auch mit der AEK Singleschuss own.
Warum, warum
zum Geiler spielt er Singleschuss?
Das ist einfach nur, dass es geil aussieht, oder?
Flex, ja, denk ich auch.
Purer Flex.
Der Gegner checkt wieder gar nix.
In your face.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Der geht ja wieder richtig ab hier.
Vor allem Singleschuss, einfach weil's
geht wahrscheinlich.
Weil's geht.
Wo sind die Gegner alle hin?
Alle gebasht.
Alle weg.
Bam, in your face.
Sehr schön.
So.
Also die Clips von der Hexe nehmen wir auf jeden Fall schon mal.
Sind die Leute in Deutschland
eigentlich auch übelst am Stockpilen, ja?
Sind sie.
Okay, nächstes Gameplay haben wir jetzt von Logic.
In Deutschland nennt sich das
Hamsterkäufe.
Oh, vier Minuten, das ist ganz schön lang.
Krieg ich da wahrscheinlich nicht unter.
Da muss ich ein bisschen schneiden.
Oh, ist das
Ist das Xbox?
Das ist ja Grafik.
MonkaS Grafik.
Ach, er ist Attacker.
Aber es war trotzdem
ein guter Rush.
Und jetzt genau, oben auf die Kiste
und dann rüber gucken zu B.
Genau so geht das.
Warum kommen die Defender eigentlich von da?
Die Defender
sollten eigentlich von der anderen Seite kommen.
What?
Ach, er ist Defender.
Ich kack, Noob.
Na dann ist es jetzt,
dann ist jetzt Spawn, Spawnrape
angesagt. Nein, das kann ich nicht zeigen.
Spawnrape Gameplay, das kann ich nicht
zeigen.
Da regen sich die Leute wieder auf.
Mal gucken, was noch kommt.
Das sind wahrscheinlich mehrere Clips, denke ich mal.
Wobei, der Rush am Anfang und der,
das war schon, war schon nice.
Ja, kann man nichts sagen.
Ich frisch dir die Munition auf.
Beide Überschätzungen.
Wie, wie im echten
Krieg.
Ich frisch dir die Munition auf.
Ah, das ist Konsolen-Aim.
Kannst du nichts machen.
Was ist denn das eigentlich für eine Waffe?
Das ist die LMG.
Die LMG M16, oder?
M27, genau.
Mit Schalldämpfer.
Aber ist schon nice. Ist schon nice.
Muss man sagen. Ist schon nice. Ich meine, es ist übelst krasser
Spawnrape.
Aber ist nice.
Ah, jetzt kommt das nächste.
Oh, die Map. Man sieht so viel TDM
auf der Map. Die restliche Base sieht
man kaum.
Die deutsche, die deutsche Übersetzung.
Ja, ähm, hab nen feindlichen Flugabwehr
gesichtet. Ja, ähm, hab...
Oh Gott. Deswegen hab ich's immer auf
Englisch gespielt.
Habt ihr's gehört?
Ja, ähm...
AK-47 sieht man auch relativ selten in Battlefield 3.
Oh, da werden sie gesprayt.
Da werden sie gesprayt.
Das war auch cool an Battlefield 3.
Du konntest schon auf den Gegner draufhalten,
weil du wusstest, gleich steht der auf.
Aber nice ist weggespray.
Oh, jetzt kommt ne Runde Battlefield 4.
Shotgun-Action.
Oh, ist auch cool.
Haben wir jetzt gebasht.
Oh.
Gegner, wollt ihr euch vielleicht ein bisschen bewegen?
Ah, die Gegner.
Also, der Dude eben, der den Kopf
rübergestreckt hat. So geil.
So, hallo, ich bin auch da.
Der Typ war geil eben, oder?
Moment, das muss ich mir nochmal angucken.
Der jetzt gleich den Kopf da hoch...
Achtung, der jetzt gleich den Kopf hochstreckt.
OI!
Bäm, weg.
Bäm. Nice.
Alter, die Gegner.
Aber richtig gut.
Also, für Controller
kann man da...
Controller-Aim kann man da überhaupt nichts sagen.
Das ist für Controller ziemlich gut
geaimt. Guck mal, das auch hier.
Richtig nice.
Poggers Clips, Alter. Richtig Poggers Clips.
Da krieg ich fast schon
das Radio mit voll, ne?
Aber ich bräuchte noch so ein paar.
Bäm.
Aber die kriegen so viel ins Gesicht rein,
die Gegner, dass ich mit dem...
Das mit dem Controller ist schon cool.
Mit dem Controller ist das schon sehr nice.
Also, das war ein richtig, richtig,
richtig nicer Clip.
Der Name ist auch geil, ne? Irgendwie
Skriller? Ne.
Skiral...
So hieß man damals, ja?
So, ähm...
...
Ich will es ja nur mal mit dem...
Wir machen jetzt erstmal
das Twitch-only.
So, und jetzt haben wir...
Ich hab ihn schon im Chat gesehen.
Den No-Name-Drop.
Sechs Minuten!
Soll ich das alles unterbringen?
Uh...
Oh, der war cool!
Der war echt nice.
Aber der erste Hit war echt cool.
Ist das alles gleiche Map?
Gleiche Runde?
Das sind coole Hits.
Ah, jetzt ist das Sound weg.
WTF, das geht so schnell,
da blick ich überhaupt nicht mehr durch.
Okay, die ruckeln mir ein bisschen
stark.
Die sind ein bisschen ruckelig, die Clips.
Aber das ist ja lang genug, ist ja genug materialig.
Such einfach das raus, was gut passt.
Die Clips sind ein bisschen ruckelig gerade.
Ja, man sieht sofort, ne?
Das ist jetzt deutlich bessere Quali.
Okay, da muss ich mal gucken, wie ich die am besten
No-Name schnippel.
Wird besser, okay.
Wir gucken uns, wir gucken uns.
Oh, der war cool, der war nice durch die Häuser.
Das konntest du doch nicht wissen,
dass der Heli da rumstellst.
Du wusstest vielleicht irgendwo in welcher
Richtung.
Das war mal auf gut Glück und dann stand er da.
Aber das war trotzdem echt richtig, richtig
huge. Minimap, achso, okay.
Bam!
Was sind das? Dawnbreaker.
Oder auf deutsch, der Morgendämmerer.
Sind die zusammenhängen?
Nee, gell? Die sind manchmal, also das sind
alles schon unterschiedliche Runden.
Ja, da muss ich gucken.
Da muss ich gucken, wie man das
wie man das am besten zusammenschneidet.
Ich werd wahrscheinlich nicht alles nehmen.
Sondern die, die qualitativ am besten sind
und die, die hintereinander gut reinpassen.
Hast du noch mehr, sind da noch zusammenhängende
Clips drin oder sind das nur einzelne
einzelne TV-Missels?
Also nicht, dass
das schlechte Hits sind oder so.
Aber so ein bisschen zusammenhängend
wär nicht schlecht. Bam!
Und dann denkst du, also die kriegen schon ganz schön
auf den Sack.
Zusammenhängen ist schwer, keine Lust
20 Minuten Gameplay. Ja, das stimmt.
Aber es ist halt, es ist jetzt schwierig
da irgendwie
15 TV-Missels zu zeigen in Folge.
Ich muss mal gucken, wie ich
das, wie ich das einbaue.
Was kommt, was kommt denn sonst noch?
Heli-Heli-Heli-Heli-Stells?
Oh, Infanterie!
Bash. Als Übergang
zwischen den Clips, das ist
eine geile Idee.
Als Übergang zwischen den Clips, das ist, das ist
cool. Das ist eine gute Idee.
Ja, AT4
ist übelst heftig zu hitten in
ähm, in Battlefield 4.
Richtig schwierig.
Rekt. Der ist, der ist
auch schon reingeleckt.
Wow! Sound, please!
Ah, jetzt kommen ein paar Infanterie-Clips.
Hahaha!
Du bist nicht wirklich
hinter dem gesamten gegnerischen Team gespawnt
gerade, oder?
Das ist definitiv
ein Top-Clip!
Hahaha!
The fuck!
Hahaha! Das ist ja geil!
Also, ich nehme auf jeden Fall
die Infanterie-Clips und
ein paar TV-Missels, die kann man, denke ich, auch wirklich
gut so als Übergangs-Clip nehmen.
Ich bin halt
Heli-Main. Ja, merkt man,
du basht, also, die
sehen ja keine, keine, wie
sagt man so, keine Sonne, die Gegner.
Boah! Der ist
cool! Der ist richtig
cool! Der ist pock,
Alter, der ist, das ist nice!
Guck mal hier, durch den Ring durch!
Durch den Ring!
Das, das, der Swagshot, äh.
Schuh!
Hahaha!
Flup! Bam!
Nice!
Was geht denn das jetzt, wenn's fertig ist?
Okay, das ist auch, weil's geht, oder?
Einfach nur, weil's geht!
Das fand ich, das fand ich schick,
das fand ich sehr schicke Plays!
So, next!
Ähm, den haben wir denn hier?
K.U.S.
SWAT!
Oh, noch mehr Heli-Stells!
A.D.S. ist am Start!
Heli-Stells!
Ja, gut!
Jetzt, ich will's nicht schlechtreden,
ich weiß nicht, was, äh,
was, wie's, wie's weitergeht.
Das ist ein Clan War, ist das?
Woran erkennt
man das?
Nee, oder wenn ich mir die, die Tags
hier oben angucke, sieht doch ganz
normal aus.
Die sind mega alt.
Ich mein, das ist bestimmt ein ziemlich nicer
Gunner Streak.
Aber ich kann mich halt noch dran erinnern,
dass wenn man, wenn man, ähm,
einen guten,
einen guten Pilot hat, ist es als Gunner
jetzt nicht soo ultra schwierig
nicer Streaks zu machen.
Wegen der TV-Missle?
War da schon ne TV-Missle?
Oder kommt die noch?
Die kommt noch, oder?
Nee, ich bevorzuge weder,
nee, nee, nee, also Battlefield, ist mir egal,
Bad Company 2, Battlefield 3,
Battlefield 4, wenn man was richtig krasses
hat, meinetwegen auch Battlefield 1 und 5.
Aber am liebsten sind mir Bad Company
2, 3 und 4 Clips, weil da kann ich halt aus
erster Hand was zu sagen, weil ich alles viel gespielt hab.
Und Hardline, Hardline geht auch.
Was ist denn das für ne Map überhaupt?
Ist das die Radarschüssel?
Ist das die Radarschüssel-Map?
Ich erkenne das,
ich erkenne nämlich nur Terminal-Kamera.
Ach, Goldmuth ist das.
Ernsthaft? Ich erkenne da nix.
Ich zieh bloß
Turbosider.
Ich find's cool, dass man hört, was Team
Ah, bam, in your face.
Eigentlich eher in your Rotor.
Ja doch, jetzt erkennt man's.
Das ist ganz hinten auf der Map.
Oh, das war ein huge
Missile. Boah!
Der war cool!
Pog Rocket.
Also der Jethit eben, der war echt
nice.
Ah, du hast ja noch irgendwie gefühlt, äh,
hast du mir die Playlist
geschickt? Oder wolltest du mir nur den einen
Clip schicken? Oder, oder,
oder die komplette Playlist?
Nur, nur dass ich's jetzt nicht, äh,
dass ich
die Sachen nicht übersehe.
Nur der eine Clip, oder? Oder war's
zufällig, dass du den einen Clip geschickt hast?
Also nur, nur den Clip, okay.
Okay, nächster.
Nächster Clip.
Jetzt von
Mr.
Ares
Airskill
Ah nee, immer noch K.O.S.
SWAT. Wenn ich den, wenn ich den Channel
jetzt einfach noch, ja muss ich den Clip
jetzt, okay, noch mal, noch mal einen.
Was haben wir hier jetzt? Infantry Gameplay.
Mit,
boah, die Quali ist, ist
ist
bisschen, bisschen schwierig gerade.
Man erkennt nicht viel.
Ist das Dragon Pass?
Nee, nicht Dragon Pass, nee, wie hieß
das? Oh, man erkennt, man
erkennt wenig. Man erkennt,
dass die Gegner gut gebasht werden.
Das ist die Community Map?
Die Gegner werden gut gebasht.
Wenn man jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr erkennen würde,
das wird im Handy abgefilmt,
oder? Nee, ich kenne das.
Das ist einfach, das ist, bei dir hat,
bei dir hat das bestimmt gute Quali, oder?
Hat das bei dir gute Quali?
Ich gehe davon aus, es liegt einfach
am Rendern. Oder hat das
auch schon im Ausgangsmaterial so komische Quali?
Man erkennt wirklich wenig.
Erst mal weggedefied.
Es könnte von der Optik
fast eine Bad Company 2 Map sein, ne?
Mit dem Dschungel. Also die Gegner werden schon
gut gebasht. Re, oh, Alter.
Jetzt ging's auf den Sack von hinten.
Habt ihr das gehört?
Er hat gerade gesagt, er hat den nächsten Clip
für eine Montage.
Ja, passt auf jeden Fall gut.
Wenn man irgendwie das mit der Quali noch hinkriegen
könnte, kannst du mal schauen,
also der Clip ist mega nice, ja?
Ich würde dich sofort nehmen,
den Clip. Hast du
irgendwie die Chance, das nochmal aufzunehmen
in besserer Quali, oder ist die Ursprungs-Quali
schon so verpixelt?
Aber gut, wenn es vier Jahre alt ist,
kannst du es nicht nochmal capturen, dann hast du es wahrscheinlich nicht mehr, ne?
Ja, okay.
Da muss ich mal gucken.
Vielleicht, oh, ne.
Mal gucken, vielleicht kann man irgendwie so
Splitscreen machen mit zwei Sachen.
Da kann man das Video nämlich verkleinern
und dann sieht das nicht mal so pixelig aus.
Mal gucken, mal gucken, ob mir dazu was einfällt.
Wenn nicht, ja, mal gucken.
Mal gucken, was mir dazu einfällt.
AI, genau, wir machen
wir machen einfach in Azure
in Azure Upscaling Server und da lassen wir
AI enhanced
äh, schärfen und upscalen.
Und dann sieht das alles wieder wie gestochen aus.
Wir machen den CSI Enhanced Mode an.
Das müsste ich, aber das müsste ich eh
auch ein bisschen zusammen, zusammenschnibbeln.
Was ist denn das überhaupt für
ne Map? Äh, für ne, für ne,
für nen Spielmodus?
Das ist einer der
30.000 Battlefield 4 Spielmodi, die
keiner mehr spielt, ne?
Chainlink, ach stimmt, das war ja mal
ein Ding.
Das spielt keiner mehr.
Und ich glaube, ich bin nicht
sofort dabei, du kannst Ausrufezeichen
Battle Plays machen, da kriegst du das
Formular, äh, wo man die Sachen einschicken kann.
Also richtig
nice ist Gameplay, leider ist die Quali
nicht so gut.
So, wen haben wir denn als nächstes?
Nochmal!
Wieviel hast du denn geschickt?
Moment, hä?
Hast du zweimal das gleiche geschickt?
Ne.
Doch.
Du hast zweimal das gleiche
geschickt, glaub ich.
Hier ist noch einer.
Oh, da werden sie gesprayt, jawoll.
Bam!
Oh, der war cool.
Das ist so ein kurzknackiges Ding, sowas, sowas
geht immer. Ich hab die Sniper
verpasst.
Okay.
Welches?
Welches davon ist
das? Oder, oder
in dem Gameplay von eben?
Battle Plays musst du machen, warte mal hier.
In dem von eben?
Okay, guck ich
nochmal. In dem da?
Wo ist die
Sniper-Action?
Ah, hier! Ah, da kommt noch was hin!
Bam!
Locker, locker geht immer.
Die Gegner!
Die Gegner, was ist mit denen wieder los?
Was ich gerade mache, ich gucke
mir gerade Videos an,
um, äh, Battlefield, also
ich will ein Battlefield-Video machen mit
Clips, die Leute eingeschickt haben.
Und ich gucke halt mir die Clips an.
Bam! Was ist mit den
Gegnern los?
Du kannst sie ja immer direkt ins Gesicht ballern
aus nächster Nähe.
Gleich kommt noch der 360 zum Abschluss.
Nice.
Wird ge-
quickscoped!
So, next. Wen haben wir denn
sonst noch hier zu bieten?
Hatten wir schon. So, hier, einen haben wir noch.
Tobi Tiger.
Der hat eben gerade erst was eingeschickt.
Den Clip kenne ich noch nicht.
Hoffen wir mal, dass es jetzt hier kein
G-Baited ist.
Ach, der Dr. Kabu!
Okay, das ist alt.
Das ist alt. Das ist definitiv
uralt, dieser Clip.
Oh, nicer Shot.
Ich glaube, das nehme ich allein schon deswegen rein,
weil es doch so ein olles Gameplay ist.
Das ist Battlefield 3, oder?
Oh, das ist Battlefield 4?
Ich kann jetzt den Unterschied überhaupt nicht mehr erkennen.
Vier? Drei?
Doch, drei, ne?
Das sieht man an den Perks, sieht man das unten.
Nice.
Wir haben fast genug Clips.
So zwei, drei richtig
gute Clips wären noch
echt nice.
Äh, Moni, überhaupt keine Hektik.
Muss ich nicht beeilen.
Falls wir das bis heute Mittag und Nachmittag
irgendwie noch zusammen kriegen, nehme ich es vielleicht
heute noch auf, dass ich dann die nächste Woche hochladen kann.
Aber es waren ein paar nicer Sachen
dabei, muss man echt sagen.
Huge.
POC Airs.
Leute, es war wieder ein
wahnsinnig nicer Stream.
Ähm.
Ich guck gerade, ob jemand da ist, den wir hosten können.
Aber sieht nicht so aus.
Keiner da?
Gut. Ähm.
Hast du selber noch irgendwelche unused Footage?
Bestimmt.
Irgendwo auf irgendeiner externen Platte.
Aber das finde ich im Leben nicht.
So, jetzt ist die große
Preisfrage. Was machen wir
jetzt? Wie gesagt, ich wollte
eigentlich nachher noch einen Stream machen, wo
wir mal ein neues
Android auf dem
Raspberry Pi ausprobieren.
Aber es ist jetzt schon fast 15 Uhr
und ich war jetzt schon
viereinhalb Stunden
und ich habe schon ganz trockenen Hals.
Vielleicht machen wir das einfach
morgen Abend. Mal gucken.
Vielleicht machen wir das heute, aber dann
nicht vor 17, 18 Uhr. Oder
wir machen es morgen. Mal gucken.
Ist euch eigentlich aufgefallen, dass wir
drei Corona Emotes haben?
Ja, wir haben Monka Corona,
Fields Corona Man und
Corona.
Also die wichtigen Sachen.
Wobei ich ja
den Fields
Corona am besten finde.
Trockener Hals, jaja.
So sieht's aus.
Ja, schön, dass ihr alle dabei gewesen seid.
Wir sehen uns dann entweder heute Abend
so 17, 18 Uhr.
Ähm.
Betreibst du zufällig Home Office?
Es ist Sonntag.
Kekrona.
Oh, das ist gut. Das gibt's bestimmt schon.
Emote.
Ne.
Anscheinend nicht.
Also entweder heute 17, 18 Uhr
oder morgen Abend probieren wir das dann mit dem
Raspberry Pi und Android aus.
Und schön, dass ihr
alle dabei gewesen seid. Wir sehen uns nächstes Mal.
Bis dann. Macht's gut. See you.
Tschüss.